the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club pieces are flying off the boards at
the St Louis rapid and Blitz with the
rapid portion behind them Blitz
Specialists work to rack up as many
points as possible Blitz Legend Maxim
Basher lrav went on a tear storming up
the standings to jump into clear first
place however it's not a one-horse race
with multiple Chasers hot on heels MBL
is one of the fastest players on the
planet can he keep up the pace or will
he be caught the final day of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to the final day of the S Louis
rapid and blit players are tired but
still they need to make fast moves let's
make a fast move to the studio and get
the day
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America the St Louis chess club
proudly presents a St Louis rapid and
Blitz it all comes down to today and it
starts right
now nine rounds of intense and
entertaining Blitz and we will have a
winner today welcome everyone I'm
International Master T Sav and alongside
me the one and only grandm yasa San and
the legend himself Peter swiler Tanya is
brilliant to be in studio with you both
Peter you're looking exceptionally
dapper today I like the three piece
look what a day we had yesterday yes lot
of switch UPS in our leaderboard should
we take a look at the standings going
into this well first let me say hello to
everybody hello everyone and uh thank
you for joining us for the St Louis
rapid and Blitz yes indeed as Tanya was
mentioning we had a fantastic day one of
Blitz today the players will reverse
colors at one time there was a five-way
tie for first but one MBL went on an
amazing winning streak and uh separation
at the top Tanya do the honors and tell
us the current standings after four days
of rapid and Blitz let's take a look
yasa we had a switch up in the time
control in the middle of the tournament
and this was a Bo for some and Bane for
others we haday Robson taking away the
rapid but he slipped down to a tie for
fifth position having a bad day on day
one of the blitz but look at that at the
top Maxim vasher lra scoring a fantastic
seven out of nine on day one is at the
top of the leaderboard with a twoo
margin leading ahead of Fabiano Karana
and Yana pushi Yan one of those players
who had a fantastic swap from his
performance in the rapid going into the
blitz exactly well those are the
standings after the rapid and Blitz tell
us about the standings in the grand
chest tour currently and these are
extremely important because these are
our season standings and we see that
Fabby who's tied for a second in the St
Louis rapid and Blitz is leading the
tour with a 20 grand chest points
$120,000 uh in earnings he's going to be
playing in the sink field CL cup which
will be the final event and my eyes uh
yes are on that position for and tied
for six Maxim and Yan if they're able to
get in those very crucial points today
they have a chance to leave frog Fabby
in the overall standings provided that
Fabby doesn't keep his currently uh
second position in the rapid and Blitz
and uh tell us about the format let's
take a look and once again the players
will be fighting against each other in
nine rounds but the colors will be
reversed from day one it's a point for
win a half a point for a draw and zero
for a loss and my favorite part no draw
offers absolutely it's early days but in
case of a playoff Tam you let's take a
look if there is a playoff it will
happen today right after our final game
if two players are tied for first if
they have equal number of points at the
end of the nine rounds they will play a
mini two game rapid match with 10 plus 5
if it is still tied it goes into an
Armageddon which means 5 minutes for
white four 4 minutes for black and of
course black gets result odds white gets
the extra time on the clock no increment
flagging is encouraged heavily in that
one and yes if there are more than three
players who are tied at the top of the
leaderboard at the end of the day then
they will play against each other in a 5
+ 3 second increment wow well uh we'll
hold our breaths for the playoffs and
again this is it this is our final day
of play the schedule it is yes uh and it
has been Fantastic 4 days and we've LED
ourselves to this a very very fun day of
Blitz one more time nine games before we
have a winner we've seen the form these
players are bringing in we've seen the
turnarounds the roller coaster we had on
day one and we're expecting more of that
today absolutely Peter it's been a
tournament of decisive games it's been
truly remarkable ab and uh yesterday
broke all records in in terms of
decisive percentages even with the last
round featuring a very very low two
decisive games out of five as you will
see on your screen right now we have a
whopping 80% decisive uh uh games uh in
they won three rounds of no draws
whatsoever and the special mention has
to go to Yan pishi who made zero draws
in his nine games yesterday six wins and
three losses very very exciting game of
chess Day of Chess and I suspect today
will be pretty much the same and now we
go to our tournament leader who uh
yesterday started by winning his first
game then he lost to Yan one of Yan's
early victims but then went unbeaten for
the rest of the day won an additional
five games and is now two points clear
of the he field in clear first had a
very very good
yesterday and now we have a very nice
graphic for you this is the standings
after the rapid portion with Ray Robson
on top there and three players we've
chosen seemingly at trandom and now
through the magic of television as yasa
likes to say look at what happened to
these four people Ray Robson who led the
tournament after rapid as you can see
has had a bit of a nightmare uh and the
other three have have had a very very
good day Maxim scored seven points Yan
and Wesley scored six out of nine they
all improved their standings a great
deal and uh once again Maxim by far the
happiest of the
field and now my favorite part of the
day I get to introduce Anastasia carich
Grandmaster who is uh in the studio
watching uh watching the action good
morning
n good good morning everyone good
morning yeran and Peter it's been a
great day so far and yesterday of course
social media was booming Maxim gra is
the leader his fans were congratulating
him on this result but of course it's
not over and V un former world champion
also published a tweet uh mentioning
that Maxim dominated the first day of
Blitz and of course he couldn't pass by
this brilliancy uh with knights uh he
mentioned that some lovely Knights moves
were made in the game with Maxim V and
Wesley so we all know how that that
actually vishan himself likes Knights
and he prefers them to Bishops and this
game was really remarkable game of
yesterday so also we had a very nice uh
photo shooting uh our official
photographer Leonard totis made really
nice shots of Maxim this is how you feel
when you lead the tournament and uh so
really nice pictures of Maxim from
yesterday you can see them on the screen
and please don't forget to follow our
flicker account gror Flicker and you can
find more pictures there if you're still
actually wondering what players are
doing between the rounds stop wondering
just follow our social media accounts
and you will get the first throw of the
backstage uh of grandest tour with all
players you know you will see them
chatting with each other you will also
notice what they they eat between the
games and many many other things so now
it's time to get back to the studio
thank you Anastasia I agree
wholeheartedly with the social media
that night E5 that deserves a t-shirt
Tanya it's such a beautiful move it it's
a visual right it deserves all kinds of
merch get that position on a t-shirt get
it on the mark get it on your wall what
a move that was it also feel so good
when you finish a game like that does oh
it's very very impressive uh tell our
audience what they can expect for round
10 of Blitz coming up we've got pairings
we've got our matchups and we start the
day with this action in front of us
Jeffrey Jong taking on Sam savian Wes
liso who scored six out of nine points
on day one will start the day against
Fabiano Carana an incredibly important
match not only for the tournament
standings but also for our tour
standings and of course the M uh our
Marquee match up there uh yes Maxim
vasher lra the tournament leader takes
on Liam Le the players are in their
seats ready to go action is on and they
started boy they didn't even give us a
chance to go through the entire pairings
as we do have um a uh a lapen right C2C
3 uh Sicilian in the game between mvl
and Liam uh Liam coming into this event
once again as a well card he is the
coach at uh the local University here
Webster University and he has a fan base
in St Louis you can't believe they are
cheering them on and coach was leading
through five rounds of Rapid so he's
really had a very nice event so far uh
I'm used to seeing white actually
getting in an earlier D2 D4 than I
currently have and this move C5 C4
basically said i' like to gain some
space now if I play D4 right away
there'll be an aasan what do you think
about B2 B3 which was played
really nicely pointed out you want to
get out of this cramp hole clamp hole
that black has with the Moose C4 so that
you can advance the D Pawn exactly you
need to develop your Bishop need to get
the pieces out so B3 there as you
pointed out and the Knight comes out
putting more pressure on C4 and are
really asking black to take a decision
about what you want to do with that c
Pawn Yeah if you do capture if black is
obliged I'm not saying he is but if you
if black does capture C4 takes B3 A2
takes B3 The Rook has developed my Pawn
structure has a little bit more
influence in the center he's done it
he's captured and so I would feel that
white is the one for choice now on the
other hand uh Peter will be sitting
there arguing his grunfeld Bishop is uh
has an unobstructed View and therefore
black uh should also be uh pleased with
the outcome uh quick knee-jerk uh no I
agree with you I think white starts
being a little bit by by being a little
bit bit better but black does have
Dynamic counterplay e75 break needs to
be watched constantly the pawn on C3 is
a bit soft you could maybe play against
it Bishop G4 followed by some kind of a
break in a center is playable but
structurally I would very much take
white here right Tanya I would agree
with that and especially because uh
traditional chess wisdom you've managed
to put one of your side pawns towards
the center the a pawn has moved towards
B3 you've opened up the a line for your
Rook so it's already in the game Watch
Out for threats of that knight from A3
jumping on to B5 hitting the queen
hitting the pawn uh it looks like the
Trump and Black's position is that
Bishop so as Peter said you want to get
E5 to open the position but if I had to
pick a color at the moment I would want
to be white in this position exactly me
too Rook on F1 to E1 uh has my attention
I like the idea of putting pressure and
Peter mentioned that E7 E5 is the
dynamic that black will be uh looking
for uh times it just feels like the
players are playing a little bit slowly
or uh what's who's who's used more time
it's about Level under four minutes for
both these players it's the start of the
day yes they're just getting into the
groove and the they got to warm up and
by the way uh for those of you who don't
know Liam is a former World Blitz
Champion very very deserving was it 2014
2013 World BL
Champion so he's been round he he know
he's he's he not to be taken lightly not
at all he's the winner of so many Elite
events in the Chess World a spee CH
specialist as you mentioned a former
world champion as well and he's not a
household name like Maxim vasher lra
like Anish gir or Yan pesi but when he's
fighting with these guys in a tournament
he's fighting on equal ground every
single game exactly and he's he's
acquitted himself well 13 and a half
points he shows that he actually belongs
in this field a wild card maybe but
definitely a competitive one at that uh
when the two Bishops uh Peter mentioned
C3 is a little bit soft and Liam's
wasting no time bringing his Rook to the
C file to eyeball that pawn now here's
an interesting moment right here you
have the move he did Play Bishop E4 I
was about to say you have to move Knight
C4 and it's not
something that you really want to do
double the pawns on the C file but if
you think about Knight C4 try trade I am
opening up my Rook I am threatening
Bishop A3 potentially C5 potentially D5
he didn't do it he went Bishop E4 and
after Queen D7 yes that's a surprise
move Queen D7 Bishop to G5 so the two
Bishops are beginning to exert
themselves absolutely and and the reason
he moved back to Queen the queen to D7
is to get out of these Knight jumps that
you're pointing out Knight B5 Knight C4
it's a prophylactic move I like what
white has done here Bishop G5 it's
against the idea of the E Pawn advancing
to E5 because that really is the dream
for black to break open the center to
open up that monstrous Bishop on G7 so
with Bishop G5 at least that stopped for
the time being exactly Knight D5 and
again the soft C3 Pond also kind of
inviting white now bring his Knight into
uh you have to have a good reply to B7
B5 though this is the question now how
do you reply to B5 and will show us in a
moment asked and we're about to find the
answer Knight E3 of course will hang the
pawn on C3 don't forget the bishop on G5
B the desirable Bishop takes D5 Queen
takes D5 also reminds white that you've
got two pieces hanging the bishop on G5
and the Knight on C4 uh Tanya this is a
this is a good question it's a tricky
question and Knight E3 I think is the
most obvious uh the most human response
in the position I was thinking about
Knight jumping to A5 but the C3 Pawn was
hanging it still hangs but now you take
and he's showing us the way Knight C3 is
there a knight jump I was thinking
Knight goes to G4 and you're looking at
counter play but I also see the D4 Pawn
is hanging precisely Knight takes D4
that's
a a devastating threat so there was no
question that Bishop takes C6 had to be
done and I guess we're about to see the
the the we probably start by taking A7
and then geted right you that gets
traded that gets traded that gets traded
cuz if we start by taking on E7 Rook D7
becomes an interesting reply I think so
there is Bishop takes E7 Rook D7 Bishop
C5 probably we're just going to equalize
somehow yeah but it doesn't feel like
we're playing for a win so I think
starting with S I think makes a great
deal of sense and that's what he's done
yes Rook takes A7 I'm assuming we're
about to see Rook takes well wait a
minute sorry Rook takes D4 Rook Rook
check would be devastating devastating
followed by Bishop H6 so I actually have
to play Bishop takes D4 and that will be
a Tempo Against The Rook Rook takes E7 I
don't know Tanya but to my eyes three
versus three one versus one ooh f 7
F6 uh Liam saying wait a minute I'm not
willing to uh just make a a easy draw I
want to see D5 probably is a good
intermediate move here for white well
the problem is any Bishop Retreats are
met by Rook takes D4 mhm and this gets
out of the Rook check problem because
we've now made Le for our King but you
said D5
mhm
D5 although in the end there there's
Bishop f8 my idea was if everything gets
straighted I want to take on E7 with the
Rook which is currently on the back rank
attacking the bishop on G7 but black
does have Bishop f8 at the very end and
I have The Rook hanging and my Bishop on
G5 is still hanging so Maxim is actually
this I think why he hasn't played D5 yet
he also got to this point and realized
his he doesn't have an easy uh easy way
out and you're not picking your Bishop
back up because one of the Rooks will
slide over to the file and easily defend
the bishop sove F7 F6 has caused a
stop stoppage and it's Liam whoa Bishop
F4 Rook takes Knight H6 Knight G4 for
now yeah this is this is a piece but a
very very interesting one I think we can
take and then play Bishop f8 but Liam
says no I want to protect the E7 Pawn
goes kn9 D5 very understandable Liam is
playing a fabulous control game move
Knight D5 defends the pawn on E6 s
stopping these ideas of Rook takes by
the way the bishop is hanging H5 is on
tap Rook A8 check how does that help
we're not sure I guess he wants to play
Knight H6 check but that end game will
still be very very unpleasant because
there's G5 in the end Knight H6 check
Bishop takes H6 Bishop takes H6 and as
you said G5 in the end just sidest
stepping Rook f8
mate uh Bishop E3 Tanya I have to say
I'm very impressed by Liam's play in
this game it's been in the meantime s
Sam svan has won his first round game
with black against Jeffrey Shong
congratulations m in one that was
threatened and stopped with G5 vacating
a square for the king H4 and that's a
second Pawn that's a second Pawn alert
take it if there's a third Pawn hanging
Maxim's getting desperate right now AG
four it's uh it feel safe feel safe
sorry yeah yes you're absolutely right I
think there's been incredible technique
here that Liam has shown in the first
round against the tournament leader
jumps up with The Rook uh Maxim's trying
to create play against Black's King here
exactly and it just feels like there's
enough places to for for for the king to
to hide and by the way I love this move
H3 it's not that the pawn H the doubled
H Pawn was playing a significant role
but if I can force G takes H3 Rook takes
H3 I can get rid of the bishop and swipe
yet another Pawn on the queen side H3
love it G3 and what does alpha zero say
about pawns on H6 and H3 they can
Checkmate you and here we go uh you
you're right desper Desperado uh checks
for white and Liam is about to play King
F5 and say do your worst I'm not going
to take your bishop and fall for a
Checkmate King F5 and it's our clock of
factor is the clock a factor it's uh the
touching the 30 second Mark for both
players but that's a whole bunch of
extra pawns for black and it felt that
Lamb made it look so easy snapping up
Pawn after Pawn right uh the pawn on H3
makes sure that the white Rook is stuck
on E1 not allowing black to double up on
the first Rank and another Pawn's grab
gives up the H3 Pawn but that B Pawn can
get decisive very quickly exactly and
once who's going for who's King once
again Liam is playing
absolutely fantastic I mean just this is
great stuff and and he's the tournament
leader it's over uh he had to he had to
stop a Checkmate coming on the file I'm
just going to quickly uh update my board
I apologize but there was a Checkmate on
H2 after Rook check and Rook H2 so 9 G6
now creates maybe an Unstoppable threat
of Rook check on the third rank a check
followed by I think we start with 96
actually perfect so we do have and by
the way 97 came with a gain of tempo so
you're suggesting Knight G6 he gives a
check first and defends the B5 pawn and
there are meeting ideas is Knight G6
always in the a so The Rook needs to
stay on H1 to guard the uh H2 file H2
square and now
uh Rook H3 is also a threat if the Rook
moves KN G6 it was a check Knight G6
check mate is a knight G6 and Rook H3
Checkmate that's a coming and 10 seconds
Jack he made a move still Knight G6 Rook
H3 ideas how do you fight against Rook
H3 I think it's over it's over because
if you go Rook H1 Knight G6 King H5 Rook
H3 and that's handshakes mate was
inevitable wow our congratulations to to
Sam but we're going to go to the Fabby
game as oh and the players are playing
with two seconds on the clock so o
somebody just checkm Wesley blundered a
rook with the last move of the game he
blundered a full rook and resigned sorry
Ray Robson versus neppo it looks like
black young should be winning here yeah
Black's A2
Pawn oh there's a fork those tricky
nights jumping all over and it's also
going to be a queen not just the L of
and both Fabian Yan win and mvl loses a
one point onepoint game now uh there was
a twoo match a two two two-point
difference pardon me between mvl our
tournament leader and the pursuers and
it's it it it's narrowed uh Ali Raza was
two and a half points behind MV but Ali
Raza
won oh I'm it's a black black day black
started really
well with the black pie black is more
than okay absolutely in this round and
once again we see the same story we
start with very few draws shall we call
it that and I start with this game
between Ray robs and yanish in which Yan
played a very fashionable line here
isoing the the classical vienas with
Bishop B4 just going B5 here E5 Knight
D5 Knight B5 Knight B6 where you get
this very strange structure with black
doubled uh C pawns and the pawn andy4
seemingly very weak but you get a lot of
P play for for the breakage of your
structure and then uh if we continue
forward all of this is I think this is
already not theoretical but in general
there is a lot of uh finesses here
available to both Sid sides somewhere
around here uh I thought Ray was doing
really well and he is doing well to a
degree but not not that great the threat
of Knight G5 is extremely annoying
forced Yan to give up a second Bishop
but Knight A4 was a very very important
detail here immediately attacking the
pawn on B2 I wonder if Ray perhaps could
have tried not tra trading B2 for C4 but
what he chose was uh this
position and uh already you can see the
outlines of how the this could become a
problem for white because this bishop on
E3 is not very active the pawn on E3
could become a Target and as we've seen
in the game eventually this became a
quein uh and if we go forward it
actually became pretty sharp pretty
quick uh because he gave up on A3 to
play D5 and D6 which I think is very
strong opening up his Bishop picking up
the the pawn on G7 and this is a very
sharp position which the engine
initially assesses as equal but Yan I
think just controlled it better in time
trouble and some some pawns as you can
see uh here uh let's say if if we look
at this position the king is cut off on
the back Rank and you still have to
solve of this all of these problems but
five mons later these pawns has
progressed the the king is about to come
off the back Rank and eventually it ends
up somewhere around the B3 Square as you
can see in the final position it's all
the way over there right the a pawn is
queening and and black is and black is
completely winning another game that
black won is the game between Anish giri
and ala fua which which featured a very
classical iqp type position with white
having this isolated Pawn on D4 and it
seemed like Anish played you know a very
logical normal game he he he got two
Bishops he got this seemingly annoying
pin along this diagonal but uh
eventually the pin was broken and once
you get to some position like this I
think you start preferring black unless
white can immediately play D4 D5
somewhere and equalize but this didn't
happen this trade on of the bishop which
was the the light Square Bishop for the
Knight solidified the structure with the
black having by far the better a bishop
white still has this weakness on D4 and
uh black continued improving and as you
can see white hasn't lost any material
but the position looks visually much
worse than it did five five moves ago
and black continued making progress uh
and eventually as you can see uh ala
infiltrated via the back Rank and
basically gave mate so uh here uh Anish
resigned because Queen G5 wherever the
King goes Queen G5 is made in one thank
you Peter for that uh Tanya update our
standings five black winds I'm not used
to seeing that one what happened well
the standings might look very similar to
how we started the day but notice how
the margin for the leader has reduced
and that is what Blitz is about get on
that hot streak and you could see a
completely different leaderboard and
Maxim still with 17 points Fabby Yan
still tied for a second but with just a
onepoint difference Ali Resa also at
just half a point behind this fight is
getting close and eight more games to go
thank you Tanya and Anastasia tell us
about some of the games that we may have
missed I kept my eye on the game uh
between wesl and Fabiano caran you
caught the moment that the end of the
game actually and you remember from
yesterday Fabby was telling that he's
kind of fighting for the second place
only but now we see that the Gap was
just one point and he managed to win
against Wesley in the first round so it
started all with D4 D5 and here Wesley
was stuck for some moments probably he
was choosing what to play he played
bishop4 it seemed like London but I
don't know the consequences of moves
didn't uh really go for the main lines
of London and um both players probably
were experimenting and here Fabby
decided to play D Tak C4 entering very
interesting position it seems like he
was in a quite aggressive mood and um
tried to you know even though the
position was like about equal he was
still looking for some chances he pushed
his Pawn on a pawn all the way to A4
trying to get some squares on the queen
side Wesley was trying to do something
in the center played like F3 um hoping
to play probably E4 at certain point uh
but I wanted to show one moment when
Fabi played the tricky move G5 you know
again trying to you know make things a
little bit crazy on the board and here
West had a very interesting opportunity
he could have played this interesting
move E4 and after Bishop B4 suddenly
this bishop on H4 is trapped but it's
not that easy I mean black still could
continue with some moves like Rook D4
trying to grab as many pawns as possible
and still I mean it's very unclear
position in my opinion even though Wy
has this extra piece um in the game so
but Wesley didn't play this move they
didn't have much time at this moment and
you could see what happened after it was
some kind of battle where I think Wesley
was better at certain point here I mean
he pwn up and um but still the fact that
black has Bishop sometimes I mean helps
in the situation even with the pawn down
uh and you saw the ending he just
blundered The Rook but let me show you
what actually happened because it was
very f after move F5 um white has to
take on F5 with the Knight because there
is no other move for the king so Knight
F5 and here black um wins the full rook
and Wesley resigned uh the second game I
was checking was the game between um two
players for American players Jeffrey
Jong and Sam Sean um maybe you remember
what happened yesterday it was
absolutely crazy game when Sean seven
won actually and um I I'm sure that
Jeffrey was hoping for revenge in this
one but it didn't happen so we I I would
like to show you a few few moments in
this game um he made this very trick I
mean was very normal you know English
opening everything was kind of fine
white got some certain kind of
comfortable position and then somewhere
here yes I would like to show this M
Knight D7 uh was played by uh s and he
created this small trap Bishop before
and suddenly um it seems like Jeffrey
didn't notice it so he played Bishop G2
move and after Bishop B before he just
lost in exchange and the position became
very bad um he maybe had some hopes to
create something on the king side he
played G4 but after a very very strong
move um like Rook E2 and E5 he had to
resign because after move Knight F5
there is this Rook D3 move and um where
to go with your queen I mean after Queen
C1 you lose your queen after Rook D1 so
he just resigned here and um um Sam S
won the game and I think he won this
kind of mini match between those two as
well so we are going back to the
studio What A Swindle Wesley was up a
pawn and he had a cold shower moment
that move F7 F5 through the magic of
Television let's just take a look at
that moment when Fabby won a game where
again he could have been Mater he was
material down uh through most of it here
just take a look I mean you don't expect
Wesley so to lose this position right I
mean it's equal material now that the
Pawn's been picked up but the B Pawn is
under Fire and I absolutely agree with
you and it was a right about in just a
few seconds and look at the clock as
well 3 seconds for Fabby Wesley has
those extra seconds and Fabby sets up
this position right now it doesn't look
like it's going to happen but that white
king feeling a bit unsafe there cut off
just a little bit and but check this out
Knight takes B5 and what A Swindle
taking away the H5 Square okay
so H5 check and here it comes this is
over loaded and that would be Checkmate
white has to capture the pawn The Rook
is on pre and it is handshakes What A
Swindle that was just oh Peter you just
feel like they will they will sting for
Wesley because Wesley was mounting a
kind of a quiet recovery with six out of
nine he started at a very low point but
with MBA losing the first game you would
feel that maybe he's in a running for
top three but losing this position will
not be a happy and for Fabby that was uh
impressive um we got a another round of
Blitz coming up I mean it it happened so
fast tell us about the pairings if we
have them for this round 11 we will uh
start with round 11 action and this is
what we have stop the pr play look at
that third board pairing
with tied for a second who started with
a win takes on the tournament leader
Maxim vasher lra who started with a loss
right can Maxim recover from the first
round loss Will Yana pushi be able to
keep up the streak that he's been on in
the blitz uh prediction times Peter
that's clearly our Mary matchup what's
going to happen uh in terms of
tournament Intrigue I'm very much team
Yan and also this is my fantasy pick so
very easy for me to pick white in this
game yeah bias opinion yes uh no draws I
don't know who's going to win but no
draws I would agree with that and that's
also because of their style of play yes
both uh make Dynamic decisions and
obviously this is blitz so in general we
will have far fewer draws than a longer
time format but we can expect a big fun
fight between these two combative
players and of course it's not only
going to be a fight here but later on as
well when ex S field Cup starts right
after the St Louis rapid and Blitz well
November 21st to December 1st uh put
that in your schedule this is the
granddaddy of the M the tournament we're
incredibly proud of we think it's the
strongest event in the world maybe only
the candidates competes but this is it
and the roster players are simply
outstanding absolutely look at that
Stella stos Ali Resa fanana yan yan dud
Wes Maxim
Leonardo and lenia Domingas fighting it
out in the sink field cup the final
event of the grand frest our 2023 season
to Crown the eventual winner exactly we
will be missing unfortunately world
champion ding Len but the wild card
replacement of lonon and outstanding
replacement uh we miss you ding so
please do return and uh Peter uh for MV
the worst start possible yeah he did not
want to to lose the first game with
white and also see all of his
competition win ala Yan and Fabby all
winning their games now it's a very very
close race one point with eight to go is
nothing it was very hard for me to tell
but it I don't know exactly where
mvl disadvantage without the diagram we
probably shouldn't go too deep into the
woods but I really like the suggestion
of Knight C4 move earlier where it would
have gotten the nights off I thought it
was very strong oh thank you for
that well we've got a marquee matchup
game coming up number the mvl our
tournament Leader by onepoint plays
against Nea
um how did they do in their nepo won is
the only player who beat Maxim
V you're saying this is a from a biased
perspective because I want to remind our
viewers who our picks were I'm shamed of
you all nobody picked mvl what's wrong
with you guys looking at you as well yes
right
here I
initiated I said Ali raaza and he's
lurking here we can see it uh as is a in
world number two Fabiano Carana he's
just in Striking this uh distance as
well nepo you're as you said saman I
mean var's got reason to be upset cuz
Sam could easily have a lot more points
Sam Sam feels like he's leaving some on
Absolut does feel like that a little bit
absolutely and once again the MBL just
lost only his second Blitz game let's
take a look at the end of that game
because I
thought from literally start to finish
Liam
played a game he can be incredibly proud
of that was that was a very nice game
considering I think that he was worse
out of the opening to outplay mvl from a
position where he had to First think
very carefully about how not to be in
much trouble now what Liam is doing is
he's setting up a checkmating pattern on
the H file with Rook on F2 to F3 and his
ideas Knight to G6 check followed by
Rook H3
mate and and you can't fight it it's
inevitable it's yeah exactly you can't
prevent it and there we see it uh Rook
H3 I am inevitable I am in this is uh
this was a fantastic game by Liam with
the black pieces it's not just this end
position where we see wh sking tra but
from start to finish how he started
gobbling up Pawn after Pawn targeting
the
H3 and the move F6 it kept the position
alive it kept the position going he had
and we saw the handshakes right here
with Maxim vasher lra King getting
checkmated on H4 it's not something you
get to see every day especially when
Maxim is in form yeah Tanya Peter I mean
did I I like it on chess.com they have
that accuracy reading I mean for me this
was a Blitz game you're not supposed to
have such a high quality accurate I I
think Liam Liam's numbers would have
been very very high there it looked like
he was fully in control once once he
assumed the initiative after 194 B5 I
guess it felt like all of his decisions
were incredibly on point just amazing as
we get ready uh once again to start this
round 11 and uh nepo versus MBL what a
matchup I just I can't
wait uh Peter what are we expecting
Yan's uh Blitz repertoire as you
mentioned I think he's been playing
mostly four in this tournament but he
can play whatever he like the man who
prepared for two World Championship
muches can play pretty much anything E2
E4 if you play E2 E4 Tanya you know
you're going to get a night or I mean
that's just it so if you want to play a
night off you want to play a groom Feld
well I wouldn't be surprised if we see a
night off Yan with E4 uh would love to
see that happen but we have seen Maxim
switching It Up In the Sicilian the
recent tournaments that he's been
playing uh has been employing different
openings even against the D against D4
he's been going for these Queen's Gambit
decline not his traditional grinfield
I'm expecting one E4 here uh a sicilian
might be the night off or might be
another one and here we go play it's E4
will it be C5 it is C5 will we see the
night off Knight
F3 and it's not the night off said it
you'll mix it up he could mix it up on
you C takes D4 Knight takes D4 and now
here's the Moment of Truth sikov E7
E5 and uh for sure uh because of the
whole Fai uh Magnus match from 2018
where this fesov was magnus's go-to
defense everybody everybody in the
world's top studied yeah it uh and look
at them go I mean they're just they're
they're gaining time on the clock they
have more time than what they started
with as you said sikov of course it's an
opening that's been there for the ages
but really gained in popularity after
that 2018 match what's been very
fascinating about Maxim in 23 he's one
of those very unique players who's had a
an extremely predictable opening
repertoire it's the nof it's your
grinfield against D4 and he's stuck to
it but over the last year I think he
realized and he spoken about this in his
blog post as well that he realized that
he needs to change it no matter how
difficult it is to start over again and
that also resulted in him not getting
the kind of opening positions that he
wanted but finally he finds his rhythm
in these openings that he hasn't played
before we're seeing him employ the sniko
of now we see him play these different
lines from the traditional uh Maxim that
we've known over time and he slows down
finally because G3 H4 on the board it's
a good time to take stock of the
position it's a different approach
entirely by Yan and I think Peter
mentioned it best when you play in a
world championship match the amount of
preparation that you do kind of carries
you over for the next year or two you
play in two World Championship matches
you got a lot of luggage you got a lot
of ideas against a lot of openings and
guess what this looks like a nice
treatment that White's doing he's
playing to trade off the light Square
bishop and just control forever the uh
Square D5 Peter jump in on this one for
me uh is G3 H4 well known yeah it's a
one of the main ideas in this line
because you the problem when you play
this uh C4 variation against the vesnik
of your problem is your light squared
Bishop whoo Castle's long Peter
whoa that's a different approach that is
a different approach it looks borderline
bad but in fact it's difficult for black
to open files on the queen side as you
can see you can play A4 A3 or you can
play the other Pawn forward but it will
always be met by white closing the the
the flank down you you play A3 I play B3
you play B3 I play A3 just as you said
closing the flank down but on the other
hand what is the king doing on B1 and
the thing about this plan is it allows
white to just go hell for leather on the
king side because we no longer have to
care about the center we no longer have
to we actually actively encourage uh the
opening of anything on the king side so
that this makes the game much sharper
much more double-edged and this is
exactly what Yan needs Yan if Yan wins
this game he ties for first after rounds
exactly exactly uh Tanya it's a bold
risky strategy what what what do you say
is this something you would have
entertained yourself bold risky strategy
is the style of both these players and I
think uh they're happy with the opening
outcome cuz this is the kind of position
that they like to play what is the one
difference between their styl is that
I've always found Yan his attack aggress
uh aggressive play is often based on
intuition on Instinct while Maxim feels
a bit more on calculation based his
tactics are more on a solid ground of
calculation U so it's really interesting
to see this Clash of similar style but
with different foundation and for me
right now it feels that white is the one
who's getting to Black sking first no
question about it that move King f8 is
an indication of exactly what you just
said is he's getting on his running
shoes the black king is is getting ready
to scadaddle Peter yeah I think it's
going to be difficult to run very far I
think White's threat here is probably G5
G6 because that will be very difficult
to ignore I think uh well then you can
open up lines you were mentioning it's
very difficult for black to open up
lines against White's King I like this
for white it it it feels like uh the
risk is paying off T it's because any
pawn break on the queen side is going to
result in a blocked structure regardless
you're not going to manage to open up
any lines for your rook and your queen
notice how all of Black's pieces are on
the left side of the board on the queen
side uh the black king left completely
without any God wh pawns uh going to
shred that King side very soon we've
seen F6 has is on the board H5 instantly
and you want to try to block it with a
move like G6 but it doesn't help because
white pushes H5 instead so Maxim
stopping H5 but this just results in the
king uh wide open this looks horrible
now horrible for black yes exactly
Bishop B to simply just attacking the PA
on a H5 connecting the Rooks I'm stunned
by the by the decision H5 by the way
Maxine made it immediately as if he felt
he had he had to do it but by putting
the the pawn on a light Square it
becomes an instant Target for the bishop
on E2 this looks as horrible Bishop
takes H5 Rook F1 I think uh it's game
over where is Black's attack it's not
there you've got the stunning Knight
you've got the stunning Knight on D4 no
that that was a a line of of uh six-time
Champion Walter Brown he said pretty as
a picture does nothing I mean it's
Knight the Knight is gorgeous on D4 but
it's not attacking it's not he's done
the right thing because if the C4 Pawn
Falls now with the pawn on B3 he might
be able to generate threats but Jana is
in no hurry whatsoever and well I love
this move Rook F1 this a very nice
contained move it's basically saying I
don't have to rush I can play Play
Bishop takes H5 on on my terms at yes
you're absolutely right and if black
goes for the C4 Pawn yes you can take on
E2 the queen captures back the Knight
you can win the C4 Pawn but the White
Queen taking on H5 will be far more
dangerous for your king and black is
just extremely late for the party yes
the party is over the party is over
Queen takes H5 Queen H6 Rook takes F7
would be made the queen H6 check
followed by G6 is likely to man and what
I mean you you come in
to today's action with a two-point lead
you feeling good uh you lose your first
two games against key Rivals you're not
feeling so good Tanya and that is the
point it's about getting that hot streak
going for you and the opposite of that
can put you in an absolute tilt the king
because the only piece on the king side
is the king it's the king to the rescue
of the King right now there's nothing to
I'm not buying this Peter I don't know
about you what are you what are you
trying to sell I'm try I'm try I'm
trying to find m in 3ish here you want
to take PA I want to play Rook F6 check
of course that's my first reaction as
well and take with the pawn so that you
just open up you know the healthy open
lines Rook F6 why doesn't Rook F6 win
the game he has two and a half minutes
and he's doing the right thing he's
double cheing because Rook F6 if we
shall we just put it on the board make
it very clear to our audience what we're
seeing what we're seeing is Queen and to
to add insult to injury also night 7
check oh well thank you for that that's
that that's very insulting and very
injurious oh my word uh Rook F6 has got
our attention uh and you think it has
yanss as well right Rook F he reaches
for the Queen instead but this is also
extremely strong I think Rook Rook F6
would have been a beautiful move but
Queen H3 the bishop the bishop is on pre
but if the Knight leaves the D4 Square
where you vate the F5 the defense of the
F5 Queen F5 Queen F7 would be game over
that's mate yeah so but is this setting
up rook F6 is it setting up Bishop takes
H5 check you know what I think he says
you have no moves it I don't think there
is a direct threat but black also has
nothing that moves the Knight cannot
move the Rook cannot take on C4 those
two things are very clear to me the
bishop on d8 can't
move the king I think unveil will play
A5 A4 I think I'm be able to resign
watch him play 5 A4 here no he goes back
with the queen queen E8 so he's
basically saying Bishop H5 and Rook F7
I'll defend Bishop takes H5 King takes
H5 Rook F6 for style points for style
points get the king out in the open and
before you bag it uh Rook F6 again it
just feels so oh badly I I think Rook F6
still looks like the move that should
work because you give up a rook you're
also giving up a bishop but that black
King and no one's coming to the defense
on the G line you can even give up a
rook on G1 in the line at the end Rook
F6 Bishop takes Rook Pawn takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop I think Rook G1
might work give up The Rook as well and
once again the queen is enough to give
Checkmate exactly Knight E2 you don't
even need Rook G1 Queen G2 right away
and here we go Bishop takes H5 he'll go
Knight F6 though it's strong Knight F6
is stronger and you take with the Rook
this time yeah you you actually give
mate instead of winning material KN six
F6 play King f8 and then just Rook G1
and he takes with the Rook Rook H6 is a
Checkmate in one and how are you
fighting against the m one queen f8 f8
or h8 and then Rook G1 and there's no
stopping Queen G4 oh nicely calculated
and nicely finished off by Yana pishi
beautiful game I mean uh once again mvl
is being victimized by simply fantastic
playet the the fun point is even if
black plays Queen E6 here yes we still
play Rook G1 no now that will get
another visual come on Yan thank you
queen6 Rook G1 you called it Peter
beautiful play as the threat is Queen G4
check followed by Rook H6 mate and if
Queen takes Queen Rook H6 mate anyway
exactly exactly oh this is stunning oh
very very nice he'll play Rook h8 and
spoil our beautiful uh finish uh you
just take the queen now sadly we just
take the queen now and uh we will play
G6 G7 and we will mate the
king Maxim continues to fight with 6
seconds on a clock and uh a busted
position to boot G the G forward and
then Queen G4 and finally handshakes
what a masterpiece an attacking
Masterpiece by Y where we going to go
we're going to go to the game of Liam
and Wesley asso uh
Wesley feeling terrible about that loss
uh he just suffered against Fai that was
very undeserved very
uncharacteristic uh what's going on in
this one Tanya I just the first look
with that Knight on D6 White having more
space in the position black looks
extremely passive if anyone's enjoying
that position it's got to be Liam Right
Wesley just played the move 98 however
trying to evict the Knight and the
Knight was for to retreat and Knight
comes back to F5 now with ideas of
attack on the king side the other Rook
uh comes on to the H file always
sacrifices on G7 and H6 in the air as we
have a very very very nice uh view of
beum
there takes a an exchange sacrifice and
a good one I would really want to get
rid of that Knight on D6 Wesley said I
do not want to suffer hang on a second
we've just given up two pawns or only
one cuz Queen B5 Knight takes D4 we we
run into a fork we
still thank you I was like what wait
wait a minute isn't that still there's
there's a lot of bonds for the exchange
now I'm not sure white is better anymore
not at all I I have to agree
wholeheartedly and that night was far
more worth than the exchange and now
black sight is the one that's putting
pressure on the weaknesses and the point
you were making D4 could not have been
picked up earlier but now it's has to
give it back take oh Rook takes F7 the
queen draw yeah ah F2 is hanging very
cleverly done but Rook F4 is a good find
by by the coach hesitation there he will
have drawing chances this is not a very
easily uh winning Rook ending if if
Wesley trades quins do you put the Rook
behind the pawn yes he puts it sideways
apparently apparently not apparently not
I would have put the Rook behind and
brought my king over to the queen side
Wesley says I've got to bring my my my
uhing King over to the queen side but I
want to keep my king side ooh am trying
to get rid of as many pawns as possible
which is the right strategy for the
defensive play now the question is are
you in time I don't think we can take
but we probably should still hold yeah
ala fuja meanwhile takes down Ray Robson
we will be able to take on H6 next move
maybe because that's yeah we can just
take on pick it up and the King Pawn
ending your Pawn Queens at the same time
as Black's Pawn exactly I thought he had
to play B4 we're going to see a draw
here and we will see a draw uh that
means that we will have one remaining
game between Fabby and Sam as these two
players figure out a way of getting to
King versus King which they've achieved
we're going to jump over to the game
between Fabby and Sam and it looks like
a win for the exchange I'm not so sure I
think this is probably a draw actually
wait Fabby on the clock he's got six
he's got 6 seconds on the clock CL now
we can even play B3 B2 and just trade it
for the G6 pawn and it's just a very
simple technical draw yeah good point I
don't know if I even plays a out to be
honest it's just there's not very much
to play for here exactly but it's Blitz
and the players are playing on seconds
and I think it's going to continue oh it
definitely oh there's a m threat you've
got to move that King away put the
bishop on F5 it's what we call an anchor
Square uh the bishop is nicely protected
and anchored and now you can just move
your King around it doesn't matter the
there's there's no mating uh patterns
with the bishop uh nicely defending and
confidently uh playing very very fast
very nice and now your king can take a
walk it almost feels like he knows
exactly what to do it's he's pre-moving
this game truly impressive play Don't Go
King 87 yes that would be a mate on 87
that would be injurious ooh something
happened there Sam wasn't sure you don't
want to put your piece on pre he's
really got the time going right now
almost 30 seconds he's managed to build
up on the clock funnily enough I would
have walked away from the G Pawn I would
have be playing King D5 King D6 King and
just not getting myself made it on the H
file there that's it there we have it a
confident hold by Sam what round Peter
oh my goodness three draws shockingly we
we're very unused to this we're very
very used to this but the fight for
first really intensifies with with Y
beating mvl so they are now tied for
first FA half a point behind and ala
also want Sala is a half a point behind
a half a point behind so there is a four
horse race what we wanted what we wanted
and starting very briefly with that game
that we just watched finish uh between
Fabby and Jeffrey Shong it was a very
very uh sharp Catalan type uh type game
uh began as a nimzo but is now uh much
more s similar to a Catalin and it
became really crazy really quickly as
you can see white has completely ignored
the pawn on C4 said yeah I'm playing a
proper Gambit I'm not trying to win any
material back and uh Sam correctly I
think uh opened up everything in the
center by playing a five and perhaps the
the early critical moment came here
where white won the pawn back but black
now has a lot of play and the engine was
insisting that you have to play Bishop
F4 here instead iby played Bishop B3 and
if you look at the position four moves
later this is massively better for black
the pawn on B2 is gone the Knight went
B4 D3 take B2 and F have to scramble not
to be not to be completely lost
somewhere here I think the engine was
suggesting playing the move Bishop G4
with the idea of Bishop B2 and saying
black is basically winning wow this
wasn't played Bishop B7 D5 before Queen
takes C7 gave F some hope and then uh
they reached this position which is
obviously already a huge Improvement
White is somehow even a pawn up by now
and here Sam uh played Rook D5 Bishop D5
Rook E3 this exchange
sacrifice and as we've seen managed to
hold it and ala just briefly his win
against Ray Robson he went back to the
well his his now it's not Bowski now
it's actually neither right because the
on A3 but it's very similar to what he
was doing in one day one he played this
reverse Sicilian uh very quickly they
got to this structure where uh there was
a trade on D4 then one of the black
bishops got traded on B3 and eventually
the knights came off the board as well
and we can look at the position
somewhere here where material is equal
but the white Bishop is just so much
better than his black counterpart and
alzo eventually won a very nice
technical game uh continuing his very
promising start of the day thank you
Peter and let's take a look at the
standings after two rounds of Blitz
Tanya it's very different you ask from
how we started the day as Maxim vasher
lra fails to keep his lead on the
he is now joined by yishi with two
victories there at 17 points uh along
with Maxim Ali Reza close behind along
with Fabiano Karana just half a point
behind the tournament leaders Liam Le at
15 and then we see a big gap as Wesley
saw tied for sixth along with Ray Robson
fantastic let's go to Studio with
Anastasia for more action on this round
anastas over to
you I kept my eye on the game which
turned out to be absolutely crazy it was
a game between Anish giri and Jeff Jong
and um this is one of the critical
Moments White played Bishop D3 inviting
black actually to go into the Trap so
after Queen A4 and B3 you can see that
this queen doesn't feel so comfortable
and Anish play this move Queen D1 uh
hoping with the next move Bishop C1 to
Simply take the queen but Jeffrey
actually kept calm found really nice
moves he played C5 here Bishop C1 Queen
is hanging but nevertheless C4 move and
he says that now if you take on A3 I
will just take on D3 and after Queen D3
B takes A3 I will have actually three
minor pieces for the queen which is
actually quite enough uh if we speak
about the compensation so that's why
Anish decided to play Bishop B1 you know
it's stay calm but Queen C1
followed C takes B3 and you can see
what's happening here you know it's
Queen is hanging and all those pawns
become very very tricky on the Queen's
side after Queen D1 B takes A2 uh we
don't know actually who is fighting for
victory here even though white has at
the moment Queen for the rook and um two
pieces um I mean it's still absolutely
unclear what is happening right now so
A4 followed and um now it's actually
Anish who had to fight for a draw and
this is what was happening for a long
time um Jeffrey had really good chances
uh somewhere around here but now at this
moment I didn't have much time both of
them and things I mean were changing
many times and um here was another
moment when uh Jeffrey had um good
chance maybe to try to play for victory
B3 um pass pones they have to move
forward so B3 was a very important uh
move uh which would allow black uh to
you know to try to win this um game
after Bishop B3 there is like nice move
Bishop B4 and there is no defense
against Rook e one so probably he missed
this opportunity and after that actually
now it's Anish who was on the driver
driver seat but he didn't find um a few
exact moves to convert his um better
position already to the Victory and I
think somewhere around here he just felt
that it's enough you know for today and
he just decided to finish this crazy
game in the draw so uh now with with
this drawer I mean Anish at least you
know makes it a little bit easy for
himself and we are about to go for our
commercial break and there will be also
a nice chat with Maxim which we had
before the
[Music]
tournament Maxim welcome back to St
Louis welcome back to gr tour um in the
short video which you made before the
tournament which you sent before the
tournament you specifically mentioned
that you're looking forward to have
Thanksgiving here um I was wondering
what is the most interesting for you
about this holiday and are you going to
discover and some Black Friday sales
perhaps uh yeah for me it's not really
about the Black Friday sales it's really
about you know I mean I know that
Thanksgiving is a huge tradition in
America and I've never been able to
witness it in person I've seen only
scenes from movies and so all so yeah
I'm looking forward to to look what it's
like uh you know in real life and also I
I hope to have great gifts to celebrate
for my opponents prior to that can you
share actually how many times you've
played in singfield cup before actually
how many times you played in St Louis
and which tournament was the most
memorable for you as I've played in
singfield cup uh from 2014 onwards so
that should be 10 but I think in 2020
because of Co it hasn't happened so it's
my ninth Edition I won it twice
especially the Edition in 2017 that I
won ahe of Magnus of all the top players
and uh I did beat Magnus in that event
so that one felt quite special yeah and
um what do you think about this one you
know rapit and Blitz and S will cup what
are your
expectations uh I'm definitely hoping to
do well it's the last classical event of
the year with the sill cup so I have my
PL been eratic especially in classical
this year so I'm hoping to bounce back
to to a good waiting so I'm you know it
starts here I think and same for the gr
Chester rankings uh I'm doing decent but
I still need two strong results here to
to qualify for next year's Edition yeah
and um you just coming from Grand SS
event yes in I love men how can you
assess your participation there and
let's say um we know that you lost the
opportunity to play in the candidates
because of this result but in general
like what what are your feelings about
this event and how did you try to
recover after it yeah g was a tough
event for me I I didn't survive in the
physical condition I op to I was a bit
sick from the start I didn't think it
have that much of a repercussion U but
it did in the first
half um and then I recovered quite
nicely but it was not enough so you know
I'm hoping
um yeah to to play better here of
course uh I don't have any doubt that I
can play better so so I will and but
yeah it was a tough event uh lots of
things uh were happening like every day
it was a crazy fight so at least the end
of the tournament as a neutral uh player
like neutral spectator was fun to watch
yeah but now let's say with this event
I'm really sorry to say that but you
lost this chance to get a spot in the
candidates I mean did it change your
goals and approach let's say for the
rest of the let's say year and the next
one did you change your goals um yeah I
mean I wouldn't say that the one is
where I lost the opportunity to play in
the candidates I think I think it comes
down to my first half of the Year where
my play was
erratic um so after that you know it
doesn't
uh uh it doesn't change my Approach uh
for for next years I'll still be trying
very hard to to compete for the world
championship cycle of course it's a p
don't manage to qualify uh for 2024
candidates but then I already set my uh
my eyes on the 20 6 exactly I mean of
course and I'm sure your fans also are
looking forward for it thank you so much
Maxim for this interview and all the
best of luck for you and both events
yeah thank
[Music]
you the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches
its epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cop and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
[Music]
out welcome back everyone as we're about
to kick off our next round and we've
already had switch UPS on the
leaderboard let's bring up our standings
let's do the honors Tanya as 11 rounds
of Blitz has brought us to this moment
we are going into round 12 and it's No
More Lonely at the Top as Maxim bashra
has been joined by Yan pesi with 17
points and hot on Heels Ali Resa fuja
and Fabiano Carana just half a point
behind them it's getting crowded at the
top isn't it yes this is getting messy
and fun for us yes it's exactly the kind
of tournament that we like a field wide
open Maxim VRA stops today with two
losses definitely time to stop the
bleeding which brings us to our pairings
which are very exciting ones at that
check that out MV versus fuia that's hot
and heavy right there I was talking
about having to stop the bleeding with a
matchup like that we know that we're
headed for a decisive fun game of chess
with their style of play it's going to
be aggressive action absolutely
yesterday it was that matchup of fuja
versus mvl that catapulted mvl into
first place because mvl won that game
with the black pieces if color if roles
were reversed in this one it would be
fuja Cal pting himself in first and
we're talking about how their styles are
so like each other and we saw the yishi
our other tournament leader our co-
leader now is playing against Wesley so
uh Peter what do you think will be the
decisive factors when Wesley plays
against yan yan I think is currently uh
zero out of two against Wesley in this
tournament he lost the rapid also I
think lost the first blitz so he needs
to stop he needs to stop with that
losing to Wesley business
that's Wesley that has this kind of a I
want to say Dark Cloud over uh Yan there
their rivalry that goes back a number of
years definitely favoring Wesley in
their head-to-head battles but I tell
you that all French matchup between uh
mvl and fuia that one I seriously if if
fua wins and he starts with three out of
three and mvl goes 0 for three that's a
that's a nasty hatrick and anastasha
earlier was talking about Anish
returning with his hoodie chess players
being super
superstitious Maxim Mar lrav here
returns with his cool Cali t-shirt for
day two but it hasn't worked so far for
him not so far 0 0 out of two and Anish
is yeah no he's got the black hoodie
he's still on his black hoodie there
playing against Ray Robson who had a
Fant fantastic run in the rapid but it's
been a nightmare for a race so far in
the blitz it's been about the clock
management for him when you've got a
10-second increment in the rapid you can
build up on that but with just two SEC 3
seconds excuse me with for increment or
is it two two you I corrected two
seconds uh it isn't easy and we see it
is go time it is the car when you want
to play for a win is black go for the
caroan I've always said E7 E6 Bishop E2
the Nigel short defense uh to the caroan
attack as uh we have castles on the
board now here very big moment Knight D7
C5 uh they have become the in extremely
sharp variations and I remember uh
trying my best uh to make heads and
tails out of these positions uh C5 takes
D par me D4 takes C5 as on the board and
we've had our first pause because there
there's a variation that goes D5 D4 you
are threatening uh D4 D3 there's a
variation that goes takes on C4 followed
by Knight G6 and it's the lad that uh
Ali Raza chose and we see a lot of
development to follow by both these
players to me the caran always feels
like the French with the bishop out for
black see that's exactly what we Aspire
I always like the French defense I
didn't like suffering with uh my light
squared Bishop I like the caroan because
often times I got a French defense
position with the bishop actually active
so I naturally chose and preferred the
latter Bishop E2 um is there an e
hanging what's going on here well well
that would return the material balance
right Peter these positions are very
very sharp uh your take on this
particular line uh the choice you
described earlier between D4 and D take
C4 that ala chose taking on C4 this is a
much more conservative option for black
uh you're only really aiming to equalize
um white maybe is a touch better but uh
generally this is not that bad for black
at all after D5 D4 it would have been an
absolute mess so I think
ala sort of giving a giving a not to
mbl's excellent home prep and just Ching
something that is a bit safer if if you
don't mind me mentioning f are we not
losing a bishop here was about to say do
I have to trade Queens to be to
to to have the G4 Square yeah this is
maybe a very good point because if the
Knight goes back to C6 which seems
perfectly logical I think after G2 G4 we
might be losing a piece straight up
losing a piece yes uh something strange
is going on here Tanya um Knight C6
which looks like a decent move G2 G4 the
bishop would have to be dropped back and
then after F4 F5 you'd find yourself
trapped a piece down so we're
considering Queen takes D1 followed by
Knight G4 it might be to stay alive
he there we go it's a peace sacrifice
right for two pawns I don't understand
G4 it doesn't look like it's enough
because you also maybe he wants to
provoke F5 then take on C5 and then play
Queen G5
check right so we take m is also
committed now mvl really has no way back
he quite committed yes takes Bishop
takes
take and he's got a queen G5 check the
check so that the Queens don't come off
and now he will take on C5 and take on
G6 he will still be much worse well I
have two pawns yeah Queen D5 is just
going to be so painful cuz you have to
start dropping dropping well we're going
to take the piece yeah start by taking
the piece and V is even pausing here
because he can start with Queen D5 even
now maybe might even be stronger you
don't necessarily have to grab the the
bishop on G6 right away
you're saying Queen G5 but there is
Bishop eight no forgive me this might be
even stronger frankly no this has been a
very strange decision by by Resa because
he could have gone I mean that end game
was also not particularly fun to to be
fair to he's done Queen D5 just the move
that you've uh you've suggested Queen D5
now I suppose I have to play Queen E7 to
defend the Knight on C5 not what Ali
Resa was thinking when he went into this
material this is just Wai for the
question is whether mvl will convert
cleanly or not but yeah Bishop C4 I like
Bishop C4 coming creating a huge set of
rookie one next mon uh something has
happened in fuja when he matches up with
against MV he's not matching up well the
the yesterday the game he lost uh was a
one-sided game and this one looks the
same Tanya it ended with a maxim win and
it looks like this one's headed that way
as well and I noticed when Ali RZA made
the move Queen to E7 the retreating move
that we just saw he looked completely
dejected with about his position what am
I doing something has gone very wrong
out of the opening and the only way to
keep material balance was to trade the
queen at that point before retreating
the night but he perhaps did not like
the outcome of that end game anyway and
now this is just going to be it's hard
to imagine Maxim not getting the full
point we see Ali Resa uh bringing the
Rook to E8 if white was to play rookie
P1 do you give up your queen you're
forced and you feel like this improves
your chances somewhat you're still going
to be in a lot of trouble but I think
and is unlikely to do that yeah I was
actually thinking that uh in this
particular position I would love my
knight to be on D5 so move I would find
attractive as Queen G2 threatening Queen
takes G6 after Rook E8 I'm sorry I would
find so that I could launch my knight to
the D5 Square he has played he wants to
double up on the f file also a really
nice idea just Rook F2 with the idea of
getting the the final piece into the
game with Rook F1 F7 is such a big
Target here big time I remember Victor
Kai after a moov like Rook F2 would
exclaim so
simple keep it simple it's so simple but
when you're a piece up and you're the
one putting the pressure especially at
that level it's not that difficult to
keep it simple while the queen is
attacked he needs to find the square for
it your idea of coming back to G2 with a
pressure on the G6 Pawn looks really
nice and then he keeps it on the F7 Pawn
instead still eyeing a rook F1 Knight D5
that's the focus isn't it uh Rook D4
this looks like an attempt but you know
just B2 B3 just protect the bishop uh
with each move with each passing move I
want to say Peter I find Black's
position going steadily steadily
slipping away I can all but call this if
you want good good here for ala he is
still alive and the position he got
after let's say queen E7 and the bishop
capture it looked like the game might be
over in five moves right he manage to
stabilize if if the Knight actually
lands on E5 and the game still continues
he is still there he's fighting but the
position remains very very bad of course
exactly uh Tanya what do you think is f
is B7 hanging am I a pawn grubber I was
thinking yes you are yasa that's the
answer but I think in this position
perhaps it gives black the opportunity
to come to E3 with the queen attacking
the rook and the Knight something about
it Maxim didn't like he pauses brings
The Rook into the game with Rook F1 but
this does give black the time to jump in
with the Knight not is seemingly very
strong the pawn Knight E5 Queen E3 that
looks and things start hanging all over
again
F7 there's a pin against the Knight so
again F7 is hanging there's a a rook
getting hit so Knight E5 Queen E3 that
looks tremendous for white and if you go
yeah how do you keep everything defended
do you have time for Queen C7 is that
enough but Rook is hanging on D4 so
you've got to go queen queen D6 I guess
the point being that we have a check
from C6 in case of ah thank you uh Queen
yes I'm forgetting that there is Queen
E3 Queen D6 defends the rook and also it
avoids uh a knight fork with Queen C6
check but then Queen D6 uh makes it a
bit tricky for white no if you go Queen
D6 you're threatening checks already I
think this is why you're seeing mvl
pause he he's realizing that his very
easy conversion is turning into
something which is less than easy now
going to require work yes less than easy
Queen to E2 defends the bishop which is
already defended but more simply it pins
the Knight and I we still play Queen D6
I think Queen D6 Knight B5 Che King G1
there's R G4 check at least a rook G4
check thank you so much there's all
kinds of there's all kinds of jumps that
you have to control que C5 Rook F4 so
stopping this is fantastic news for
black because we get to get rid of the
bishop on C4 exactly I wanted to say
exactly the same thing and the pressure
against F7 got neutralized remarkably
this I thought it was dead this is
entering the potential I mean it's still
much better for white but you can
imagine not winning this now yeah two
pawns and a pretty stable King so M and
20 seconds though on the clock for Ali
Resa with the facing 2 minutes and 20
seconds for maxim Vash uh but it looks
like ala has made progress towards that
defense there still work to be done and
that clock now under 10 seconds is going
to count for a lot exactly Rooks traded
goes for A6 doesn't immediately pick up
the bishop on C4 hopefully he's thinking
that uh he can uh dislodge the bishop
away from the um
F7 uh pressure Rook takes Rook takes on
the board uh A7 A6 and uh Knight D5
jumps in with the
Knight and watch out for ideas of uh the
Anastasia mate with right now the E7
square is defended very well guarded but
97 Rook H4 tricks were in the air
exactly 95 now we have to deal with the
of b75 this is
becoming it's it wasn't the clean
cut Victory we hope for because once
again this Knight on D5 requiring
attention maybe we have to play B4 in
order to just uh keeping the bishop
alive we do have a result in Neo's game
by the way our tournament co-leader made
a draw with Wesley s so this is an
opportunity for maxim to jump back on
the leader board of Maxim is able to win
this position uh which it feels like
he's let a little bit of his Advantage
slip but still an extra piece the bishop
is still alive uh I am liking the fact
that the bishop puts pressure on F7 I'm
still counting on Maxim to convert this
he he does have the material Edge Fabby
has beaten Jeffrey whose nightmare
tournament continues Jeffrey really
isn't having a uh oh a nice event uh
Fabby uh oh and that move made sorry
yasa but he made that move with just
three seconds on the clock did Ali Raza
yes just no time left and Bishop F7 is a
big threat you've got to move the queen
away Queen F6 by the way wait good move
Queen F6 if you want to trade Queens
impr at Le improve my Pawn
structure and by the way still I know
he's playing only on his increment but
to his credit Ali Raza is really hanging
in there I'm I'm impressed can he
instead y I go for Rook to F4 and I
really want to try and win that F7 Pawn
I hit your queen where do you move away
Queen
E7 probably the only square and he goes
for the queen trade but that's got to be
relief for ala oh Big Time King G7 let's
go and again not much time uh he's only
getting two seconds for each move that
he makes and he's not able to to to get
a a a bank of
seconds Rook e Rook C3 let's go Rook C1
I was about to say Rook C3 let's go Rook
C1 and Rook C3 okay King F2 and isn't it
time for F5 yet absolutely um Peter he
saves this onest
yeah the conversion yeah it if not for
the clock the clock is simply an
enormous Factor at the
moment on day one Maxine was so
impressive with his endgame play and
technique he won so many crucial points
on that H and I I have a feeling we're
going to see some of that coming in the
pawns on the queen side are getting weak
well in fact they just
wentop and Bishop E4 that's a boss move
stops Rook C2
Rook takes A5 three check is what Maxim
is cating decides not to allow it yeah I
think it's a very understandable
decision and is this going to be about
losing the queen Side Pawn but trying to
create a race on the king side with the
that F Pawn no more race uh that that's
two connected pass pawns on the queen
side all Maxine has to do is to prevent
an accident happening on the king side
but the race is coming on G4 is in the
air but the problem is you you trade and
there's a check on G5 so you don't have
time to go G4 just yet exactly King F6
by the way he made that move a little
Herky jerky because 2 seconds on the
clock he's now up to four but he's been
making the last 20 moves on just the
bare minimum exactly before finally
lands which is great news for L res at
least finally MV has something to worry
about on the other side of the bo G2 on
on Black's agenda King D3 uh you have to
give the bishop back well now suddenly
jump in with a knight some
chances Peter how you start pushing yeah
F3 F3 oops sorry when you say some
chances do you mean for black to hold or
for for a draw for a draw for a draw I
mean uh Ali Raza is
absolutely yeah if the Rooks come off I
think the white pawns are just too quick
the White Knight stops the F Pawn but no
one's stopping the A and the B Pawn I
don't understand why Ali Rea has not
played f three earlier uh just you need
you need to distract yeah F3 has to be
played yeah white from doing yeah white
is just pushing very strong move there
by F2 what because there was a queen and
F1 is guarded by the light and look at
that Cheapo that he set up he moved his
King in order oh and queen comes in with
with the check well you got to make a
queen there's no choice oh he just no I
was about to say the clock stopped
something happened
oh the clock just
stopped the battery died W it's un
electrical oh my
goodness likely we have video so that
they can set up the clocks correctly
with exactly the amount of seconds they
had but this shouldn't not ideal this is
not this shouldn't happen I don't recall
that ever happen no there's a very
famous incident which featured which
dying he doesn't continue he doesn't
wait for the clocks to come on it's
handshakes and it's game over so grab
back in the lead stops the bleeding um
that was a weird finish that was sorry
you were about to say it there was a
there was a very famous incident in uh
in Kazan In 2011 candidate matches the
exact same thing thing happened in a
with a clock in a in a bleed game
between Timur rajabov and Vladimir
kramnik and it started a long story
let's see the replay because Tanya the
clock just went Bo here we were down to
7 Seconds it wasn't flagging
Black's going to Queen White's going to
Queen with a check and just as he
reaches out to put that Queen on the
board the clocks go off exactly and with
7 Seconds to resign the game uh
okay the gods were
angry it is a winning position for maxim
vasher lra but probably Ali Resa would
have continued regardless it still
worked for the clock and then we saw Ali
RZA just with handshakes he did not want
to continue anymore Peter where was the
action elsewhere well the action will be
in Anastasia's report because the two
games I chose for for this round were
both extremely quiet Affairs uh Ray
Robson against Anish giri was this uh uh
this started as an anti Berlin and this
type of a structure where black plays D7
D5 a bit early as you can see here black
immediately goes D5 in one tempo and
takes on e4 this sometimes becomes an
interesting position if if one side
plays uh ambitiously and the other side
is maybe a bit impec size but in this
particular game I think Ray was very
happy just to keep things under control
and there were pieces continued coming
off constantly and they were peaceful
yeah and eventually everything came off
and the game was drawn and a somewhat
similar story in a game between whoops
uh uh Wesley saw and yanish are very
very the the
pianissimo the the Joo pianim with white
not even playing C2 C3 and uh here once
again this is a typical structure a lot
of people are now playing these KN
Knight C3 mb3 structures but you have to
have something uh in these very
symmetrical positions you have to have
some kind of an idea for why you're
better and I think Wesley um he tried
but eventually uh more more pieces were
traded and then the queens were
traded and uh this Rook ending wasn't
really very exciting with the Game
ending in a repetition about 10 later
two peaceful draws there but let's take
a look at the standings because I'm
still in a shock by how that uh MV game
finished MV was only a half a point
ahead of Ali Raza and that was a huge
victory that was drama on the board and
big drama on the clock as well as Maxim
vasher lra takes the lead with a win
against Ali RZA fuja it was a dead lost
position for Ali Reza but the clock
dying like that no one was expecting it
Fabiano Carana Yana pish half a point
behind a Maxim vasher lra in Blitz with
so many rounds still remaining it is
once again a field wide open the Half
Point margin barely matters and for more
highlights uh we're going to head over
to
Anastasia thank you Tanya and actually
Peter was right lots of action in the
games I kept my eye on and starting with
a game between Jeffrey J against Fabiano
Karana things went quite smoothly in the
opening everything was more or less
under control from both sides and then
um Jeffrey played this move B5 and at
this moment fa was probably afraid to
take on A3 um following this line Queen
E3 and now probably he missed it after B
takes C6 he is not obliged to take with
a bishop which would create a lot of
troubles after Knight D5 and it's crazy
variations and The Rook on C it is
hanging he could have taken this Pawn
with the rook and then actually now
there is no Knight D5 for the same
reasons because Rook on C1 will be
hanging in all this lines but he decided
to go for for the Queen's exchange and
they entered um quite drowish ending
after that um but look how tricky Fabby
is after couple of moves he he played
this tricky move Rook seven probably
waiting for Jeffrey answer Knight B5
which seems like everything is under
control after Bishop B5 and white could
just continue with Bishop B5 but Jeffrey
was tempted probably with this idea Rook
s and he calculated the line but Fabby
actually calculated better so after
Bishop B1 Rook C6 um I think he missed
something uh like Bishop B5 and after
Rook D6 this very important move Knight
E4 um some intermediate move and uh
actually this Rook is trapped um after
94 it's trapped and I mean white has
nothing to do like try to get rid of um
take at least something here after
Bishop B4 Rook A1 Black simply take on
D6 and um and ended up in a winning
ending after that you know two two pass
pawns on the queen side so in a few
moves Jeffrey just resigned in this game
Fab is actually I think uh getting some
speed in this tournament and he has a
good tournament so far and the second
game which I was checking today was
again between s s and lean Liam uh it
was snik of variation which was like um
all this normal ideas which you normally
see in this line happened in the game
Bishop took the Knight on the3 and I
mean also Sam managed to bring his
Knight to D5 there were many many
exchanges and then suddenly I'm really I
don't know where exactly but around this
moment things went wrong for leang Liam
he started like to play a little bit um
um passively maybe and white managed to
grab one of the pawns he took the pawn
on A6 and um probably understanding the
position is not so good anymore Liam
tried to create at least some kind of
play on the king's side and he brought
all his pieces all the way to to the
king's side but it didn't really help
him because um um Sam who played with
white pieces found really good moves
like for example here after Queen E3 he
came out with this very nice Rook D7 now
you cannot take on D7 because of Queen
f8 Checkmate so he played really really
well very precisely and didn't get any
chance to his opponent to create any
kind of counterplay even though it looks
a little bit scary for white with this
Knight and queen
near the king but it didn't really work
in the end after King G7 again very
precise move Bishop B2 um making sure
that E5 um Pawn is hanging because all
this variations with Knight G3 now and
for example maybe like Queen F4 is not
working because of Bishop B5 so um very
good actually play of Sam I really like
the way he played this game so I think
so far he's doing really well two and a
half points if I'm not mistaken in three
rounds really good start for him of the
day and now let's get back to to the
studio for more action for that
Anastasia indeed a very big start as
that previous round I'm still reeling by
the whole controversy with the clock we
promised to get you more insights on
what happened it just looked like the
clock just like ran out of gas and had
too much the the clock said I'm finished
either that or the gods didn't want the
game to continue it's enough for ala
he's gone through enough in this one
stop but that was uh a moment that I
haven't witnessed before absolutely yes
a big one and you some big news for us
well uh well let's just say Blitz socks
I mean we we're at that stage of our
show where we like to check in with our
friends at Q Boutique and see what items
they are offering us check this out we
are proud proud proudly we announce the
2023 St Louis rapid and Blitz Soxs yes
they were chosen for the drawing of lots
stay on the move with these custom
logoed 2023 St Louis rapid and Blitz
sock these full calf length polys Tri Ln
socks are comfy and sporty great for the
gym or the chessboard also featured with
the 2023 rapid and Blitz vests these
vests support the St Louis rapid and
Blitz logo on the chest and represent
the grand chest tour and St Louis chess
club logos as well the vests are offered
in both men's and women's Styles so it
is perfect fit for any chess lovers in
your life stay warm and stay stylish
available at qbt stl.com for all your
chest needs isn't that just fantastic I
love those socks are you do you have
them on no oh you need to get yourself a
pair obviously I got to stay comfy Peter
I mean important when they did the
drawing of lots I noticed those socks
and they they did look I think I think
they're in the goodie bag have they
passed you by I think no I got a goodie
bag I just have to investigate carefully
you're not ailing yourself of the
important opportunities in life there is
I know I have to get out more I'm sure
about it a big question right now yeah
tell us about the pairings for this
round 13 is it a superstitious number
yeah and will Maxim VRA we of the big
opportunity of being on the leaderboard
once again at the top and he's playing
against Anish giru who's got 13 and a
half points he's far behind on the
leaderboard but if he's able to get the
ball rolling and get in a couple of
points he will at least make his way up
for maxim it's time to strike continue
the attack and alira fuja who's also in
the mix for the top spot play against
Wesley so Yan Nai as well with 17 and a
half points against Sam savan Liam faces
Fabby uh on that fifth world match great
match up Sam Sean uh sneaking in there
with two and a half out of three as
Anastasia told us Napo has to be careful
this is not going to be an easy match up
absolutely and they all know how Str how
strong Sam is uh they've all played a
bunch against him and online if not over
the board definitely online they all
know how how how good how fast he is so
feels like Fab's getting his fair share
of good luck though uh to start this uh
day two of you make your own luck on the
chess bod ass and I think that last game
that we saw by Fabby trapping The Rook
on D6 which Anastasia was it was
beautiful chess right there that was
that was
nasty and uh once more it's early days
but they suddenly got tight what happens
in case of a playoff I mean it's no
longer Lonely at the top it's not it is
extremely crowded at the top we've seen
how close the fight is yes Maxim leads
with half a point but if at the end of
the day two players are tied with equal
points they play a mini match of two
games against each other 10 minutes on
the clock five additional seconds every
time they press the clock now if three
or more players have equal number of
points they're going to play against
each other 5 minutes with a 3 second
increment now if if everything still
remains in balance in these mini matches
then we go on to a chess format that is
so dangerous that it's called the
armagan right which gives white an
additional minute on the clock no
increment and if it's a draw black wins
the match white gets extra time but
black gets result odds are we going to
have a tie for first place at the end of
it is the big question but these are the
standings yes well it's a possibility
for sure as you see how close uh those
players are with six rounds remaining
now uh Tanya that's where we got messed
up there we we were playing 5 plus two
in the blitz but then you saw the five
plus three in the tiebreaker why these
time controls get shifted I don't get it
I just like give me a blitz time control
give me a rapid give me an Armageddon
I'm a happy camper but when they mix it
up I don't get it I like that because
it's such an additional challenge for
the the players it requires the skill
set to adapt to these switch UPS in
between tournament you've first got the
rapid then you've got to swap that with
the shoot the rules committee two
seconds three seconds I'm loving it give
me a give me one cont gods of Mischief
are very very happy with this I I think
it's very much in the spirit don't you
Peter like just three plus two what they
play as a player maybe but as somebody
watching them scramble to adjust to yet
another format in the space of 30
seconds
I'm all for it it's a commentator's
Dream It's a fans chess fans across the
world we get to see them struggle with
this new time format and show their best
chess in it I loved it when Boris Galan
came and uh gave this wonderful rant
about why don't they just have the time
control standardized around the world I
loved it I am man after my heart I just
wanted to say that uh once again as the
blitz goes It goes by so incredibly fast
uh Wesley so I thought was going to be
creeping back into it seems like he's
disappearing Ray's disappearing yeah Ray
really hasn't really recovered from a
very very poor start I mean he lost he
lost the last rapid game perhaps
spoiling his mood after all despite
winning the rapid losing the last game
is never funny right and enjoyable and
then his first day went so poorly that
today I think it will be very difficult
for him to come back max starting with
two losses then having a huge huge and I
mean an absolutely if he had lost that
third g day in a row I think that was
goodbye Maxim hello Ali Raza but by
coming back and winning that game that's
that's impressive but he won that piece
out of the opening and then yes he it
wasn't the most accurate play but this
is Blitz yes and he kept the majority of
the advantage and converted it at the
end so B deserved Victory there for
maxim but of course the job is far from
done he plays against
and it was against Ali fuja that Maxim
got his first point of the day for Ali
Rea as well and we see that with the
trophy in sight right there uh that's
got to be inspiring for the players as
well H R Robson as we were talking about
him it has been a very difficult Blitz
portion coming down to that time control
keeping control over the clock which has
been a big struggle for the American
grandmas lots of stories in uh this
blitz but there I just saw if I'm in Ali
Ray's uh situation I'm in a rage in an
absolute ra no I'm angry I won two games
I was on a streak and I just blundered
or lost a piece out of the opening I
nearly saved it I'm angry that's a
really good point because you're not
angry at uh at the clock what happened
with the clock but with the way the game
went and I think he has to just let that
go uh keep that behind him and keep
moving he's still in the mix for the top
and it is go time exactly as uh the
players are underway Anish giri uh with
the white pieces Anisha has been having
a quiet but on the other hand also
competitive Affair uh he's had good
positions he hasn't made the absolute
most of them and we have a Queen's
Gambit accepted I've always felt that
the third move 3e4 is the most
challenging against the Queen's Gambit
accepted and the players are quickly
going into a very theoretical line with
E5 takes D4 I'm a little bit more
familiar with Bishop takes C4 than
Knight takes D4 sorry T please no ask I
was just going to I was just going to
add to your thought a followup to the
opening that the queen Gambit accepted
is one of those uh openings that we are
seeing more and more from Maxim Vash lra
in recent history someone who really
stuck to the grinfield for so many of
his years at the very very drop top is
uh switching it up in the openings
making him more unpredictable making him
harder to prepare against no question
about it and as somebody mentioned on
this block fre Peter's not happy I hear
you I hear you Peter Knight F6 Knight C3
whoa whoa whoa guess what castles no
Bishop takes C4 for you castles long
Queen E7 and we understand kind of
similar to what mvl experience
against nepo Kings on opposite flanks uh
whites play Tanya is very clear I want
G4 G5 uh here well you want to throw the
queen side at me I want to throw the
king side at you Peter this move C5 was
that ill timed it feels wrong to my eyes
Queen D5 the big question is what
happens if black plays A6 and eventually
gets to play B7 B5 do you ever win the
PA C4 A6 Queen yeah let's say let's say
I take take and I play a B5 A4 let's go
we're going to see all of this now as
the different different path yeah I
apologize we got Knight C6 instead yeah
and now we will take and play Maybe
Knight C7 no Knight D6 anyway very
important detail there that Knight C7
Rook A7 maybe was playable for B5 A4
let's go E5 first E5 first you can't go
needs to go to E8 these are not very
pleasant squares no you're absolutely
Knight D7 would allow Knight take C8 and
is this whole Theory well they are
playing as if it is or at least from my
perspective it h Anish is playing like
as if this is all familiar to him Anish
knows everything just best prepared
players in on the planet and you see
he's just uh come under the 5 minute
Mark so it was definitely something he's
familiar
with5 was te so he's played it very
quickly he he sacrificed upon has white
but I'm not con I'm not convinced of the
righteousness of the sacrifice
Peter it's very interesting I'm pretty
sure white has enough not to be worse
the question is does he have enough to
be better so we start after Knight B4
with the move Rook D7 there is a threat
of knight3 Knight
F2 which actually attacks
deserves deserves respect agreed so do
you spend some time moving your king to
B1 getting out of the check perhaps
Bishop F5 just to stop that check I I
want to uh meet Knight D3 check with
Bishop with King C2 Bishop F5 would
encourage G6 and Knight G7 which is a
nice way of bringing the Knight back to
life but okay Bishop F5 whether we like
it play we have to do it
Bishop F5 G6 Bishop E4 does threaten to
win the pawn back with
A3 he goes for it and I think if he goes
for it andil will play G6 and if Bishop
E4 andil will play F5 I think okay but
then pretty sure M the move A3 I find
very
attractive you'll have a a big majority
but so will I and I'll have F6 yes and
the Knight on e4 is just so much better
than the Knight on E8 that's a very good
point yes F5 A3 that's a tricky trap
what are the times uh Tanya or is a
clock of here we go it's a one
minute will Anish play that move A2 A3
that has to be on his agenda know
because otherwise you don't have a good
Square for the bishop to retreat you
really want to play the move A3 and you
were asking about the time Anish is
ahead of the clock he has paused right
now and he reaches out for the the
bishop and falls back to B1 oh I really
think that the there was a chance there
with the move A2 A3 that an Nish might
have been able to turn the tables
completely Bishop B1 Knight C7 do we
drop in Rook to D6 or all the way to
D7 or I I don't like letting the yeah
yeah Rook D6 I like the move Rook D6
because I do have it in mind to play the
move A3 so we do see a trade of Rooks
Rook f8 to D d8 Rook to D1 really nice
how black white keeps the E6 Square
guarded stopping any uh blocked on with
the Knight jumping in to E6 D4 for the
moment though we're taking away the
square C6 so A3 you will have to go to
D3 I'll win my Pawn back and then I'll
have a protected pass PA maybe some
nibble for white so A3 how did De deal
with this should we play
A5 try to keep our uh to give our Knight
a square
big moment here big and about two and a
half minutes for black here and Maxim
vasher lra thinking what you really want
to do is go try and get your king into
the center but you don't have time
because of A3 he falls back hits The
Rook Rook D7 yes but we do after the
move Rook D7 which was played we do give
our our our Knight the square C6 so A3
is not uh the killer threat when does
white start pushing the
ewn probably never really you want to
keep it defended on E5 yeah I I think
the thing we have to keep in mind is G4
and in case of f takes G4 ideas of
Knight jumping Knight to E4 to F6 as
well as Knight to E4 but I think uh
White's strategy at this moment is he's
got to blast open the diagonal for his
Bishop Knight G7 but do you want to
prepare for that or is it worth even
sacrificing upon for it's worth
sacrificing I would agree with that it's
more about Tempo than uh it's initiative
it's initiative you want to get your
piece in the center exactly now again I
was thinking that the Knight on E8 was
actually doing a pretty good job I would
have been more tempted A3 knight5 looks
very promising A3 Rook C7 looks very
promising this looks very nice for white
A3 Knight C6 Knight D5 get it to F6 and
then see how black likes it I was about
to say that's why I kind of felt the
Knight was actually doing a better job
on f8 than on G7 Rook back to D6 this is
classic Anish he wants to keep
everything under control an invitation
to a draw offer he's not going to repeat
no ways I don't think he does no no no
no tournament situation as well he has
to oh come on Anish you've got to play
this song mvl should claim mvl should
not be fooling around here oh my God now
Knight G7 and that's it three move
repetition draw what else do we have we
have this is a bit surprising a huge
surprise let's go to nepo quickly versus
Sam
Sean uh nepo with the white pieces how's
he
doing I like white he's feels more
coordinated the open E file the doubled
Rooks the last move C5 is a little
Annoying of course we like to keep our
Knight nicely uh on D4 he's spotted a
weak
what what do you think Tanya White's got
two weaknesses on A5 and C3 which can be
targeted with a queen shift white
meanwhile is attacking the B7 Pawn that
you were highlighting and I think that
needs to be defended and I'm just
wondering but he doesn't I was thinking
does he go Rook B8 idea with Queen C7
but he immediately trades off uh the
weakness on B7 for the A5 Pawn I think
this is going to fizzle out to a draw
feels like it uh most likely uh Rook e
five I think was a good and wise
decision
Peter weigh in on this ending feels
balanced should be very dsh now yeah I
think this is very good defense by by
Sam hard to imagine how A6 is not
getting traded with if you don't mind
I'm going to make an executive decision
therefore and I'm going to go to the
game between Liam and Fabby as we do
expect the game between um nepo and Sam
to end in a draw what's going that's an
extra Rook for white it's an extra
Exchange in the position and it looks
like uh equal bonds Fab's in a lot of
trouble here a lot of trouble as Liam
once again I mean this former world
champion has really played
extraordinarily good chess and the start
of today was absolutely fantastic he he
beat mvl in one of the best Blitz Games
I've I've witnessed I I just don't know
how to describe it it was that good G5
on board dri seat how good bad is it
time for F4 no he just he just stopped
any back rank checks by The Rook a bit
surprised by how passively he has played
the last few moves but he is still so
much material yeah he should still be
winning but he's so far ahead right yeah
we did just see the move Knight E1 and
Knight
E5 have I got that right mhm and also
meanwhile white has picked up a Pawn on
A6 very important P H2 H3 that's just
one of those extra little moves that you
like to squeeze and give your king a
little bit more Breathing Room Rook to
D2 Tanya how easy is this to me it feels
that white should be able to convert
this without too much trouble especially
the Knight on E1 which actually guards
against any counterplay against Whit's
King you just make sure that you stay
there no Knight F3 checks a lot he first
trades off on the king side I love this
move A4 because the pawn is in a pin yes
the Knight on E5 is hanging and by the
way
incoming result nepo and Sam did draw as
we expected glad we moved over to this
game expecting you know I think I think
we yeah EXA ooh uh much better detail
there very nice Point that's another
Pawn for Liam and that's a really big
pawn and it is a very big PA Rook G it
would become bigger had black taken the
rook and then the pawn would be
unstoppable after taking the bishop so
that wasn't a possibility and we' just
seen the move Rook D4 by Liam yeah this
is we are now comfortably in resignation
territory impressive Victory from theam
yes absolutely and that also playing
spoiler Tob tournament weia versus
Wesley oh my gosh Chaos on the board 5
seconds once again to Ali Resa let's
just hope there are no dying batteries
and dying clocks in this one because the
position with black king on G6 I would
be scared for Wesley here
G6 but he throws in Queen h8 coming in
Queen h8 M Rook H6 there is but G G5 is
protected what with the queen on D2 but
there was Rook G8 no yeah he takes it
and the queen has to come back to start
attacking Black's King but look at that
played on one seconds there yes played
with a single second a single second on
the clock Rook F3 is a threat winning
the queen and he's moved away uh this is
where nerves it's all about n here ala
has been making the last five moves with
a second on the clock but he's walked
into a lot of self pins as well this is
not been well played by fuja not at all
no a lot of his Advantage seems to have
slipped away from when we joined check
he recaptures with the pawn not the yes
yeah but that's extra Pawn for Wesley in
a rook Pawn ending now exactly Wesley
must be much better oh this has been
disastrous uh the last few moves for Al
Resa from a position which felt
dominating he has to now save it defend
this yes he's trying to save it there's
no question King G6 that was a nice move
C2 over Rook behind the pawn F7 King F5
that was a lovely move F7 def might have
been enough to save it you run towards
the C2 pawn and you you pray that the
Pawn King King and pawn ending is6 King
D5 well you take the pawn you take the
pawn there's nothing to do you can't you
you you you can't sit there and wait for
for for black to improve his position is
the clock what are the clock times time
it's six seconds follow R are 5 Seconds
for Wesley the pawn on E3 is defended
and King E2 draw A4 let's go draw
problem King D3 you take the opposition
easy draw yes and that's it and we saw
Wesley move back he knows that there's
nothing to be done here uh I think both
players are going to be relieved there
Peter because it just felt like one game
remains and that at the end felt like a
six time repetition with the King Ray
Robson defending the Lena position here
which should be a
forlorn foror hope really rookie five
please thank
you what every Russian school boy has
learned
and the Lucina y was going to be in town
in December as well sorry y was going to
be in town in December oh very nice GM
and Rez and that's it The Rook is going
to defend uh where do you move with your
king actually what is rookie one wasn't
really all that precise he have do
necessary he'll have to do it all over
again but he will he will do it yeah and
let's Also let's also just break down
the Lucina for uh for everyone watching
who might not be familiar with it it's
about building a bridge yasa exactly
well the whole idea of course is we want
to promote our pawn and our King is
currently on the Square where where we
cannot move our pawns so we got to get
the king out of the way and we keep
getting harassed by these Rook checks
Rook D5 for Rook E3 and so what we need
to do is build a bridge and now Rook to
D4 with the idea of playing Rook to G4
and that's the handshake and the Lucina
position and that's the finishing touch
and we saw resignation there once it's
uh carefully executed and that was our
final
game wow I feel like once again I'm just
holding my breath and just we can just
let it go a lot of things going on Peter
uh starting with that game uh between
ala fera and Wesley so where FIA once
again say Sayed this move D2 D3 saying I
will play all kinds of theory a full
Tempo down C5 once against the once
again the reply we saw Anish giri go e
takes D5 here in the rapid replied to
his D3 D4 Wesley takes with the knighta
says I don't care Pawn down positions
are great I'm going to play all of them
and uh aren't you in a groom Feld of
sorts this is more of a Catlin I think
this is a or grimfield perhaps with
colors reversed right and uh it looked
like ala had a reasonably Pleasant
position here if you if you look at the
position somewhere here the bishop Pawn
E6 seems very strong uh the black Rooks
are denied access to uh to the B8 square
but then it became crazy and very very
quickly actually uh somewhere here it
still seems like well things are
reasonably sane let's say but then the
black queen got into the the white
position and things uh became very crazy
somewhere here already as you can see
control has been lost it seems whitee
might still be better but control very
much has been relinquished and we
started watching from here honestly uh
it never felt like alira had it good
here he's already a pawn down the the
other one getting picked up on the six
is also uh is also falling so uh
yes he has some threats but objectively
I think he was fighting for a draw all
the way through starting from here and a
very nice recovery by him not to lose
the game very nice and as for Yan's game
against uh Sam seian this was a a quti
affair where Yan once again played this
very early A4 A5 uh and then only Then
followed up with uh C3 and B4 and we we
got to this symmetrical uh Italian
position with like going D5 and
eventually Yan as is very thematical in
these positions uh pushed himself
resulting in this uh situation where
suddenly there was there were a lot of
Pawns in the sent and now there are none
uh and I think Sam very correctly
because you have to do something while
white has full control over the eile S
very correctly started blowing up the
queen side and C yeah once once we got
here draw was I think inevitable pretty
pretty much inevitable thank you for
that Peter uh do the honors please Tanya
what's our standings after 13 very
eventful rounds of Blitz indeed we are
going into round 14 and this is where we
are Maxim VRA keeps his lead with half a
point ahead of yan pami we had only two
decisive games three draws and this has
been the mix up now there's a half point
gap between the top four players with
Fabby at 17 and a half Ali RAR with 17
points uh and then again after Liam we
see a 1 and a half Point difference it's
still extremely close and tight at the
top what around 13 we had and we've got
Anastasia with a further breakdown
Anastasia what got your
attention I was actually analyzing both
games which had decisive results and you
CAU the the ending of both of the games
the first one was between lein Liam and
Fabiano Karana things started to get a
little bit shaky here Fabiano decided to
take on C4 first and then decided to
play this move E5 um weakening a little
bit his King side and square F5 and
that's what Liam decided to go for he
immediately played Knight H4 asking the
questions what about this F5 Square in
case if you play moves like G6 of course
you don't want to do something like that
because definitely your opponent will
sacrifice something soon or later so
Queen f8 was played Queen A4 A6 and then
um white got I think quite good position
and it I think was more difficult for
fit to play all the way this game and um
you can see even here that already so
many threats like n just six after C
takes B5 or Bishop D6 are coming so he
played the move King H7 was which maybe
was not so good one but very natural to
play especially in Blitz and I must
admit that Liam played a very very good
game he kept things under control for a
long time but still Fabby had one moment
where he probably could escape with a
draw it happened let's say the moment
you were started to analyze already
somewhere around here um he could have
tried to play Move Rook D2 and after
like obvious F3 there was a nice streak
he could play Knight F2 and famous draw
yes after could follow after take the
bishop and King H1 of course you don't
want to play King F1 because they're
going to be Checkmate on F2 so then um
he could have escape with this nice nice
move Rook D2 but he didn't play this
move and then you saw the ending what
happened after and as for the game
between um Ray Robson and Jeffrey Jong
uh you saw the ending you The Rook
ending and um the way Jeffrey converted
it things were quite I mean drawish for
the most of the game it was Petro
defense from the very beginning and um I
thought the game would finish in a draw
I mean the move 40 30 nothing was
changing that much until the moment that
um um Jeffrey found some kind of play on
the king side and he tricked his
opponent and managed to win this Pawn
even though it was not that important
white could still try to keep control if
he would have taken this bishop on F6 at
one point uh but it didn't happened and
then let's say Ray started to play Not
So precisely and after a few mistakes
ended up in this um Rook ending which
eventually finished um with a victory of
um Jeffrey Jong so not so great event
for R opson so far these last days but
what to do it's bleit and uh now it's
time to go for a commercial break and
before that let's find out what how
players adjust their style according to
the different time
controls
[Music]
Grand chour has different time controls
rapid bleit and Classics how do you
adjust your playing style or strategy
depending on the time control yeah it's
very different going from one time
control to the other I think I I mean I
just got back from I man so switching
from classical to Rapid might be tricky
so I think it's important to play some
training games to sort of adjust to that
and then and yeah sort of go from there
uh so yeah I really enjoy playing rapid
and Blitz it's much shorter than
classical and lot less stressful usually
you have more fun playing I think the
main difference is when there's less
time on the clock you can take more
risks because the opponent doesn't have
much time to punish you so uh I think
that's basically how most people play
they play a lot more aggressive more
tactical games than usual and that's
probably what I'll try to do as well
yeah by now I'm used uh to this mix of
typ control so you know I try to know
what I do best anyway play fast and put
pressure so of course that's obviously
easier busing rapid and in Blitz some
I've been struggling in the Blitz in the
last few tournaments I've played I've
been doing better in the rapid um that
didn't chose to be the case uh but I
prepared specifically for for the bleed
as well um because I feel this uh first
tournament will be important I like the
format because you play all kind of
Chess so and and adjusting to it is kind
of easy because the tournaments are a
bit look like longer like for one is in
June one is in July so you can adjust
slowly but um in general I'm big fan of
the format you play all kind of Chess
and you will see who's the best then
yeah this is this is a definitely a
challenge to do uh not only for the
players I think it's fun to try some
different things but also probably for
the people watching it's interesting to
see some Blitz and some some rapid and
uh because they all have their own own
peculiarities so um and we see some guys
who are more uh i' say more motivated
for some time control or for others
because they enjoy it more so it it'll
definitely be interesting to see yeah I
mean takes a while to get used to it
definitely I think it's a very different
game between speed chess and classical I
guess as I heard from another player he
just got to keep improving on chess you
know try to play your own game try to
play better and what you turn in
classical will hopefully move itself to
Rapid and BD yeah I'm very bad at
adjusting my style usually I'm always
one step behind so after I finish the
Rapids tournament I'm like I figure out
how to play the rapid and then already
Blitz and I'm too slow and then I'm like
just in the mood for the Blitz and then
comes the classical and I'm kind of uh
too fast again so I'm always a step
behind but I I'll try I don't think
really you know this sort of adjustment
works at all it's just about your your
condition if it's good is good if it's
not then then Alice well for me here
it's just B and Blitz so I guess I don't
have to adjust that much although
there's still some adjustment between
rapid and Blitz I think for me Blitz is
easier because I play Blitz way more
often even just casually rapid is
difficult I think uh somehow it's in
between classic and Blitz and those are
the two that I play more commonly so for
me it's difficult to adjust so I think
the only way is to just uh play more
games and practice more so lately I have
been practicing this quite a bit I play
some title Tuesdays something online um
rapit I have not been playing that much
um mainly J chesto event and also in
bill in July this year I play some rabit
there and as well as World Cup but um
I'm very excited to see how I would do
because I haven't played such a strong
uh tournament in Rapid and place for a
long
[Music]
time
the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious is cop and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 cran
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out hello I'm women's Grand Master Jona
I will be creating content for Grand
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the S
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
[Music]
today welcome back everyone with five
rounds remaining it is tight at the top
uh going into round 14 let's take a look
at our standings and this is where we
are with five rounds remaining Maxim
vasher lra holding on to his lead but
just by half a point ahead half a point
all the way down from second third and
fourth as well absolutely yes and then
Li on a fifth position with 16 points
and then there's a bit of Gap but that
said Wesley so has made a lot of
progress in the blitz can he keep up the
momentum it's all about the top four
right now and look at the matchup that
we have 14th round coming up oo big 14th
round coming up and a big matchup coming
up with Fabi taking on Yan pesi that has
got to be our Mo match up absolutely we
also keep a close watch on the mvl
versus Ray Robson as mvl just Clinging
On as you say half point lead Sam seon
versus fua as the players are getting
ready for this 14th round I've just seen
a Topsy Turvy Affair I'm just not sure
who's who's ready to claim the event
it's impossible to predict uh and we saw
Liam in round 13 take down favano Carana
we're seeing the leaderboard take down
NV those were two great games and these
two players uh Peter one of these two
players has got to put their stamp on
this event otherwise it's going to be
mvl mvl is going to say if you guys
don't do it absolutely I I slipped up I
gave you a chance one thing I wanted to
point out though is that uh fabibi very
much being in the running is very bad
news for people in terms of G GCT
standings because even if he doesn't win
this event it looks unlikely now that he
will finish outside the top three yep
and that means he will that he will
definitely be leading the G standings
going into the singfield cup absolutely
absolutely right good point and uh for
nepo uh with the black pieces against
Fabby what's his mindset T Jan Bashi has
been playing brilliant chess on day one
of the Blitz and he continues that uh on
day two as well it's a confident neppo
he's played the he his score is also
very reflective of the quality of the
games that we've been seeing Fabby has
had an up and down day on day one it was
plus one for him on day two he's W some
he lost the last round so I think it
will be about Fabby making a recovery
from his loss against Liam uh and as we
were talking about earlier from the
grand chestor perspective the overall
standings it's important for Fabby to at
least finish close to the top Absolut
this would be bad news for those who are
following him including Yan Nai
including Ali Resa and Maxim vasher lra
and we've got got action we've got the
English opening on the board C4 and E5
uh by the way just to butress the point
that uh Peter made it the opening of the
show nepo was one of those players well
not one of those players he was the
player who didn't uh make a single draw
in day one of the Blitz and uh how many
draws has he had far I think he's he
made a couple now which is very
regrettable very regrettable should not
be allowed by the way uh beat takes E3
E4 the most challenging I want to say
because after the move Queen E7 the
Knight is going to get trapped if you
allow H6 and D5 that would be
embarrassing to this Knight on H3 hence
the move F3 and my goodness look at the
players play they have been they are
going quickly into a position where
white one upon not the most
beautiful uh
beus uh Pond structure you've ever seen
uh doubled C pwns doubled e ponds but
weigh in on this one Peter is this
Theory surprising to me to be honest uh
I understand that black will always have
some compensation because White's uh not
very Mobile in the center but you are a
full Pawn up with with a bishop pair to
to boot I'm guessing the justification
would be that this dark SC Bishop is
extremely restrained and Yan playing H5
and the H fall on your screen there very
quickly further restrains it by saying
you can't even bring it out while let's
say G2 E1 G3 right uh and white will
struggle to do anything in the center
here because you really don't want to be
playing G3 G4 and weakening this
entire uh and I want to say this is a
bathtub I've never seen before because
the bathtub structure normally looks a
bit different but this is a kind of a
reinforced bathtub by white um Tanya
were you were aware of the bathtub uh
struct structure uh double c e pawns and
a Pawn on D3 I was not by the way I mean
uh the it's a smaller reinforced bathtub
because normally it would be C4 G3 E3 F4
normally again it would be C4 G3 C4 D3 a
e3 F4 would be a e3 yes that okay very
good this one this one is a perhaps
a a small a smaller but a fortifi
smaller that
a crib a cot a crib once you see it you
can't unsee it interesting Bond
structure there in the Santa meanwhile
Yana continues to try and keep the
Bishops as restricted as possible not
the Bishops so much as the dark Square
Bishop he's trying to restrict so what
Peter had mentioned earlier was that in
case the dark Square Bishop went from C1
to E1 to G3 that was the whole idea of
yan was to play play the move H4 so yes
we can go Bishop to E1 to F2 to G1 to H2
but you may not find your Bishop so
active or attractive if you will on that
diagonal eventually came the move D3 D4
and this is the siren Call for black to
play Knight A5 Tanya it's a really
interesting situation in the S though
with the four pawns and the king and the
bishop Bishop lined up it's crowded in
the center for white that we see
uh the piece placement well right now an
obvious but a big threat on the board
that you were pointing out uh forking
one of the pieces so it's time to start
uh striking at White spawn structure
absolutely Knight A5 and that's the big
question you I don't think you want to
play C5 I'm pretty sure you don't want
to play D5 um why did Fabby play D4 I do
not know I have no answer and Yan
seemingly isn't even interested in
Knight A5 this is all very confusing to
me why wow night A5 looks so obvious by
the way that's a uh a very famous line
from Dr Robert hner asked a question
Robert thought very deliberately and he
said I do not know and he answered very
Del but the the funny part about that is
for those of you who don't know who
Robert hner is Robert hner knows
everything about everything everything
about so when he said I do not know
confused everybody uh B D3 T this is a
it's just somehow White's done something
that
maybe don't you feel White's for Choice
suddenly why did he play G4 I I didn't
like the sequence of Bishop D7 followed
by G4 black is still not doing that
poorly but yeah I'm I'm not sure why
less and less yeah I'm not sure why the
very obvious option there was not
preferred over
this by the way uh important breaking
news uh our tournament leader uh mvl is
better much better against Ray Robson is
again mvl enjoying a half-point lead
depending on the outcome of this game if
we do have a
Victor yes will keep it's a big one
we'll keep a close watch on that but
right now sticking to this end game Rook
G7 played and the point that you were
making about the night jump trying to
Target the Pawns in the center I think
that was a really critical moment
because what you really want is to try
to force white to push that deep for
ahead leaving behind a lot of holes in
the position for the Knight to jump to
and that was a moment where you could
have enforced it by attacking the SEO
pawn and that was why we were both Peter
and I were so very confused why wouldn't
you want to encourage white to play D4
D5 as you said the moment you play D4 D5
you do leave behind two very crucial uh
um uh squares uh we're going to make a
quick switch here just to uh jump in on
the game of MV versus Ray Robson what a
moment to switch at we have a big move
bam
F6 blasting open raay King doubling up
his pawns and here it goes bam Bishop
takes H7 check and first first looks
that's game over and the reason is
because you've opened up both the G and
the H file if black was to capture the
bishop on H7 you first jump in with the
queen giving a check on H5 and The Rook
joins the party in the next move and
exactly hits the target from G3 it looks
over and The Black Queen on E7 actually
is stopping from escaping you whenever
whenever this Rook goes the King goes
back to f8 but gets M it on h8 because
the queen is actually in the way uh I'm
thinking you can't take the bishop and
Ry agrees he says taking the bishop
would have been deadly so he played King
G7 Bishop F5 Bishop takes F5 Rook takes
F5 again this is the big threat check
and mate so you got to get your Rook out
of the way Rook h8 so that your king can
actually raise one tempo short just one
tempo short If he if he wasn't time to
play Rook H6 and have the option of
meeting Queen G4 check with Rook G6 now
Rook H5 unfortunately I think is
borderline winning yeah and he's done it
but did you see the way Ray just made
the move Rook at six he almost just
threw the Rook it's just dejection from
him he knows his position is he know he
knows that was a huge move Rook H6 and
again just as you were mentioning Peter
it was just like your your Tempo shy of
uh putting up some serious resistance
and you can see the slouching show
shoulders there as Ray recognizes Rook
G6 this was a maxim V lra show it was it
was from start to finish F6 Bishop H7
fantastic attacking uh game there and
Rays just got to figure out how
maximize some resistance he's got to
play King E8 he's ready to meet a check
with a block you that's a skew of the pi
the F6 Pawn I know that's a good pickup
what do we got with two pawns down or
just one please who cares about the pawn
look at the black king there yes we
don't even need to do the math right
now but if you want to it is an extra
Pawn for white only one one extra Pawn
okay I mean you know Queen E7 trade
Queens I repair my position position
suddenly I mean that's what you've got
to play for you just hope that your
opponent helps you you need a lot of
help because white would not really want
to ever trade Queens in this position
you that would be a terrible decision
wouldn't it I would't be surprised if we
actually see Maxim at some point
starting to push the H Pawn down the
board forgetting about the king but that
combined with the attack on the king
will be undefensible agreed agreed it's
time actually he could have already
started with H4 absolutely agree and Ray
is
trying it's a very very narrow path but
he needs King E7 and Rook takes D5 and
he might he might have a
shout well actually the position that we
have maybe it is time to start pushing
the H Pawn already because you're not
getting to the black king immediately
everything is defended around it the C8
square is defended and there we have it
Maxim combining pce activity with that
extra Pawn push well let's take a look
so is it now consequential
H4 King
E7 H H5 Rook takes
D5 H6 H6 um can't take it because F7 is
hanging exactly no I think H6 is
actually he offers a queen trade Queen
G6 please trade Queen well Queen
takes you think he's going to go for the
sun game might be just winning it might
be two connected past pawns right H5 and
G4 he's reaching for the Queen and he
has done it so like I said it was that
extra
Pawn extra two pawns well actually the
connected F spawns you L the5 Rook takes
G6 uh H5 on the board the pawns are
pushing but is this trivial I wouldn't
call rook and pwn games somehow are
never trivial they're always and they
all taking a very interesting decision
giving up on H5 to to to keep control
and to take on D6 and respond
I'm not sure I wouldn't have played G4
automatically there Peter I just
actually quite like it I think
centralizing the king is just always
going to be a very good idea now we play
G4 Rook takes D6 and I think we win very
comfortably G4 and Rook takes D even
King takes C4 as you can see there by
reaching yeah well Rook takes A2 and the
game flares a new doesn't it he doesn't
want to allow D5 I understand why he's
doing that yeah well check I don't know
why we're doing okay uh I guess he wants
the King on the war Square he feels it's
very well placed on e4 and now it will
drop back a square but it I felt it was
very well placed on F3 too right
controlling the G2 Square from where
black can actually defend those pawns so
now and now we just go in G4 King F4
King G5 I think we should be winning
here agreed so even though the pawns
will be in balance it is two Pawns of
black two Pawns of white but in the race
white is far ahead exactly uh Tanya
that's exactly it the pawns are going to
be on H6 and G5 and you're still going
to be with well in the starting block on
in the me Fab is one correct move away
from being absolutely winning against
Jan and a massive massive it's game over
actually let's just jump to Fabby versus
W it's over and Fabiano has one
against huge win for Fabby it's
Checkmate on the board uh we will come
back to this but and let's go back to
Ray and our tournament leader
mvl putting the finishing touches on
what we think is a winning rook and pun
endgame that suddenly you don't trade
right came well where do I go with the
Rook Rook good question6 might be the
only move that might not have been very
clever A1 is Chick oh my God has Maxim
messed this
upil might be worse whoa and the whole
point is that the King on G7 is the
worst place squ The Rook went to G6 it
it it found itself trapped on B6 and the
queen but black queens with a check that
passes the tempo to black but Lu luckily
for mvl The Rook on B5 has no checks so
this is probably still a draw but this
is a huge turn around that's a
heartbreak for mvl from the position he
had and now well for Ray this is just he
saves the day remarkable and yeah rook
and fun end games like I said I mean
there's so many resources never trivial
ooh a B5 yeah no I think that's okay
okay I was about I was about to say
shouldn't we be starting with Rook Rook
to G1 no we can still do that and oh
this is such a big Miss by Maxim who
played such an excellent game the
sacrifice in the middle game this game
is heading for a draw I just want to say
the executive unfortunately there yeah
this is just going to be a draw how did
for
G1 with Sam he's going to pick up B3
he's going to pick up G6 the players are
going to find a way to trade Rooks
there's a check there's an interception
and that is it this ends in a draw Ry
Robson relieved Maxim VRA bid a big
Miss which means of course that uh Fabby
is now tied with mvl for first and this
is our final game we've got Jeffrey
enjoying an extra Pawn but not enough
now Fabi still half a point behind
because I think he was a full point
behind and V uh y was Yan was half a
point yes that's correct oh I'm sorry it
was yes you're right it was Yan in in in
the clear second Point by half a point
Jeffrey is whoa what happened there
Jeffrey lost an end game he really
should not have lost and I think he even
maybe resigned in a position which was
still holdable what I think Jeffrey is
uh just not enjoying himself and F kind
of tilted King F2 is a draw yeah the
final position is still a draw but he
just yeah just didn't but he in in this
final position P maybe you can take he
didn't look like he flagged I think he
just resigned yeah unbel like I think he
didn't realize that even in this
position if King C2 has Knight D4 check
if Knight B2 has Knight E3 he is still
perfectly in control but right I think
he just wants this tournament to be over
by this point is really not going well
for him brutal brutal um that uh Fab
nepo game we we were kind of oh please P
what what what were you focused on sorry
Fabi we we've seen the start in the end
but in the middle there what happened in
the middle yeah starting from here uh we
left it somewhere around here and Yan
for some reason he played Bishop A6
Bishop F1 was a clever little little
trick by Fabby seems like we're just
protecting the pawn on G2 but what we're
also doing is we're playing C5 and the
bishop can no longer be taken with a
check so once the bishop we we can
include C takes D6 and this is a massive
massive Improvement for white because we
actually got rid of one of our absolute
worst pawns on the board traded it for
healthy one on C7 and now we are Pawn up
with a decent structure Bishop against
Knight weakness on H4 which weakness on
F6 and Fabby ended up winning this
reasonably comfortably the other two
games I I kept my eye on a little bit
where the game between uh
eventually uh please yeah uh Wesley
against Anish which was actually a
fantastic game uh where this there is
this crazy variation of the anti Berlin
where black goes Bishop G4 here not with
the intention of taking but with the
intention of sacrificing this piece and
this normally this normally leads to a
very strange position I think they
uh it's it's takes too long to describe
but basically previous practice would
result almost by force by with players
by move 20 having a strange position
where White Steel is a piece up black
has pawns on F4 G3 and H4 but they're
completely blockaded and then you have
to prove you're better with this extra
piece but Anish actually I think he
burned an important little idea for a
Blitz game here surprising Wesley a
great deal Wesley played King H1 here F5
Queen E1 F4 Knight takes E5 although
this is still best machine moves and
here uh as you can see this is still
some correspondence games uh Rook f8 uh
Bishop D4 Rook F6 and here uh the engine
was showing something completely
unbelievable I will not be able to even
reproduce it I don't think but there was
some line I saw on my screen which I was
sort of refusing to believe
completely uh I think it went something
like the main move here was F3 after
Rook H6 check you were supposed to allow
King G2 Bishop H3 no this is wrong right
because
weion to to Bishop H 4 but the point was
in the Blitz game if you don't know what
you're doing here you're very likely to
go wrong and this is what happened uh
King G1 Bishop H3 Rook F2 Bishop H4
already this is a lot of trouble Wesley
maybe thought he still somewhat in
control but Queen d8 very very clever
move attacking the bishop on D4 and also
creating a threat of Queen G5 check uh
and somewhere here there's just no
defense against H7 H5 and Anish win's a
very important game against Wesley
Wesley after a very good day yesterday
today is struggling seemingly and Anish
is gaining gaining steam but there's
probably not enough games in the
tournament for him to come into
contention for the really top places but
he will improve his GCT point standings
well with each Victory your confidence
sores Tanya do the honors please tell us
uh about the standings uh after well uh
14 rounds well let's take a look four
games remain and it is Maxim vasher lra
still at the top with the tiniest of
margins half a point Ray Robson with
that miraculous save against Maxim and
I'm sure the other players were also
rooting for Ray in that position they
want to keep that margin as little as
possible and it is Fabiano kwana at
second place clear second there again
just only half a point ahead of yan and
the story line continues all the way to
that fifth position Anish with that win
uh slips up to the sixth spot and for
more highlights from round 14 we're
going to head over to
Anastasia thank you T but actually you
stole my show because I kept my eye on
the game between Maxim and Ray Robson
and then you understood that this is the
game and you switched to to that one but
let me show you at the beginning how
things were developing after this Knight
D5 move um Knight takes D5 it takes D5
maybe black could have tried to trade
this uh Central Pawn for the pawn on the
king side after Bishop H7 King H7 I
don't want to say that it's ideal
situation for black and it looks a
little bit dangerous but maybe it was
really good good alternative compared to
what happened in the game but still even
Bishop C
was quite fine move after that but look
at F4 very very straightforward move by
Maxim which paid off later so Knight D7
is still fine F5 and here probably
Bishop G5 was too was too much for black
he could have just tried to stop this
Pawn play Knight F6 and just develop
later with B5 and Bishop B7 Rook E8 I
mean position is quite fine after that
but he played with Bishop G5 allowing
all this play and what happened after so
from here things are really wrong for
black and he got into trouble as we
could see later in the game and this
crazy ending where um Ray Robson managed
to escape was of course very very
interesting to follow um and also the
second game which you also checked the
the end was between Jeffrey Jong and
leang Liam I think yes I mean it's
psychologically difficult probably to
play against these top players and the
fact that Jeffy resigned in the drawi
position probably also shows how hard it
is how much pressure he has on his
shoulders during this tournament um and
the game was pretty equal until certain
point um let's say the I mean the
balance I mean they have same amount of
Pawns um let's say the ending is pretty
equal so probably he just kind of
started to tilt somewhere where he lost
um his his pawn and enter descending
which normally he would still try to
keep but um I really don't understand
some of his decisions for example some
whatat somewhere here normally you don't
try you try to keep Queens on the board
in this type of situations you don't go
to the knight's ending um I mean King H2
was quite a good alternative but he
played Queen E1 trading the queens and
maybe he would have saved this ending
but normally you don't do this you don't
go uh to the knight's ending with a pawn
down I mean normally it's technically
lost position but I just want to show
the very end yes I Peter mentioned uh
This Moment that he just could simply
play something like um King F2 uh and
position is still I mean after D2 let's
say if sorry something happened to my
board so this position yes it's drawish
uh but it's really hard maybe yes to
play at this moment he was also tired
and disappointed with how the game went
after so with on this note let's go back
to the studio to follow the the next
rounds thank you Anastasia I just wanted
to say that that final position was
worth taking a look at and what
Anastasia wanted to show you all was
that after the move King F2 if you play
D2 now it's you get to play King E2 and
after King C2 it appears we can't stop
no we were in time with a check King C1
we're in time for yet another check and
that would have been drawn and it I once
you get into this mind set where you see
that you're losing or feel that you're
losing and you're having a bad
tournament Peter it's very hard to get
out of that it is very difficult to
shake often I think Ray not Ray sorry
Jeffrey uh Jeffrey has perhaps won two
games in the entire rapid and Blitz
including the rapid section and it must
be a very difficult feeling to have to
continue showing up and continue playing
when it really isn't going your way and
everybody seems to be ganging up on you
uh he will obviously look back on this
and think this is a bit silly but uh
it's understandable uh Tanya uh it it's
tight at the top but let's uh let's peek
ahead and see the roads for uh the top
players we'll start with round 50 we'll
start with the matchups uh that are
about to begin and it's four very
crucial games as you said yes it is
crowded at the top with just a half
point lead for maxim VRA who faces
Jeffrey Jong and we've been talking
about Jeff play Jeffrey it's a good time
to play against a player who is having
well and for I I completely agree with
Anastasia psychologically so difficult
when you're on this losing streak to
come out to have this will to fight so
Maxim bashra can he score a big much
required Point against Jeffrey our other
player Yan naami is playing against Liam
who actually beat Jeffrey in the
previous round and yes versus K that's
the Marquee
matchup let's peek ahead uh show us the
16th round pairings and what mvl and
Fabby are facing yeah let's look into
the future a little bit because really
the next few rounds are super Critical
with again just a half point the
slimmest of leads there and we see uh
Maxim V lra will be playing against
Wesley now Maxim starts this round
against Jeffrey and he play and he plays
Wesley in the next one to me these are
two players who are not in their best
shape right so it might be uh the
pairings where Maxim wants to strike
what are your thoughts on this agreed uh
Jeffrey could play the role of spoiler
equally well he could play the role of
Santa and start giving a lot of gifts uh
Fabby versus Anish Gary Anish Gary will
be very pleased with himself having
beaten Wesley with the black pieces 17
yes have and also just we will switch to
round 17 we also saw Yan will be playing
Jeffrey Jang in round 16 so another
pairing that Santa Claus be Christmas
coming a little early there FIA neppo
ooh
that is a spicy spicy match up right
there and then we have MBL versus Sam
seon that'll be very nice Fabby versus
Ray Robson but it's all about round 15
coming up let's jump back to the current
situation absolutely yes I need uh to
figure out where is my round 15 I don't
have my round 15 we will bring our round
15 with the matchups and the road ahead
that we just saw to me it feels that
Maxim it's really his moment right now
the next three games that are coming up
he can get he has opportunity doesn't he
he does have a big opportunity there
Peter even though playing Black against
Wesley is normally not not a dictionary
definition of of an easy game Wesley
today is not Wesley Wesley of yester
yesterday he was uh quietly tied for
second in in a blitz tournament in the
separate Blitz tournament they played
yesterday he tied for second with Yan
today his play seems to not be the same
crisp crisp Blitz that he played last
night so we'll see we'll see how that
goes Ali Raza versus for Fabby coming up
Fabby just one a crucial game against
nepo there no matter how you put it nepo
just kept slipping slipping slipping but
his opening idea there was remarkable
and I
think the result not indicative how what
a decent positioning it surprised us all
I think that you can just give up a pawn
like this in an opening and just play
quiet but I think had he played the
middle game well he would have been
completely fine right that whole night5
idea why he didn't play why we will
never know play night5 will but it is
Blitz and these things happen and
eventually Fabiano Carana showed some
really nice technique in the end to
convert that a very important Victory
and as you said yes it will be all eyes
on Ali are taking on Fabby an extremely
crucial game for our standings as the
players are walking into the playing
Hall we see Anish and andela yeah let me
just set this up a little bit further
Ali reaza comes in to this St Louis
rapid and Blitz as our defending Grand
chess tour Champion it was a scant one
year ago that well we didn't expect much
from Ali Raa he came into St Louis he
did this nice interview where he said
you know what guys it's been my dream
since I was a little boy to come to St
Louis and play these exalted Masters
little did you know that two weeks later
he'd be walking out with a bounty of
trophies as he won the rapid and Blitz
he won the S Phi cup he won the $100,000
bonus for winning the grand chest Tor
now he's up against Fabby who is equally
in the position that uh uh Ali Raza had
a year before he is leading the
tournament and Ali resa is not a little
boy anymore he's a big beast in these
formats the world number one Blitz
player he's taking on Fabby he's
trailing Fabby by a point so if he's
able to win with the white pieces that's
going to be a that's going to be a big
news for him and there he is with a he
looks like he's enjoying the moment
right and I'm still thinking about the
first rapid game the very first day of
the St of the St Louis rapid he won
where he won a in great style actually
he did can he repeat it it's he starts
with the white pieces as he did in that
game as well and I remember his
interview where he said I don't know why
Fabby keeps repeating these openings
with me he never gets a good
position well here we go this is this is
such a big game and again for fuja like
I said the the game he lost to mvl
earlier today that would have enraged me
because you blunder a piece and then you
come so close to drawing the game and
you let it slip away uh what kind of um
I want to say angst will he have I think
he's got to play for the win uh Peter uh
this is this is a no bars hold them
event you just play all out those are
old words word salad it's all yours
those are old
words no I mean no seriously but I agre
with the sentiment yeah you you got to
play for for for win and if it means
taking excessive risks
you remember yesterday threepiece
sacrifice
by Fabiano car oh my God an event Rook
F1 Rook F6 Rook G6 let go let's go that
was a game on fire but Fabby really
interestingly said that you know he just
kept on playing he knows it's Blitz he's
probably lost he has to take his chances
some great practical decisions there uh
against his game against Ali Rea that
was exactly uh Ali Rea was in a winning
position but complications and Fabby
came on top and it's handshakes and
who's going to come on top this time you
called it a great gamble Peter and will
we see another one Joo Joo piano but
Hungarian variation with Bishop to E7 so
none of these Bishop
G5 H6 Knight takes G5 sacrifices the
bishop stays at home just to make sure
that Bishop G5 doesn't cause any issues
D7 D6 very quietly black said look I'm
going to trade off my Bishop on E6 show
me your opening Advantage Tanya I mean
my my brain turns to Mush when I see so
many Joko pianos I don't know you know
like what's the novelty any anymore I
mean who played this the first time
around how about you forever ago right
first time around but the point is that
these positions are so complex because
the different move orders that white can
have uh and and they tend to switch it
up and it's so difficult to keep track
of uh all these small advancements you
put your Pawn on A3 do you put your Pawn
on A4 the Knight can come from C3 can
come from D2 but we see a little
nonstandard Italian structure in this
one where a trade has happened on C4
white has doubled the pawn but in return
gets control of the dile and the D5
Square as well starts expanding on the
queen side and notice how without the
light squared Bishop the F5 Square
becomes also a bigger Target for White's
Knight to jump to uh We've Just Seen A
rerouting the Knight on C6 Fabby judged
in his estimation didn't have a future
on D7 the pawn on C4 is potentially weak
also this Knight can jump to D5 whenever
white would like and maybe you want to
have the move C7 C6 to give it an
eviction notice in the moment it just
feels like a nice um space Advantage for
white again the double ponds do serve an
a practical function of preventing d65
as long as the pawn stays on D6 this
bishop on f8 remains passive so it's
just a strategic fight and uh trench
warfare at the moment absolutely I think
for black at some point you want to make
a move like A5 you want to try to
provoke white to perhaps push the B Pawn
and create some dark Square weaknesses
you'd be eager for that to happen A5 B5
and as you said then then you've got a
C5 Square Knight to D2 I like like this
move it's not like you You' mentioned
the F5 Square bit it's not like you
could put your knight on F5 and expect
Victory with this move Knight to
D2 White's kind of intimating that he's
ready to put some energy into Knight A5
and just trying to make inroads on The
Queen side Peter you have a lot of
experience in these E4 E5 structures how
do you judge this position this is a
rare structure though it's I don't think
anybody has much much uh A5 as you said
on the volume specifically in the
structures in the structures where black
takes on C4 and then nothing happens for
a while but honestly black is sort of
more mobile long term I I quite like
what Fabby has here I think this is I
think it's somewhat easier to play with
black you can play G6 you can put the
queen on C7 maybe play H6 H5 at some
point I was about to say you're after a
move like Queen D2 you're being
questioned do you want to play H5 and
your answer you can also play King H7
there is nothing really wrong with King
H7 either but uh and I was a bit
surprised I can sort of understand the
the thinking behind it but uh ala play
B2 before before so confidently I would
have kept it on B3 frankly I don't like
that we've created a potential Target on
C4 but this is maybe my uh semi-
pensioner thinking you know I I I feel
pensioner I I feel that you know
creating weaknesses in my own Camp is
more important and kind of it is is a
bigger Factor than perhaps denying black
the C5 Square well Knight A4 was a Road
to Nowhere Tanya and it's come back home
to C3 that didn't have future so it does
return the a file has opened up though
so you're trying to trade off or control
the a line the one thing that white
always has to watch out for is a D5
break right now white has got four two
pawns and two pieces controlling the
square but you have to make sure that
black in this case Faby he doesn't land
with a successful D5 break so you have
to make just don't allow that to happen
it just feels to me like there's a lot
of toing and throwing by both players as
Knight on F3 kind of like toward the
board uh what you know was going to go
to F5 and nothing really happened so um
trench warfare at certain moment I was
expecting a rook to come to the defile
so at least I would would have a a C4 C5
Type of a break uh but at the moment it
you both players just going back and
forth back it's a lot of maneuvering and
in that process getting a few pawns
traded a pawn push here and there
creating some weaknesses but that's the
nature of how the Italian or Spanish
positions go there is a lot of two and
four from the pieces before an eventual
break in the center exactly we're just
seeing the move F2 F3 again keeping the
Cavalry away from the business squares
of f4 and G4 I'm expecting King
G2 I would not whoa whoa well I was
about to say I wouldn't want to trade
dark Square Bishop until I realized
there is a weakness Peter on D6 it will
be it's more or less impossible to
attack it with anything rather than the
heavy pieces and the heavy pieces
there's an equal amount of them on the
board so I don't think D6 bothers F deal
yeah I think it's probably still very
much within the uh equality margins but
in Practical terms I think it's easier
to play with black you don't see the D6
bound as a weakness why there's you you
can triple up on the D file and I will
just play Rook d8 Rook D7 Rook e G8 and
there's you'll meet me anytime I try to
go on the D5 yeah there's already in the
current position there there was an
option for a B7 B5 break because the
pawn on C2 is currently hanging So you
you're not actually sacrificing a pawn
there but fby decides against I'm pretty
sure he considered it he is hinting at
D6 D5
perhaps if white does nothing right now
we can take on A1 and then play G5 next
move but white is unlikely to do nothing
and ala takes one pair of Rooks off and
puts the Rook on D1 I it's not that I'm
you know gung-ho about White's play it
it is a position I always found it
easier personally uh when I see a pawn
weakness like this stands out like a
sore Thum and I've always found it
easier to play uh um against a weakness
than rather defending it so I'm thinking
it's easier to play White Tanya you're
you break the tie between Peter and I
Peter likes black flexibility I like the
fact that I can see and Target a
weakness you I I've played these
positions a little bit with black so you
have volume I kind of I'm going to break
the tie and I'll say that I wouldn't be
unhappy to get this position with black
either I keep the D6 Pawn defended uh
when needed even if it means a night
Retreat from F6 uh to E8 I've got these
ideas when necessary of course I'm
always eyeing the D5 break I've got the
a file for now under control I was
actually a little worried about White's
Queen jumping on to B6 but I think the
point is that Queen B6 doesn't get you
anywhere not only is everything defended
but the Rook can actually slide up and
kick the queen out get go away you you
bother me uh yeah Queen B6 is something
that you you need to prep um I was a
little bit surprised by the move Rook D2
I like Rook D3 followed by Queen D2 uh
questioning your D Pawn you could in
that case as you said play Knight E8 or
maybe Rook d8 but in any case uh
pressing D6 Rook A3 so now Fabby is
basically saying okay since you're
playing it
passively uh let's see what your
intentions are and here we go Knight
comes E8 just as you prescribed and this
is what we were talking about right now
there it's impossible for you to you
putting further pressure on a D6 and how
do you how do you actually improve your
position you can't move the knight from
B3 the Knight jumps on to D4 you want to
keep that under control for sure if you
move the other Knight the Knight anyway
comes on to D4 because Knight on B3 will
be binned well I uh my friend Bruce
Harper and I uh wrote a book called King
walks and the idea is in a king walk is
you bring your king into that area of
the board that needs needs reinforcement
after I saw the move Rook A3 I like to
play King
B2 I'm going to March my king steadily
across the entirety of the chess board
and bring the king to the queen side and
you know reinforce you know uh as an
author of a book reinforce the work yeah
and that was an interesting choice and
look at that that's a big move by black
there and I like it because all of
White's forces are on the queen side and
I have a bad feeling for that white king
you take on G5 the queen jumps in I'm
threatening to land with my knight on F4
the H Pawn will move forward shredding
the king's defenses there and I just
feel that White's Army might be too far
away from his own King exactly I did not
like this Knight B1 C3 as played and I
think Fabby gun because there's Rook G2
we can take on G2
and correct he's blundered but maybe
there was nothing better to be done as
well I mean the position looked very
difficult with Knight F4 and H4 coming
in think just this is this is just a
terrible blunder told you blacks better
there yes it's just like easier to play
it's certainly turn out that way there's
no way there's no question about it not
only that but it's it's pawn and
compensation it's like now you know
I'm black is not only attacking he's
doing so did you see the way ala played
that Rook he's just playing he he's he's
not playing well he's the number one
player in the world but he's blundering
basic tactics right now he's threatening
Rook takes H4 that's the only thing he's
doing but I mean fabi's Fab's got this
game fabulous game by Fabby and not just
putting pressure on the board look at
the clock right there 5 seconds for ala
very difficult position to defend and
Fabby has enough time to pause at the
critical moment to wrap this up uh in a
concrete manner but we've seen
turnarounds we've seen people mess we've
seen the players mess up even more
winning positions
what are the CH re Robson what are the
chances of uh fuja with a miraculous
save well and anything can happen in
Blitz but having said that I mean really
if Fabby will have to blunder badly to
uh not win this game I think he's really
more or less got this game under WS
Peter jump in looks Terri thing to add
to this yeah this looks absolutely
horrible everything is going on pawns
are being captured and
well as fua is losing should we just
check in on mvl for a quick Gander there
yeah this one is about to finish any
moment and Fabby looks like he's about
to get the big win and those are three
versus two but black spawns are pushing
but wait a minute did yeah Queen wait
Who whoo who it's a race maybe gives a
check First and M it's it's Jeffrey Jong
playing under 10 seconds right now
as by the way Fabby did win as we
expected and that was a cute move
because we've got Queen A2 whoa Queen a
A2 to defend a so A7 he just double
checked and Queen H one still G Queen
only move Queen H1 by the way this is
this is not clear no I think black
should now be uh okay I think so too
right I mean the queen is ready to come
to uh
H one from H1 to A8 and then you get to
go G3 and G2 oh this may have been a
queen B8 Queen F3 check though it's
probably a Perpetual how easy how easy
it is to give in a practical game with a
king on G5 this might not be a Perpetual
because you cannot give checks from the
fifth oh gosh Jeffrey is playing as
though he's got this uh he's got a draw
in his pocket or something I don't
believe that it seems like the engine
agrees the question is just in practice
on 3 seconds do you ever make a wrong
check by mistake but seems like this is
fine Jeffrey is playing very confidently
it just feels like White Queen will
never find its way to actually block a
check anywhere with correct you have to
aim for squares closer to the black king
and hope oh that was Queen E5 game
over he nearly vot having said you can't
interposed the queen he nearly gave into
it it sure did oh my goodness it's
getting tricky now as the king gets
closer towards the White Queen right
there's there's no fighting place in the
corner I thought Queen F4 checked there
so you can't go King B6 was a little bit
more precise but the diagonal checks
that's a very key point that your king
will never get to eight because of the
diagonal check on B when you when you
get to B7 with your king but how can you
play this virtually perfectly with no
time on the clock he's showing us how
he's been doing it for the last by way
he's fallen into a peret yes that he's
done it uh Jeffrey saved a losing
position let's jump to the game of Ray
uh Robson as Wesley so as we do have a
tie on the top uh Faby uh defeating uh
the world's number one player uh Ali
Raza yes we do and we still have action
on in this one uh what's going on here
so I think it's the clock I think it's
all about the is he going to just trade
no he's playing for the
win it does look like Black's peace
activity white needs to be the one
careful yes because the black king is so
close what was that I mean this
nervousness is what it is nerves nerves
nerves exactly if the Rooks get traded
off that's draw on the spot so every
decision that Wesley takes to keep the
Rooks on he's ambitious
exactly and by the way the Knight can
maybe wow it's a lot of hesitation from
Wesley for sure Knight's coming to G3
with a check right the king oh you're
forcing the king to it you can't go to
E1 you have to go in the corner again
might still be fine though with the Rook
on A3 the king cannot really uh join the
the attack so the true Knight E2 check
Knight to D4 to F3 though Peter Bishop
G4 really stops really stops all of that
yes it does that was well and now it
seems that black really has no no way to
create threats but I like that Ray there
making sure he doesn't walk into some uh
Fork yeah and uh it feels like Wesley
has maximized every single piece on the
position but there's no progress to be
made with the rook and Bishop taking
away key squares from the king and the
Knight truly uh King G3 would walk into
a one move Checkmate Rook F3 uhoh uhoh
as I was about to say are we walking
into a nasty pin no Wesley just in time
to save his King and uh Rook yeah now
now who's playing nobody nobody nobody's
playing you're going to find a way for
the Knight to give up um the knight's
going to give itself up for the pawn
sure and that'll be the end of it Knight
F4 Knight H3 well
done nicely done there by back to being
friends
wow but we do have a tie on top we're
going to have to take another look at
those playoff uh things uh Peter where
was the action uh in the mvl Jeffrey
game they played a very very old school
French
with yeah and uh it seemed like uh
Jeffrey actually got a very nice
position out of the opening somewhere
around here G6 is a very clever move
here by the way using the pen and the
fact that D6 can be met by KN D5 and
they're posing and
the pawn on D6 is in trouble so he I
think somewhere here if anyone is better
it is black but uh mvl managed to
stabilize and they ended up in a
position uh like this which is already
very very level uh all the Rooks came
off and this is of course still very
much uh very much level but as you have
seen eventually became quite sharp uh
players continued uh continued pushing
uh black is trying to create something
on the king side while A5 and B6 could
potentially be targets and as you can
see three moves later we we have a we
have a race which eventually resulted in
that absolutely crazy uh Queen ending
that that we saw on our screen which
ended up being a draw and the game
between uh Ray and
Wesley was a quietist affair they played
this uh English opening which uh a bit a
bit later uh right now there's a lot of
pieces on the board
but uh 5 months later there's been a lot
of trading done in the center and then
some more trading being done and then
the Queens also come off and um it
looked like it was a very very level end
game but both players since no draw
drawers are allowed normally a game
maybe would have ended somewhere here
with a handshake but they played more
than 100 moves from here without
changing the results thank you Peter for
that and after 15 exciting rounds of
Blitz uh Tanya tell us the standings it
is a tie at the top with a tie the top
it's the tie of the top Fabian kaana
Maxim both at 19 and a half points so
yeah so I'm going to predict it we're
going to have those playoffs at the end
of the day we got Yan re recall our
playoff roles but yeah but Yan is the
trailing by a point as you were about to
say he is and alian Liam a point behind
Yan so still with the three rounds
remaining there is a lot to fight for
and for a further breakdown of the
action let's head over to Anastasia
yeah thank you Tanya and finally fa is
leading together with Maxim so we have
chances right so I was checking the game
between Yan pomes who is now in the
third place he played against leang Liam
and definitely he wanted to improve his
uh situation in the tournament and okay
it was really crazy opening stage very
creative from both sides and now we can
see that black are trying to create some
kind of an attack on the king side with
the King on f f so it can backfire
sometimes but still um lean Liam decided
to go for Olin he plays G4 and Yan I
mean didn't play the best let's say
moves but it's hard to actually
understand what are the best in this
situation um so here I mean he tried to
also open the center um getting some
counter play because I mean it seems
like black is coming with Queen G5 next
move so uh Queen G5 happened in the game
and F4 look at this I mean it's really I
mean every move plenty of variations
could have happened uh but Yan was
literally trying probably to make the
position as sharp as possible to get his
chances chances as well but he went a
little bit far here and after Queen D4
good move King H1 um Le leam played
Knight E3 winning the exchange but he
could have tried to play something
different like H3 was the move which is
again hard to spot and after GTX
completely crazy move computer of course
suggest Queen D3 uh trying to create few
threats like on the king side and also
like Bishop C3 threat followed by Queen
E2 um it I mean I'm sure that it would
be very difficult for Yan to defend here
but he didn't find this move he played
Knight E3 and after um Yan gave an
exchange things were not so bad for him
even though he was still suffering a
little bit but um after certain point he
just probably decided enough is enough
and went with a Perpetual check he could
have done it here but he played few
moves more and repeated the position
later in the game so it was the game
finished in a draw so Yan keeps one
point um difference between the leaders
and the second game I was checking was
between Anish giri and Sam savian also
very interesting theoretical battle I'm
sure both players knew it I don't know
till which moment I mean maybe somewhere
around here it was still on their boards
so I think that like move the four was
still ideas to fish giri but things went
wrong somewhere uh around this moment
black started to play quite um um you
know aggressively in a good sense trying
to to fight for initiative and um um I
think Anish literally didn't get it
somewhere and U after the trades of
Queens especially some somewhat around
here it would can can be clear for
everyone that that it's black who is
trying to win um this game an tried to
put some uh resistance but it was not so
well I mean King H3 probably doesn't
King should kind of go towards the
center but he played this maybe
emotional move King H3 and after that he
didn't get really chances in the game to
survive so this is how it finished Sam
Sean won the game and by the way um with
um I mean with this Victory it it means
that he has done plus two today and he
didn't lose even one game uh during this
second blit um they so really good for
Sam and now it's time to go for the
commercial break and before that let's
have a look at the chart which I had
with Fabby before the
[Music]
tournament abana welcome back to St
Louis your home uh welcome back to gr
stour how do you feel to come back here
after Grand Swiss it's just one week ago
the tournament has finished how did you
assess your result yeah it was it's good
to be back I I right before Grand Swiss
I was playing an event here the US Chess
Championship and I I had this event in
between which was a very very big and
influential event for a lot of players
and for me there was a little bit less
writing on it because I wasn't trying to
qualify for the candidates um but it was
a very exciting event anyway and uh
decided to places in the candidates
tournament so that was that was very
important vid and Nakamura made their um
had their success there and yeah for me
it was a little bit less um of an
exciting event let's say it was going
quite decently and then at the end I
kind of ran out of steam and the Finish
was very disappointing for me uh so
overall it wasn't like very negative or
very positive certainly a little bit
disappointing but I'm hoping that uh
what I'm looking forward to is that we
have rapid and Blitz now so it's a bit
of a change because I played in the last
uh few months mostly classical chess I
had how many games you played I
wonder quite played 11 in the US
Championship quite a long and tough
event and then 11 in the grand Swiss so
a little bit longer than average and
here we have uh in the singfield cup 9
classical games a little bit of a more
usual uh schedule but it's nice that we
have a kind of intereso before so we
have rapid and Blitz chest a little bit
let's say less pressure in terms of
preparation and and that sort of thing
and more based on like your current form
and how you're feeling your mood so I'm
hoping that I'll be in good shape for
that also for me it's very important of
course um because I'm In Contention in
the grand chest tour standings I'm in a
good position but last two events will
be very critical yeah for sure and
coming back a little bit to this the
candidates tournament and you sport
there I mean you you said that you
played in Grand swis with a strange
feeling yes that you were you already
qualified you reached your goal already
and how was it actually to play there I
mean having in mind that let's say you
don't need to to do so and what do you
think about the other players how
difficult it was for them yeah I can say
from experience at these events are a
lot of pressure and even this year when
I was playing the World Cup it was a
huge amount of pressure and I felt it
very strongly physical effects the
tiredness and everything and the grand
swis was a bit different because I
didn't really feel that pressure but I'm
not sure maybe it wasn't a good thing
like maybe it's better to feel that
drive to like uh you have to win this
game I I remember in The Grand swi in
2021 it was I I had to qualify for a
candidates by that tournament and I was
playing Ali Resa in penultimate round no
sorry two rounds before the end and I
kind of felt like I really need to win
this game and I was able to win it and
to secure Candace's qualification mostly
because of that win against al Resa and
this time I think if I needed to qualify
I would consider the game against deak
in two rounds before end again like
absolute must-win to get top two like
very very important to win this game and
I didn't have this feeling of like
intensity so maybe it also um sort of
let me down in a way in that sense while
during the World Cup I had a really
strong feeling of like intensity like
every game is super crucial so it it
gave me a lot of stress I I wouldn't say
it's like good for my health but maybe
it's good for tournament performance
yeah like for example Nakamura had to
try to win against you right in order to
get the spot in the candidates and
speaking about this tournament I mean
how often do you think about it you know
it's going to be on April there are so
many events in between and things to do
but still do you think about the event
and what do you think about the field
which we know already the candidates the
candidates yes let's say yeah I no I for
me it's the biggest event on the
calendar for sure like every event is
important every event I care about but
um
there's only one two events a year that
I really like um put all my effort into
preparation before the tournament and
everything like coming to singfield cup
I mostly have a normal schedule and for
candidates of course everyone is is
taking it so seriously because it's a
unique chance to play a world
championship match that and almost
always first place is the only one which
counts yeah last time it was a bit
unusual that second place ended up also
counting but usually you really need to
win so of course you need some luck in
order like you need the right
circumstances but you also need um very
good preparation and you need to be on
form so everyone takes it the most
seriously that they can and I I've
played many already uh so I have a lot
of experience but I sometimes I wonder
if this experience is like super
important or not because the first time
I played in 2016 I had no experience and
my preparation wasn't ideal let's say
looking back on it but somehow I almost
was able to to pull it
and Sergey Ken was the one who who
qualified for a world championship match
that time so sometimes I don't know if
it's more like experience or um
sometimes coming into it for the first
time like we'll see some players in next
one um is also like a huge motivation
like prag is the first time I think um
also
abasov I know he's not like 100% in but
uh but assuming he plays then it's also
first time for him and vidit as well so
we see a few first- timers here
I think it's it's both the most
interesting event of the Year besides
the world championship match but also um
for the players of course takes on a
unique amount of stress and uh pressure
yes so this what I wish you I mean all
the best of luck in this in this
tournament thank you thank you thanks
the
[Music]
2023 the whole Chess World is looking
forward to the candidates and right now
are we're looking forward to round 16
exactly well take us through it and tell
us about the standings T let's take a
look yes three games remain and this is
where we are for the first time in the
blitz uh we've got actually the first
time uh in the St Louis rapid and Blitz
we've got a tie at the top with five
players sorry not the first time clearly
long David we've got two at the top
Fab's at the top for the first time on
the leaderboard along with Maxim sh gra
and then in third position you've got
Yan with 18 and a half Ali RIS with
another Point deficit but tell us about
the pairings for this upcoming round 16
we've got a big round 16 coming up and
it is Yana pishi who's at 18 and a half
he needs to score a point against
Jeffrey Jang he starts with the black
PES Jeffrey has been struggling in the
event so far so it's a bit of an
opportunity there for Yan Ali RAR fuja
at 17 and a half takes on Liam l they're
both tight so really important game for
them to leave frog to go ahead in the
standing exactly we've got Fabby the
tournament the co- leader at 19 and a
half taking on his good friend Anish
giri what are our predictions for that
one well I'm just wondering who has the
easier task Wesley so is White against
mvl also our tournament leader would you
rather play Black against Wesley or
white against Anish
Peter these days against Anish is just
very very difficult to survive the
opening even even with the white pieces
Wesley didn't manage a few rounds ago
this is what we're watching yanish
having beaten Wesley in a span in a
Spanish is now back to his n of playing
ways is very fashionable now but no
bish3 Bish D3 Bishop D3 is by this point
old hat you know they they they've
actually started playing Bishop very F1
oh come on what chess coaches around the
world are just going uh mad how do you
explain Bishop B5 Bishop D3 Bishop F1
and you've got a position where White's
Pawn should be on C4 and his Knight
should be on it will be on C4 soon
because I don't think D6 D5 is any good
here so you have to allow the the Marzi
bind and but it feels to me like your
several Tempe behind is white standard
rooky bind and queen D2 Queen D2 this is
very very unusual this feels very
artificial to me what about you all of
it right Bishop D3 Bishop F1 the repeat
that we saw putting the queen in front
of the bishop what not the way usually
develop in chess uh again uh in my
experience with the Sicilian having
played these Hedgehog positions sure we
could call them the Hedgehogs yeah I do
like the I do like what Anish has done
and achieved so far uh Fabby of course
once you put your queen on D2 need to
fanat the bishop on D3 that's an open
invitation as to B5 and he took it
instantly we've missed something Queen
takes C3 it's a peace sacrifice I think
is the point okay so that's two Pawns
speed with which Fabby has played this
sacrifice to me it reaks of some
preparation some kind of Peter that
seems like a ridiculous peace sacrifice
if you ask me but he did it looks
interesting we can play something like
Bishop A3 now perhaps trying to hint at
some Knight B5 attacking the pawn on D6
okay the bishop on A8 doesn't look great
we can maybe fight for the control over
the C file I don't hate it I'm a bit
surprised considering that Fabby didn't
really need to take the such outlandish
risks in this game and we were
discussing ofir if maybe he is even okay
with the shortage draw in this game
clearly not well indeed this this peace
sacrifice shows reeks of ambition it
does opening prep or not it is very
ambitious play a decisive result
extremely likely in this one so it's a
night it's a night for two pawns for
only two Pawns of course there are three
on the queen side but at any moment uh
D6 D5 if I ever get a knight if I ever
establish a knight on D I do not believe
in the pawns whatsoever I believe that
uh Black's minor pieces will have an
easy time and that was why Peter went
for the bishop A3 uh to basically put
the kabash on D5 because again uh if
black ever gets uh pieces squares for
pieces and guess what A2 A4 I I I find
this very very
un
trustworthy it's not very encouraging
that Fabby took about a minute and a
half after sacrificing the bece to play
the move A4 I think bishu may have been
missed though because I think Anish play
D5 intending to play Bishop C5 next move
attacking the Knight but now his Rook is
hanging and white will be able to play
E4 E5 next driving that Knight to some
really annoying squares exactly E4 E5
Bishop C5 would have worked brilliantly
for black but the inclusion of Bishop B2
is as you say extremely annoying I think
this was mistimed this okay but hold
on puts it on H5 well because again you
cannot allow any E4 takes D5 Knight
takes D5 would have in my opinion been
game over uh so again yes if you put
your Pawn on magically go B4 B5 I'm with
you I think that's sufficient uh
compensation for a piece but at the
moment the pawn is not traversing
through B4 Bishop takes B4 is on Black's
agenda Bishop B5 Tanya do you find it
easier to play uh these positions with
the pawn in your pocket or the piece in
your pocket it to me it would depend if
I'm familiar with these kind of
sacrifices if I have the plans and of
course if it's a Blitz game I think it
it could be it could be the idea or the
gamble that actually does work out right
uh we saw the move Bishop B hitting the
Knight there was no there was no way the
Black Knight could have come to B6 it
would have actually been trapped after
the move A5 that would have been nice
for white it is all about getting the
pawns rolling and I'm wondering if it's
time to try and trade off the dark Squad
Bishop because without that you really
can't play the move B4 so is it
desirable to go Bishop A3 he's just
played Rook C1 assing any Bishop uh A3
ideas and he probably will take
recapture with the Rook allowing black
to take on E5 but uh
it's I think a difficult decision for
Anish to give up control over the C file
even for that Central Pawn on E5 it
might be very risky so once again Rook
takes C1 Rook takes C1 Knight takes E5
how do you continue as white P there is
Knight takes C6 but you can also perhaps
play for some Rook C7 I'm not entirely
sure I think we'll see in a second yeah
we're going there I think Knight D6 is
probably
likely Knight takes
E6
Tak Bishop takes e
D4 there an intim with Knight F3 check
that is true but I was just thinking get
your Pawn as a rolling you've got your
own uh action D4
D3 Bishop F6 see even even Knight D6 is
not being played quickly and Rook C7 is
completely empty as I look at it now
because after Bishop D6 we have to go
back so you have to play Knight D6 and
yeah he went for the intereso yeah Anish
says more porns are
better more is better more is better G
takes F3 e uh pardon me f takes E6 on
the board and Bishop
D4 I think that was somewhat important
I okay uh but this bishop to my mind is
much better than this bishop how are we
handling Bishop F6 Peter we're trading
in some way I think and then hoping if
we get before B5 we're very happy but we
have three Tempe away that's two pawn
moves and we also have to move the
bishop away somewhere so black will be
able to do something about it okay
but I think it's one of those positions
where I'm pretty sure the engine will
say black is significantly better but in
Practical terms if if you blink and
somehow allow before be5 you're you
might be in Desperate Straits exactly
I'm even thinking I I really want to get
in D5 D4 desperately I want to unleash
my Bishop so I'm even thinking of the
pawn sacrifice E6 E5 Bishop takes E5 and
D4 uh Anish obviously preparing that uh
break uh E6 E5 Tanya this feels slow
suddenly for black Bish D6 was
somehow you feel like like you every
move counts double I don't even know how
to say it but Knight F4 okay we're back
in business E5 D4 on Black's agenda it's
about these pawns right Bishop
C7 I don't know getting you need to get
in B4 how you going to do it he's also
stopped any ideas of the Bishop from B5
jumping onto C6 any trades on that
because Knight E2 was a threat which now
has been sidestepped with King to F1 uh
at the right time white might even look
at trying to trade off the light Squad
Bishop if he gets the opportunity I oh
my gosh H5 it's such a slowl looking
move I mean E5 felt like I like the but
I'm still liking White yeah I I don't
know why it just feels as if White's the
one who's making all the progress look
at that move Rook to C6 I was only
looking at Bishop C6 but he's saying you
can't capture The Rook Bishop takes
bishop and a to follow okay so what is
Zach I guess you're threatening Bishop C
Bishop B6 is what you're threatening Al
takes and Bishop E5 always in the air
Rook takes D6 and Bishop E5 as you
mentioned in the air but for me it's
Bishop B6 I'm looking Bish Big Time
threat what am I going to do I don't H5
he played it so slowly I thought E5 was
absolutely absolutely critical it feels
as there should be so much sense of
danger for black in this position but
making these slow moves on the king side
has allowed the Fabby to get the pawn on
E7 Rook C6 is actually the more I look
at it a very strong powerful move
agreed uh I I still haven't come up with
a good answer for Bishop B6 myself
looking at Bishop B6 because if the Rook
gives up the C8
Square I also just realized yasa you
were
saying you were saying something about
The Rook yeah I'm threatening Bishop B6
and if the Rook moves then Rook C8 uh
you were saying Rook takes Bishop E5 and
picks up the Knight that's that's
attractive it's very attractive and also
the fact that Fabby in the last move
moved that King to F1 he was actually
setting up rook to C6 because if the
king is in G1 and we visualize that
position black can take the rook and
then jump in with the Knight to E2 and
pick up that Central Bishop on
D4 I sorry to interrupt you but I just
want to say that uh mvl is losing
against Wesley so so if Faby does well
here and nepo turned things around he
was losing against Jeffrey and he won
and this move Bishop E7 is a realization
by Anish he blew it he blew he simply
now he's seriously
worse oh my goodness uh Fabby Faby could
be seizing the carpedm Seize the Day big
moment because Maxim VRA in his game
against Wesley so is in big trouble
we've got our eye out on that one but
here if Fabby wins this he takes the
soulle lead check this move out big time
move Rook
B6 uh intimating that once I get my Rook
to B8 you'll be completely tied up King
F7 Rook B8 on the board and it feels
more and more like Anish has he he he's
let uh the position slip away completely
G5 again slow moves H5 G5 has nothing to
do with the play pardon me Peter yeah I
think Fab by this point he knows he can
take on A8 and play Bishop C6 and win
win the piece back I think he's looking
for more I think he's trying to figure
out if he can maybe play Bishop B6 first
Drive The Rook away and then maybe
somehow interpose something on the back
Rank and I think A5 indicates that he
probably wants to win that piece back
but he wants to get the second Aon to
let's say A6 by the way before cashing
his chips in uh say same idea getting in
B4 as well that's another nice little
extra and the pawns just keep marching I
mean it feels like March of the ants
here and it feels like the players are
playing two different games here Anish
playing on the king side these moves H5
G5 doesn't really help the cause he
allowed everything for uh for Fabby to
accomplish and meanwhile Fab's just made
so much progress on the queen side uh
eventually ideas of Rook takes Bishop in
the air right now I have time for that I
think this decision by an Anish to play
E5 is basically correct why have we
played before but a little bit he just
it
it I think that was missed that's just a
pawn or was this the idea your knight
can't take the bishop cuz the Rook on d8
is f Rook G8 I Bishop G7 though oh now
we can take on C7 now that the Rook is
protected
but this I would never have done I don't
know why this happened r c Rook ah okay
because yeah I still Rook C8 Bishop D6 I
still disagree with
this by the way mvl our co- tournament
leader has lost to Wesley and Bishop
takes a this game is going and that
Bishop on A8 is alive what does it mean
it means what oh the pa the G Pawn just
got chopped off I was about to say
Bishop goes back to D6 Pawn goes to G3
Bishop C8 Bishop B7 an idea here
absolutely but it stopped with the King
coming to C6 could play Bishop B7 check
first and then Rook G6 that maybe was
much stronger actually he can still do
it now it's drawn after you can yeah
take twice yeah I don't know why we
taking these massive amounts of risks as
Anish maybe Ste Ste no now you can't
take
there6 wins and Anish realizes it and he
resigns but oh what a game he threw away
a half a point there at the end
absolutely uh Peter a very very eventful
round do do we have all the results do
we is li no no no no Liam and fuja still
hard at work let's jump in on that game
and that's a position with a lot of
pieces on the board it's your it's what
players are fighting King and King and a
couple of Pawns and we should be we
should be uh uh pressuring them to far
Resa to play King h8 and Rook B8 and for
uh Lin to put the queen on the light
Square cuz then we would have like 25
pieces on on the squares of their own
color exactly it feels like
Checkers just got
sacrificed something just got
hacked takes on C5 and white king ising
a biging threats on the king side are
very very very dangerous now Queen H6 is
a check but it's only a check from H6
check from E6 and then D6 should be
winning protected pass Pawn the on the
and the bishop on F4 is not helping oh
nasty professional Queen trade easy win
I'm not sure I I I think he would have
given mate if he continued D5 D6 was
pretty sure was mate was just mate yeah
I I I think he probably missed Bishop C1
he thought he will go Knight B7 and just
win this Pawn on on C5 but he's not
actually winning that pawn and now King
E7 and he's not winning the E5 Pawn
either yeah King D Knight d8 oh that was
a bad B well the bishop is kind of
Trapped no no the bishop is getting back
to F it's definitely one of those
situations where you should have been
playing for mate I think so too yeah
because I think he will regret that he
didn't play for mate he just thought he
was going to win the C5 of course he did
of course G3 G2 now maybe even ala
clearly considering yeah Ali Raza saying
hey wait a minute aren't you kind of
messing things up here Lyn why not
Knight C3 maybe Knight C3 was actually
winning on the previous move but now the
Knight cannot return and go Knight
C8 ooh nice move the bishop can't be
picked up
queens is back to being winning back to
winning the C G5 is hanging and C5 is
hanging a huge Victory a pivotal Victory
they were tied they had the same score
and with that victory at Liam and that
just knocked Ali Raza completely out my
my horse uh out of the race but Peter uh
one of those five five Victory rounds
that you mentioned no no draws people
are very very hard at fighting for those
uh for those places on on the final
standings fighting for those GCT GCT
points and yeah this was a very dramatic
dramatic finish but uh just to go back
and and to illustrate here it says here
might mate in seven mate in s should
should be yeah just giving this check
and then at pretty much at any point
including this this Pawn in the attack
will result in white with with the
additional 97 check being being the
option uh added to the equation you just
win very very simply and the engine says
this is still winning but as we've seen
it's it's a tricky win and had had uh
ala not played uh not played D3 here as
you can see the engine now currently is
saying this is a draw D3 was actually a
decisive mistake in this position ouch
uh In fairness uh Lan was very much in
uh in control for most of the game
because this looks like a very very
balanced position but then alza as I
think he likes to do he just gave up
this Pawn on A4 for the dark sare Bishop
but in this particular position with the
King already very safe on B1 and no
immediate attack on the king side and no
way to even challenge the white position
very soon like already a few moves later
uh here you can see that white will have
a very easy time consolidating there's
never really any any serious counterplay
yes black uh has this very beautiful
looking blockade on the king's side but
you're only really hoping that white
will never find a way to to properly
improve his position and he should have
lost that game and eventually he did
lose that game and the game between
Wesley and mvl was uh a symmetrical gr
field in which Wesley played Queen B3 uh
a move that goes in and out of fashion
and A5 is one of the fashionable replies
to
it and a critical moment came uh
somewhere around I think this point as
you can see uh a lot of pieces have come
off the board both Bishops are gone one
pair of knights is gone and
strategically black is doing fine but
there is this break between the B7 pawn
and the A4 Pawn meaning that the B7 Pawn
is a bit of a Target and uh for now
black has things under
control but uh in this position uh
giving up up on B7 wasn't necessary you
could play something like Queen d8 and
keep things together uh but Knight six
isn't that bad but after Queen takes B7
you absolutely had to take on B7 play
Rook E2 and after let's say Rook D1 you
can play very very very concretely
because if you allow white to play King
F1 white will stabilize you can play
Knight A5 attacking The Rook on B7 and
wherever it goes you get to play Knight
C4 and you get the organized counter
play against this Pawn on A2 and that
would have been enough in fact you as
you can see already the engine says it's
maybe you should try to draw the game
yeah equal equal with the chance of
black of black playing for a win but
instead of that enveil played Queen D6
Rook B6 Rook a C8 Knight F3 and white is
just completely stabilized and a few
moves later even the A3 point also was
gone and Wesley of course converted a
two-o Advantage very very efficiently so
a five result five result round and a
big shake up in the standings well let's
talk about that tell me about the big
shake up in the standings who's leading
who's on first well there's a certain
world number two who finds himself at
pole position with just two games
remaining Fabiana Carana for the first
time in the St Louis rapid and Blitz
takes the lead a sole lead with a
onepoint margin ahead of Peter's pick
yeahi I'm feeling good about my pick at
the start of the tournament now yeah yes
you are you and Anastasia both have
reason to celebrate Liam's Fortune's
Rising as he takes down Ali raaza and
let's jump to studio uh with Anastasia
for her highlights of this eventful
round
Anastasia indeed yeser we have many
reasons to be happy with st but it's
still not over wait a minute you know
few rounds to go and I kept my eye on
the game between Jeffrey Jong and Yan
what a game it was you know Jeffrey just
almost proved the rule that he is the
most dangerous player in the tournament
at the moment because when you actually
having a bad event you are the one who
can become a very dangerous opponent but
you you know things were crazy first of
all look at the position we have Dutch
defense a very rare guest on this level
uh it seemed like Yan just decided to
play whatever you know showing to
Jeffrey I will I can find a way you know
probably to beat you you don't have a
good tournament but look what happened
few moves later at this moment Jeffrey
played the move Bishop before and he of
course Yan had to play the only move
King more or less the only move King h8
you know avoiding what happened after
but he kind of said to his opponent yes
do it actually and Jeffrey played Bishop
D6 um I mean just winning the pawn of
course after Queen D6 black will just
lose the queen so he cannot play so and
after Queen E8 just to give you an idea
computer says it's plus three and a half
for white in this moment and even more
so after that I mean position is just
absolutely winning for Jeffrey but still
he had to show some kind of you know he
wins an exchange he's an exchange up and
also a pawn so I mean it's really huge
advantage and you I don't know how it
happened but you can ask me what
happened after but really it was just a
question of two moves he blundered I
mean he started to lose the track at
some point definitely but it came all
this way to this position where Yan
played This Night of to move absolutely
amazing and what happens if uh King F2
black doesn't play n for immediately but
he has this absolutely amazing
intermediate move Rook B8 and it turns
out that Queen has nowhere to go no
Square because like Queen C3 is going to
be Knight G4 and black wins the queen
very beautiful and there is no Square
actually the funny thing is that to stay
in the game Jeffrey had to find the move
like Rook D7 making sure that one of the
pieces tonight or queen will go um to D7
after that but um here he just resigned
let let me show what would have have
happened if Queen takes on B8 then it
would follow with Knight G4 what
wherever King goes like King F1 for
example Queen S3 and there is no way to
defend against this Checkmate on F2 so
this is how um yanomi would have won the
game if Jeffrey would allow him to show
it on the board but the game finished
right after Rook B8 and this is how Yan
is getting closer to the top but I'm
sure after move like Bishop D6 in the
opening he was remembering all the Bed
Wars he he knows in his life so the
second game I was checking was the game
between um um between s Sam S and Ray
Robson unbelievable game I mean so many
times the evaluation was changing um
it's really clear um evidence that
players are getting really really tired
um just to give you some examples I
really like actually how Sam played in
in the middle game he decided to sacrif
I in exchange here at this moment and it
turned out to be quite interesting
because his Knights are coming to the
king side and he got really nice
counterplay and compensation for the
exchange sacrifice and later on had
really like great chances just look at
it Knight H7 very nice blow and um after
that Knight E5 uh Knight f8 he gets
material back and the position was
absolutely winning for him for a long
long time all the way until move like 56
uh where uh he decided let's say I don't
know there was this kind of position you
can see that he has just simply the
night up and he played here Queen G2
allowing black to take the Knight on the
he just forgot that there is this Spin
and after that um I me tables were
turned and Ray Robson won the game
against Sam S finally Ray also showed
that he can get some points in this
tournament and U so it's now it's time
to go back to the studio honest Asia
thank you for that huge turnarounds and
queen takes E3 that's a heartbreak
that's that's just terrible but at NEPA
winning that game after Bishop takes D6
crazy uh pairings coming up are just
fantastic and including the last round
pairings as well but let's start with
round 17 what do you have for us T going
into the penultimate round we've got big
matchups as uh tournament leader Fabiano
kanana he takes on Ray Robson this is
his moment this his opportunity he needs
to score a full point in this one he
plays with the black pieces he's playing
against a player who's struggling in the
blitz he needs to make the most of that
Maxim vasher lra at 19 and a half a
point behind Fabby to keep himself in
the race also has to beat Sam seavan to
another player who's struggling in the
event for both these players extremely
important to get the full point
including tied for second Yan naami but
for him I think it's the toughest
playing yes no question about it and
tell us about about the round 18
pairings because somebody scripted this
for us had you uh been asked at the
start of dament you could not have
scripted this better because take a look
at that fourth board it will be Fabiano
caruana playing against Maxim vasher lra
this is just unreal we've set ourselves
up for a big big final but it first
comes down to how these two players
performed in round 17 agreed Maxim needs
to make sure that he's in striking
difference a distance to Fabby going
into this last round oh my goodness well
we do have two exciting uh penultimate
and ultimate uh rounds coming up I just
it's so painful uh you play 60 great
moves like Sam just played with Ray
Robson you're nursing an extra piece
everything is going your way feels good
and then suddenly one move Queen G2
there's no reason for it that's a panic
move anything Rook moves King E2 I don't
even know Peter explain that uh to our
viewers because
we've seen it we know what it's like
people are tired
and we have we've played 16 rounds of
bleit in two days and nine difficult
games of Rapid before that it's a
mistake none of them would ever have
made in a and even in Rapid and even in
a bullet game I think when he's fresh
yeah he would never have played that
move as as you say it is a very panicky
backwards move that shouldn't even have
been considered to be honest it just
doesn't look right right it's
heartbreaking when you throw away a full
point like that
I think a
signal kind of a very nice sign of what
kind of event he's having he's just not
really having a particularly good last
of days we have a replay uh mvl was
doing incredibly well cruise control he
was up against Wesley so through the
magic of Television we missed it but
here was some moments um of that game
it's a lot of extra pieces for white on
the board a rook and a knight and it all
comes down to Wesley finding a safe spot
for his King where is it managed to do
just if you go to G2 then there's E2 and
H5 so what we have to slip our King to
the queen side it's exit stage right a
little hesitation there by Wesley the
good news for him he had those extra
seconds to find the path for his King
and he decides yasa to walk towards the
queen side
exactly it's funny uh Peter you're up
Rook you're up a knight and you got to
kind of slalom your way up the board uh
and there you go he's you saw these
handshakes though they're not the they
are not the crispest handshakes I've
seen in and this last position if you
give a check on B1 I think King A3 and
that is the end of it and there we saw
the handshake there once again a bit
lukewarm but uh the others were
definitely rooting for Wesley in this
one
absolutely AIG catching my breath I'm
sorry it was just wow um big stuff
coming up and I'm looking at this
pairing uh of MV uh Sam Sean uh MBL will
be very aware that Sam just blundered
his head I'm not I'm not sure how how
many of the previous games they actually
see but he just knows he needs to win
two and hope something happens to fa I
mean he actually get he gets to play
Fabby in the last one so he needs to win
this one and then beat fa last and one
thing I wanted mention is Fabby being in
po position with two to go spells kind
of Doom for the grand chest t for the
rest of the field If he if he wins this
outride he'll be on 33 points yeah going
into the SN field 33 points going into
the S field probably finish in the top
five and secure first yeah and U an
amazing cushion there if if he does win
it even if he ties for first he's in a
very very good spot but if he wins it
outright yeah remind me Tanya coming
into today's game it's today's
tournament uh where was Fabby he was
like two points behind um mvl was he not
yes and he's always been in that top
five mix in the blitz but the rapid was
not that much of a happy start for for
Fabby uh and I've met him a couple of
times during the tournament after the
day play and he's not been happy with
the way things have gone for him uh so
it's really interesting to see that
despite that he finds himself after his
performance yes yesterday and today
leading the field with a point and of
course this has major ramifications for
our grand chest St standings as well as
what Peter was just mentioning but wow
talk about landing on your feet two
points behind uh and suddenly one point
ahead something's gone well for uh Fabby
in this final day of he needed nvl to
play let's say Les less well than
yesterday but he's doing everything
that's required of him he can't really
influence mv's results but he is winning
every game that he can but it felt that
things aligned for the players with mvl
start today losing the first two games
slipping up on that big twoo margin and
now it comes down to this big board can
Fabby take this important win if he does
he keeps a full point lead going into
the final battle against mvl in round 18
at least a fourpoint lead because it
will be required from uh nvl uh to win
to match him by the way Ray stealing a
page from
The Playbook of ala D3 a D4 this has
become the trend yeah and I'm honestly
curious I'm honestly curious why Fabby
chose to take with the knif because I
think this this tends to become quite
symmetrical and comparing this to a
Tempo up tarush yeah in a game you are
probably playing for a win well I think
I would have taken the tus but maybe he
feels that a draw is not really such a b
result the Ray Robson game uh in my it
is not the Ray Robson game that we're
looking at here so somehow it's like the
player it's different
players we are going to get that fixed
but till then let's see with the live
action and there we have it they're
calling it the nepo game but it's
actually it's it's it's wrongly done on
my site but it's not the oi Raza game it
is in fact the Ray Robson Fabby game
that we're seeing on my analysis board
and on I'm not sure to be because those
seem like they are maybe yanan's arms
can we yeah there's a tattoo it's
actually we actually watching
uh we have the wrong the tattoo gives it
away yeah yeah the tattoo gives it away
we got to go to Fab's game this is in
front of us is Ali Raa fuja against Yann
as we're seeing the knights have been
traded off but we are going to go over
to our tournament leader and and it's a
queen's Indian uh variation with the
pawn on
B6 as we'll go away from this current
board we're on the wrong board in the
playing Hall we need to go to the game
between Ray Robson and aabi but while we
do that this position that we have in
night trade has been offered here if
black was to take on B3 white would be
happy so you don't even have the option
to go Knight C4 cuz B7 is hanging right
it do you have to trade on B3 then and
there we have our board we will keep an
eye out on Yan's position as well
exactly last move Rook f8 to E8 and we
see Fabby how much time 420 Ray about 30
second lead that for Fabby the opening
already 30 seconds
that's something is something is
seriously wrong with Ray he just always
in his time travel regardless well what
are we looking at we're looking at a
bishop eyeballing our Rook instant move
move that you could make Rook E1 because
there are ideas that black may play B5
B4 so you just sidestep such ideas and
this feels like it should be better for
white uh I want to say Peter I've got
the central Pond do if I can play Rook
E1 I can play Rook C1 Knight D6 abs and
life is good on pinning that Knight
creates I think a very annoying
positional threat of Knight D6 correct
which needs to be addressed I think
Fabby has G for a line against the
cutland where there's a lot of pieces
still on the board there's a lot of play
but objectively I'm pretty sure this
doesn't fully equalize this doesn't look
like uh you know a
very strict solution to the problem of
equalizing in a Catland if you told me
that Fabby chose this line because he
needs to win with black I couldn't
understand it you want to keep all the
pieces on the board but it feels I mean
Fabby as we know is not in a position
where he you know he's desperate or
or something to win he could have played
something a a lot less having said that
imagine how comfortable it is playing in
VL in the last round knowing that even
losing doesn't lose you the first place
you had a good you don't lose and now
you going yes I was just about to point
this out that this is such a thematic
idea in this position where you trade on
C4 and you break in the center with E5
forcing wi to give up control of some
very key squares
here I'm just coming G this
this is a massive improv this was a very
good sequence Bishop to
E3 I think I probably would drop back
with Bishop to E4 takes on D4 and jump
with the Knight to the center of the
board but he does captured Knight takes
and what are we playing Queen B3 yes
well he's not worried about Knight D3
I'm not sure I guess Rook C2 D1 is
completely fine in reply to that because
of the pin because of the pin so this is
a very sharp structure in which you can
imagine some end games being maybe even
better for black but currently it's not
an end game it's very much a middle game
and uh alternatively if you imagine the
White Center actually you know getting
on the Move Maring yeah uh Bishop E5 F4
E5 all Bishop C5 I think is a very good
indication that f is aware aware and
wants to stop that from happening right
do not unleash the pawn on F2 I'm
thinking Rook C1 to D
absolutely I would I would be using the
other Rook I would Queen E7 now is was
he worried about Knight
D3 potentially you have to worry but
yeah he's worried about Knight D3 he
wanted to play Knight to
A4 I think against I absolutely agree
with this I would have just done it with
the other rook and I'm wondering why he
chose the Rook that he chose did okay
Bishop to D6 on the board maybe he wants
to play C5 now yeah kind of inclined
myself to throw a a little monkey wrench
in there I play C5 B Tak C5 I guess it
doesn't work Bishop takes E5 Bishop
takes E5 F4 you do have Bishop D4 check
he did play C5 okay
just the the
intuitive the intuitive player likes
this idea of taking away C6 C5 for black
how do you like this Tanya I like it
because one you can just take on E5 and
take the pawn back on C5 you don't have
to rush with the F Pawn uh expansion on
the king's side but also if you don't
immediately grab the pawn on C5 it still
is clear that you have enough
compensation because of what you've done
to the black pawn structure exactly
keeping the bishop pair and now
threatening to take on C5 with the
Knight right also that
Trump that Trump of the majority White's
majority is still in White's pocket it's
not that I'm going to play Bishop takes
E5 in the next move or will you if I
play C4 though is my question that's
what I mean it's always kind of in my
pocket right I can play Bishop E5 with
the idea F4 E5 all with Tempo C5 C4
Peter you think uh you you don't want to
see Knight take C5 no no and I don't
like Knight have D7 I think allowing
Bishop H3 everything suddenly starts
getting very very very pin down he goes
C4 and Bishop is chopped off and now an
interesting point and C6 C5 by by Fabby
I thought maybe he would play
by the way this is the first time I'm
really seeing a very confident playing
Ray four four wins a piece no that's
what he's done Bishop D4 Bishop D4 Rook
takes D4 is hanging on C7 and Bishop D6
has E5 that's a piece and Fabby it had
to be given up yeah fabbi the one thing
fabbi didn't want to do was give his
opposition uh his Rivals a chance of
getting back into the tournament Knight
H5 is a good practical choice I like
this that is that's actually brilliant I
mean it's amazing but that's actually
serious compensation it might be white
needs white needs to be quite careful
for the few for for the next few moves
because yeah it seems like the bwn on
four is going to get picked up and then
your King on G1 isn't really doing all
that great okay tell me again I'm if I
play F5 play KN I'm very reluctant to
play F5 though because I think it gives
Queen H I don't know maybe a five
playable I I feel that it's a difficult
move to make because you want to start
bringing stuff closer to your king like
of course you want to play I don't know
Knight C3 or queen F1 or something but
maybe a five is playable because
preserving that pawn might be very
valuable down the road if if we're not
getting mated by the way Ray just like I
mean Ray's in his own he
knows materially speaking he's got this
game one but he can also realize that
Remar remarkably there's this's some
real play against this King and he has
to be careful as well he's looking it's
like he's he's in disbelief dude you
blundered a piece I have to I got to be
winning this one you blundered a piece
it's really interesting how Fabby
materially down is able to find this
play against his opponent's king he did
that against Ali Resa brilliant by the
way in a lost position and by the way F5
is on the board expecting the queen to
jump into to join the party along with
the Knight for Fabby a decision does he
start with Knight F4 or he does start
with Knight F4 a Tempo but he has this
ability to find his play against the
opponent's king exactly it's a little
coffee house but sometimes when you
blunder and you you're you're you're
presented in these situations you just
find your best resource and that last
move Rook C6 you know what it reminds me
of it reminds me of that Rook jumping
onto F6 a rook CT bringing it closer to
your opponent's king look look what he's
doing I mean it you're absolutely right
it just has a serious Echoes of the fuja
game uh but by the way I mean as long as
white
maintains these defensive pieces Knight
takes C5 and well I will bring my my my
my knight back uh from A4 to D3 and
that'll be the end of the attack so what
whatever it is it's now G6 that's an
interesting decision a committal one
well you're weakening your own well now
you said it Knight to C3 uh Peter Knight
to D5 them home yeah yeah just tucking
things away Knight D5 I see is a massive
massive threat this has to be for white
now there's just not enough attackers
The Rook on the E is not participating
in the attack at all and yeah we're
going to have an interesting last round
if Faby actually loses
this by by the way how is mvl mvl is
pushing winning but who is he playing
against once again he's white against
saman very good Rook H4 on the
board pieces are getting traded and
that's bad news for Fabby his only hope
is was to try to create play against
white king that's gone but in the
bargain he picks up another Pawn C5 is
weak it feels like now it's not going to
be enough though not at all and there
goes C5 in fact Queen takes C5 17
seconds though these positions are
trickier to play than you would think
with with with with the King as severely
weakened as the white King on H1 is have
to win them you still have to win and
you've got little time on the clock and
Fab is refusing to trade Queens very
important of course you can I would have
actually taken on A7 I think I would
have taken on A7 again and just asked
yeah the question where are you where
are you going Mister cuz it just makes
winning all the positions in the future
so much easier if you already have a
passer on the queen side not getting
that b anymore no and by the way that
you know just covering up covering up
the king and look what Ray has done he's
brought his Queen back his Rook He's got
everybody at home he's ready to play
Rook G3 and
Rook C2 to F2 he's played Rook to C4 he
wants to get that Rook to F4 now as you
mentioned tripling up on the F line to
Target a blacks F7 I love it by the way
I I really think that that and of course
fa repeating the first chance he gets
but declining it he's up a piece just
for a seven seconds versus 14 Tanya this
is this is where nerves play such a
vital role is not going to win his game
though but he will he will be half a
point behind with a game with this move
Queen F4 Ray is Ray is eyeballing Queen
F6 that forces the queen trade makes
things so much easier for Ray King G1
Ray what same move faster better and you
can go Rook D2 but that would have gone
Rook F2 anywhere no you just I was about
to say put the bishop on on B3
no fabbi is playing on the clock he's
trying to somehow Swindle this one and
Maxim VRA that one finishes in a draw
and that's a bit of a good news for
Fabby that is absolutely great news for
Fabby Rook check Anish saying hi to us
there yes thank you Anish good to see
you
too looking a bit skittish yeah was very
worried about about being on camera nice
word skittish the G6 Pawn is defended
attacks the F5 Pawn you've got to step
away King H6 Bishop F7 though oh King H6
Bishop F7 well wasn't played yeah H5
coming in ooh H5 that do a check that
was missed and now we have two pawns oh
my gosh I think he might save this split
there're split and the good news for
white is that A2 Pawn is on the right
square with the bishop looking far ahead
any end game where the Rooks get traded
should be a win A8 square is the same
color as the light Squad Bishop should
be a win okay King f4
on on uh Wesley please Jeffrey oh no uh
it's about the clock and R Robson with a
shake of head that he's not happy with
his technique not at all uh I mean a
full piece up he's playing as if he's a
piece down it's remark down on the clock
though Yas and he's made things
complicated and almost feels like Ping
the nerves that you're talking about
it's rook and Bishop is going to be Pawn
is gone so this is now a theoretical
draw if Fabby holds it and with mvl not
winning oh my goodness he will preserve
his full point lead with a round to
spare R Robson just let go of all of
those pawns it's an extra what happen
there oh my gosh and now if there are no
pawns on the board black loses the a
pawn and the F Pawn it is a theoretical
draw but Fabby will have to you show the
defensive technique there I was about to
say I might have left the fbon on the
board and tried to hide my king behind
the F
Pawn us you used it as a in other news F
has beaten yanomi completely derailing
my my fantasy pigs tournament finally
it's still ex it's still not over this
one you have to defend this position
it's Rea is always playing on on 2
seconds on the clock Fab's at
15 and Fabby is kind of pressing you
know Fabby is gaining
space Sai playing confidently there
making progress
to D5 R into to Bishop was a big threat
well well we have chased the king all
the way to the Border Lan why do you you
lose the Aon now yeah but he he he's
actually picked up the Aon which I think
is better for morale if you if you
actually get to do that and now the big
question is will Fabby hold the ever
famous Rook Bishop versus Rook end game
I'm going to say yes but uh I'm going to
also say that time could
easily uh be a factor here be the
decisive Factor yes absolutely yes
because you need to make those critical
Rook moves when your king is on the last
rank which actually it is so Ray Robson
has managed to get Fab's King the
optimal position in fact yes and now fam
you will have to made that move with one
second did he make it with 1 second oh
my
goodness oh my goodness and now the
white king wants oh look at that
hesitation I know and Bishop will come
to D5 setting up a discover check that
Fabby says you can
have
okay King
defended Fabby wants to get out of the
last rank that is the ideal position for
Ray Robson to try to Checkmate the king
and makes defense that much more
trickier King C3 no he didn't play King
C3 don't like that decision but I would
I would think that Fabby has studded
this end game of course a million times
but especially around the world
championship match of 2018 you just
revised this anyway oh oh oh oh oh oh
Fabby
flagged oh my
word half a point lead half a point lead
with one round to spare Rook Bishop
versus Rook never over till it's over
and Fabiano doesn't lose on the board
but he loses on the clock oh my gosh if
MBL wins this final game The
commentator's Curse is nobody chose F
and everybody will be upset and you know
who he's playing right let's do a quick
flag because I wasn't I wasn't so
focused on the clock as I was about the
moves I was thinking that Ray was really
putting some challenges but here we go
it's a check five and it's 4 seconds
right Fabby reaches out he makes the
move King and presses the clock and it
was at this moment he's got 4 seconds
now so all he's got to do is move his
Rook he does it this time he gets it in
in time brilliant doing everything right
so far this is the ideal defensive setup
right 5 seconds and now you move your
king and it's the moment it's the moment
he pauses
two he misses it he misses it he misses
it
yes and there you go and that was it who
Fabiano caran Flag by the way with the
final position might be I'm not sure I'm
not sure it's a draw anymore let me
check I don't trust myself on these
things still says it's a draw even in
the final position if you after rookie
eight yeah he got himself into a
situation where a little bit tricky only
moves will have to be found for a while
but it's still a draw yeah oh my
goodness w wow wow okay tell it break
down two of the other we actually
watched the beginning of this game
thinking it was the Fabby game but no
it's Sala Contin to press press his I
was saying Ray Robson stole a book stole
Ali R's temp down credentials are being
very firmly established and this is very
very close to equality and somewhere
around here yes the white Rook is
slightly more active but the black Rook
is about to come in as well you
generally don't expect to actually be
able to win these types of positions
right and they got to this Rook ending
which is still a bit tricky but should
be a draw but uh uh Al tried playing it
as ambitiously as possible as usual as
usual as he always does and eventually
uh somewhere here the engine suggests
it's very much time to switch to to
active defense you go before you put the
Rook on C2 you start pushing your own
pawns and it says it's just completely
fine but what what uh Yan did was
perhaps uh slightly more passive but
also completely fine and they continued
in this fashion with the Rook uh as you
can see uh getting driven away away from
the Pawns
and white making some progress attacking
the one serious weakness on E6 as you
can see now E5 checking G7 Rook E7 and
in this position uh Yan started going
wrong because a very very simple draw is
available here with the move C3 allowing
white to take on E6 and now occupying a
very beautiful Square on F5 following it
up with Rook D3 check taking the king
away you're not even worse like it's
just you know black isn't even
struggling here not at all instead of
that he went Rook D3 check King H King
G4 this is still a draw but you can
suddenly imagine how this goes wrong
because the king will now after the pick
up of on E6 it will be kicked away and
five mes later this is this is the
position and ala ends up winning whereas
mvl played a kind of a kg game for
somebody who absolutely needed to win it
uh in the Spanish he played D3 which I
think maybe indicates he didn't want to
allow the open and after Bishop C5
Knight C3 D6 he play Bishop takes C6 and
then there there was a trade on E3 and
uh he black very quickly uh pushed for
counterplay in the center and B replied
by taking and playing D4 and pieces
continued coming off and by move 25 23
even we had this reasonably dry end game
which uh should be completely fine for
black black has the bishop on a very
open board yes white has a majority but
it shouldn't really matter that much but
mvl came close it feels like uh I don't
know somewhere around here in particular
after the move Knight f8 The Pawn on A6
is vulnerable also the pawn on H5 and I
thought the pawn E6 will get picked up
but what mvl actually achieved uh is he
managed to put his pieces on such
squares that after Knight F2 the pawn H5
had to be had to be given up but in
response black is in time to attack the
White Queen side and uh eventually Sam
gave up the bishop for the h BP but
picked up everything on the other side
and the game was two two nights versus
night okay uh standings if you please uh
still Yes thinking about what we just
saw Fabian Carana doing everything right
in that
Brook Bishop wow and with that this is
what we set ourselves up for slim half
point
lead 20 and a half points for Fabiano
Carana going into the final round Maxim
V gra drew his game so now he just a
half Point margin and Yan pishi Half
Point behind Maxim bash lra and it's
clear as we look at the standings that
playoffs there's going to be no tie
break no playoffs because we've got a
dream final the championship game
between Fabby and Maxim VRA that will be
our ultimate Blitz but first we're going
to toss it over to Anastasia to break
down break down more highlights of this
round Anastasia over to
you yeah what a game it was y sir I mean
it was just incredible and I think I
scared people people here in the
building screaming like make a move
father just make a move you know and
then he lost on time it was just amazing
I couldn't concentrate on my games after
that but still let's get a a close look
to the game of so Wesley so against
Jeffrey Jong I must admit that despite
the fact that Jeffrey is having really
bad tournament he still fights in every
game and he gets winning positions um in
in his game against Wesley he opted to
play Petro defense but Wesley decided no
let's play four nights uh game and um
this kind of a little bit known as a
drawish variation but um I think Wesley
was trying still to trick his opponent
and go into the position which was a
little bit more complicated um and he
pushed D5 here maybe was not so
necessary and after that Jeffrey played
very good game and managed even to
overplay his opponent in the middle game
and got really good position you can see
after Bishop D5 and as well after Bishop
F3 ruining Pawn structure of his
opponent um King side looked so nice for
black and um he was winning let's say
for next I don't know how many moves and
I just want to show you one very nice
moment when he created a very nice uh uh
checkm net around the white king and
here um he made a mistake he played the
move rookie seven which missed the whole
advantage and after that the game
finished in a draw um but instead of it
there was a very very nice move Rook A1
and then after Rook F7 just King E4 and
white has to give the Rook on F3 because
the Rook G1 is coming and if Bishop H2
also very very nice move like Rook H6
would have finished the game here and
Jeffrey could have won it uh but instead
he played this move Rook E7
understandable he was trying just to
stop the pawn in some lines but look at
this very very tricky move of Wesley
Rook G4 came and black after King G4 U
has this move Rook G8 and um Queen is
coming after that and um you can see
that um after after all these exchanges
um it's just pwn up for black and game
finished in the draw after that uh so
crazy game kudos to Jeffrey for keep
fighting in every round as well as
Wesley saw um and the game between Anish
giri and lean Liam was not that eventful
um they played 52 moves but I must tell
you that there was not even one moment
that I mean somebody had an advantage to
this game like really really well played
for both players like Grand Master game
we would say like still I mean they were
trying to look for some chances and they
after they ended up and this ending um
let's say Anish was trying all these
Maneuvers from all the sides of the
board but nothing really happened here
and the game finished in the draw
looking forward for the last round I
mean uh I think we couldn't ask for
better situation and I mean really
really feel excited about the last round
and what it will bring to us thank you
Anastasia the ultimate professional not
being distracted by Fab's game but keep
keeping an eye on the two games that she
was supposed to monitor she gave us the
the breakdowns I want to say uh Tanya we
have an
Armageddon but Fabby has white and draw
odds oh interesting way to look at it
and there's a little bit of an increment
in this one and there's an but it's an
Armageddon it's an Armageddon this is
the final destruction either Maxim or
Fabiano Karana whoever wins takes it all
pdon though cuz you're giving no ODS
whatsoever you're not giving time you're
getting color rods it's just well you
even get no Fabby got gets the
color the the rich get richer kind of
situation that's a situation so so let's
break this down if this ends in a draw
Fabby wins the whole thing story Fabby
wins Faby wins the whole thing Maxim has
only one part to championship of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz he needs to win
with black but Maxine is one of those
players who enjoys a challenge so he
reaches across the board and says I'll
tell you what you can have white and you
can have draw
odds let's play for first and you know
this is the first time in this entire
event that I've seen Maxim walk in so
much ahead of the starting of the game
and he was waiting at the board it all
comes down to this one look at that
Focus both these players knows for Fabby
it's been a successful event the it
started the way it's ended I think he
surpassed all expectations after the
he's played phenomenally well in the
blitz well he has nothing but happy he
came into today two points behind he
knows that this has been a fantastic
event for him he's going to get a lot of
GCT points regardless of the uh outcome
of this game and he's done everything to
put himself in po position for the
singfield cup which is what it's all
about the grand chest but now he wants
to win it all and now he wants the the
the 40,000 as well he wants the 40,000
he wants the full gcd points he's white
he's half a point ahead right why not
and we see Smiles before it's going to
be no smiling very soon as the play is
about come out and just AE and not the
butter nice
either but what are we expecting here
Fabby with one4 Will Maxim go will that
W E4 it's going to be some Sicilian
right Peter I'm not sure he goes E4 he
only needs a draw I think he has plenty
of I mean unless he wants to go for
Glory I think you can definitely play
something more more practical because
there are plenty of force draws against
the grinfield
and Maxim's other repertoire against one
D4 is I mean he plays the Queen's Gambit
accepted as we've seen in this
tournament which you say thank you and
you swap everything down so I tend to
think 1 D4 is slightly easier to control
in mraw situations but Fab disagree I
mean it's not that important the
important bit is just to play a normal
game Tanya when you need a draw as white
what do you find to be the most
comfortable way I think E4 regardless I
play D4 I'm a D4 player so for me D4 and
I'm happy that's it that's it it's an
easy choice for me but for Fab and for
all these top players who play
Everything Under the Sun it is all about
the tournament situation as well but I
I'm hoping for a 1 E4 uh Peter thinks
it's going to be 1 D4 yeser your
prediction uh I am going to go for E4
E4 E4 you're almost willing it to happen
right now let's see it and uh to our
audience uh get ready because this is it
uh for first place all the marbles and
so many points of the GCT somebody's
walking away with 13 GCT points and that
looking across and he's going like man
that should be me and he was so close as
well yes should be playing for first he
would have been on this table he would
have been the one fighting it out and he
knows it it can't be a happy round for
him and it's go time and what has Fabby
played it is one D4 Peter you righto no
grun field who Queen G Gambit declin
mind so we got to play Bishop G5 and not
allow a Queen's Gambit accept it
no that's interesting I think that
allows options it does allow D5 take C4
followed by B5 right and the SE I like
the seis slav as a choice keeps pieces
on the board very difficult to
completely vacuum things off the board
in in the seis positions are very dry
we're not going to see a Morano though
we're going to see a bishop D6 bishop3
is actually a very good choice in this
spot because you're forcing either black
to not equalize or to enter some very
forcing variations with and how much of
the Morano variations does mvl know
somebody is bluffing somebody I just
don't know who who's the better bluffer
here Peter and and in the Mirano you
absolutely play A6 on after the let's
say if the bishop goes to D3 here you
don't play Bishop B7 which probably
equalizes but no no more B E2 also a
line also a line of play but you're
saying A7 A6 and then you go for the
quick C5 business yeah you you have to
play for those positions because you
don't go for the B4 Bishop B7 no those
are very very dry yeah um against Bishop
E2 I think A6 is supposed not to be any
good I'm trying to remember the exact it
might be E4 B4 E5 which becomes and E4
C5 is also not that great for some I
guess yeah this is the point the
difference is if you put if while he's
thinking A6 yes E4 ah he has not done E4
I'm I'm I'm a bit surprised because this
A6 E4 B4 you were about to say E5 yeah
E5 is good there and after C5 uh the
fact that we we can take Queen takes D4
in some positions compared to the
positions with Bishop on D3 is massively
important and we do have C6 C5 on the
board mhm D4 D5 he's played it it keeps
uh we take and go Bishop B7 I don't
think we're unhappy about this well you
take you go Bishop B7 we play E4 I
assume I take on D5 I play Bishop D6 I
think Fab will take one F6 and play A4 I
think he'll go into end games those end
games could be a hang on maybe we take
with the Queen considering the
tournament situation Bishop B7 by the
way on but I'm voting Knight takes F6
here I'm I'm not voting for E4 Knight
takes F6 Queen takes F6 and throw an A4
throw an A4 somewh yes very nicely put
on you that A2 A4 comes perfectly timed
you you you hit the B5 Pawn you get to
trade a pair of Rooks maybe and he's
done it Knight takes F6 I think has to
take with W he the Knight so Queen
trades on offer but now we definitely
take take Play We play A4 I think this
will be very difficult to or even the
immediate this actually shocks me a
little bit because I think it just makes
makes white so much easier totally is
there a w to avoid Queen J because you
can go Queen B6 but then you anyway take
and go Queen take the rook and then go
Queen B3 at the end of it even queen3
right away you put your queen on B6
Queen B3 right away C4 Bishop C4 ooh B4
uhoh uhoh uh C4 is a juicy it certainly
is I mean I would be making a beline to
that square Knight E5 Bishop F3 Knight
C4 even Bishop C4 here looks very good
B3 Bishop B2 looks very good I I have a
feeling white is just much better now
much better yeah the one thing you have
to watch out for is if you play B3 you
have you have to be very certain the
knight from F6 doesn't just land on C3
very quickly right that's the one source
of counterplay you need to be constantly
on the lookout for but uh it looks like
a very good uh play by Fabby he's got
his Bishop on B2 and everything's still
looking very nice I I I'm anxious to
play Knight C4 Tanya but the one good
thing from Maxim is that the Queens are
still on the board needing a win I I
think there was an opportunity for white
to trade and go for the exact idea that
you pointing out with your arrows but
with the Queens on the board and the two
Bishops lined up towards White's King
side uh sure you get your knight to C4
and it's all of us would pick white here
but there is still a lot of game to be
played Queen E7 Rook d8 Rook
E8 and we have or queen C7 as your
pointing out
three
uh showing a
remarkable uh composure in not jumping
to the C4 Square
H3 black is jumping in with a night do
what that
C3 because uh as Peter Peter mentioned
the one thing that you have to be
mindful of is a night landing on the C3
Square when you're not ready for it by
the way Queen C2 Queen E7 just as you'd
like Rook
D1 bring the Rook to d8 everybody's
happy you want to play Knight G2 here
with white but you might be blundering
Knight
G3 oo so very careful now Knight D2
Knight G3 the idea F takes Queen takes
E3 check and I'm in your business as we
say yes yes because Rook F2 runs into
Bishop takes spawn on G3 and your Rook
on F2 spin exactly no Knight d2s and
suddenly okay I'm not saying it's
completely ridiculous but don't forget
the tournament situation mvl has to win
and he's Bishop seor is correct I think
he's he's setting the stage yeah it
really feels like that in a must
situation with black this is the outcome
that you want out of the opening truly
truly now I'm not threatening Bishop D5
because there is a bishop H2 discovered
yeah Knight C3 is Knight G5 interesting
takes takes on a four though I think
this makes F's life much easier uh I was
thinking kn3 yeah but it's probably not
more than a Perpetual I think the reason
he hasn't done it is that we can
actually accept the sacrifice and you
have theet but you don't you don't have
anything more okay uh Peter you said
this makes White's life easier why well
we've completely protected the G2 Pawn
our Bishops now are actually better than
Black's Bishop the bishop on D6 is
completely cut off from the game we can
even maybe launch some of our own play
like Queen F2 G3 here is a very
legitimate source of Queen G4 as well
yeah our pawns are a bit more mobile
while this Pawn on C5 is nicely
blockaded I feel I feel like Bobby
controlling this nicely is is doing
really well Suddenly It's really that
move Knight G5 five kind of spoiled
Black's attack yeah just one Traer
pieces and how much it changes the
position it's completely taken away uh
the chances that Maxim had because
notice how now it's White's Bishop the
one and B2 and C4 which look so much
more powerful agreed the pawns can start
moving forward when the time is right
but first it's about peace activity and
I'm liking white now it would have been
very different a few moves ago I I have
a feeling G4 might be winning but you
never played in a position
in Fus tournament situation you just
never wasn't there the ghost of Ray
Robson with F5 and F6 didn't somebody do
the F5 Bishop E5 F6 was very playable
yeah uh and sacrifice or yes yes yes
that would have been fun but uh and uh
White is the one enjoying the
proceedings we have King h8 yes and now
the E3 Pawn is guarded so the queen can
uh jump over to
G4 of6 now I was wondering if we were
eyeballing the A6 Pawn but then you lose
something in the center probably you
lose something well no with the Rook on
E1 I was going to take on d8 then Bishop
takes A4 in the end oh and also Rook D1
and E3 was hanging in lines he goes
Queen G4 thread of Maiden one F6 that's
a very professional decision there by
fby gets wins off the
board that's need only your draw by the
way that's Checkmate to the queen
absolutely there's no
that black queen is not escaping uh
there is a forc trade okay but mvl says
let's play on let's March Soldier on
I've got Bishop C2 on my agenda what are
you going to do about it Bishop C4 A5
King F not getting distracted from this
but uh the game between yanish and Anish
giri ended in a draw meaning
that uh MV cannot lose the second place
at least yes and also meaning that
perhaps the players are more interested
in this game than any other game yeah
than the one they're playing themselves
it is the championship game Let's remind
everyone and Fabian Carana needs only a
draw to clinch clear first to clinch
clear first and 13 GCT points very an
additional 13 GCT points being already
the leader of the Tour by the way the
last move King
G2 just to take away some of White's
flexibility I might be inclined to play
Bishop G2 here trying to provoke the
move H4 so I don't get
uh I don't have to deal with G4 but okay
he's played King to uh
G6 playing for King F5 by the way I
think it's really really really
Justified that mvl get at least a clear
second because he's played such a very
impressive Blitz event that some
sometimes you lose the last round game
and you you drop the I think if he loses
he will tles Ty for second but tie for
second I think so I think he's only half
a point ahead of of yan so okay and no
question of that both these players
whoever wins it is the is is a deserving
winner they've played fantastic chess in
the blitz just amazing amazing games
this end game well the Bishops have been
traded off who are we picking here is is
it completely inbalance no I still like
white because this Pawn on C5 is not
it's it's not brilliant right whereas
this Pawn on e4 like I'm not sure King
F5 now I don't think you can play King
F3 because Rook D3 is extremely
Rook C1 may be strong though black could
consider throwing in C5 C4 here just to
create the passer but it's a h yeah what
Peter and he does that yeah nicely
spotted so the idea it's a positional
sacrifice the idea is to put the King on
inst instantly returned it
wow okay both both the memberships into
the pong grubber Club has been cancelled
revoked revoked denied license revoked
Rook C1 really instructive right that
pawn is more useful to White off the
boat than on it because you want some
more peace activity maybe flipping I may
be flipping uh suddenly the queenside
pawns have become meaningful B3 but I I
thought there was a good Rook C3 Rook B8
though B3 is a very important Rook D2 is
your idea correct absolutely that would
that's on my C3 you'll have to play Rook
B8 but Rook B8 is perfectly serviceable
and now Rook C4 the bishop endings are
completely equal after Rook before
that's not a winning attempt so it's
very unclear how how is black Rook
getting into the game here back to Rook
to d8 to D2 that's my only inroad that's
the threat now Rook d8 coming in he's
taking away the C3 Square first I do
have very nicely done by mvl spotting
the the geometry there is the there's uh
he would like to play Bishop C3 here but
that loses maybe to Rook H2 want to go
Rook to B1 and start targeting the B3
Pawn if Rook H2 Rook B1 and then you
move the bishop King C4 hold on that's
very clever by five actually are you
sure Rook H2 Rook B1 Rook
G2 yeah just Bishop D4 and take on B3
and we should be okay
are it's still Level material it's still
Level material but I'll have a pass G
Pawn eventually you'll have to spend
some time developing it by that point
I'll play Bishop C3 trade the Bishops
off and and when you do white will have
a pass Eon as well it's so far away that
we're looking at maybe 10 against 25 by
the way
n has always been such a marvelous
Blitzer I mean he somehow he he manages
to keep ahead 10 30 seconds is is a for
PA fall I can he just going to give up
just going to give up the AO Pawn is he
making a draw here not
convincing is is the one with the best
chances suddenly and maybe he had to go
with his King to C4 to grab B3 so A4
could have been defended but he even
reached for it and then somehow thought
thought better of it yeah thought better
it for some reason Rook F3 Rook F3 Bish
G2 very strong attacking the F PA
forcing white to put pieces on King E6
no do you go E5 and try and create play
he doesn't want to do that once because
it also gives black an additional G hold
on what's going on now you've got a
passer on the G passer yeah W wo wo wo
what what three
oh he missed it he missed an opportunity
for Rook A3 was that just a pin and you
win the yes the bishop you you oh you
would win an exchange that would have
been an easy draw4 is in trouble he has
to play five this is no longer a
draw four against nine by the way oh no
this will be decided on on on oh did he
who oh my
God he played rookie two and lost The
Rook oh this is a drao yes favy he's oh
my goodness and Fabiano Carana is the
winner of the St Louis rapid and Blitz
Dr drama to the last drop
congratulations to Fabby but yeah that
was quite something do we still have one
game remaining let's just check in on
Sam versus Wesley I don't see a result
we see Maxim lra congratulating Fabby
for his performance there what a game
what a finish wow rookie to trapped in
the center of the board got to give mvl
credit the the the chances came at the
very end props to mvl for continuing to
search for ideas and actually getting
very very if he puts it on maybe any
other Square he's probably objectively
winning how close was it we can we can
take a we can take a look uh start with
three moment because that was a big Miss
as well minus two minus two which is
which is quite obvious these are the two
that is is can you point out that Rook a
3 moment for a second cuz that would
have been tournament over right and and
and Fabi obviously missing a very very
big chance here Rook a 3 ends the
tournament on the spot because you have
to take on D4 put the bishop on E5 yes
it's a draw but you have to win with
black exactly uh so yeah that was that
was a so that was the first Miss yeah
and then after Bishop C3 somewhat
thematically uh the same thing happens
on this side of the board and actually
Rook A7 check would have preserved the
pawn he could have given this check
waited for the black king to vacate the
the vicinity of the E7 square and then
put the Rook on the eile but he didn't
he didn't find that play D5 and now he's
in a massive massive trouble but then
came the the final twist in the tail
rookie two and suddenly there Rook
strapped no more squares and he could
have moved anywhere on the third rank as
long as you're not losing the rook in
one move and you're just pushing two
pawns up oh my goodness wow extremely
dramatic my goodness and uh we do have a
trophy ceremony coming up at the World
Chess Hall of Fame
let's go to Tony Rich at the World Chess
Hall of
fun well the tournament was fast and it
was definitely an exciting event to
watch a big congratulations to our
tournament Victor Fabiano caruana who
takes home the first place prize and the
Beautiful singfield Cup trophy Bobby
congratulations I thought it was the
full thing and there is our winner kind
of expecting a speech not just not just
not not just a pretty picture but I was
thinking the whole thing was about to be
picked up in hand over that's still a
really lovely Trophy and really I
expected him to say thank you to the
commentators for the wonderful job that
they did the fans watching for the fans
and there he is 13 GCT points in his
pocket that's really he is looking gold
for uh the grand chestor but I'm at 33
total gcd points for $40,000 a lot of
earning there adding it to his Pur of
his grandchester winnings and for me yes
so impressive the way he made his
comeback from the rapid truly two two
points down coming in today he overcame
that and uh it it actually required for
for mvl to have a nightmare we thought
mediocre day for mvl might be enough if
somebody has a fantastic day but if my
mental math which is never particularly
good at this time of day is correct
Fab only in this field nothing is only
but he only scored six out of nine he
didn't have like an outstanding day with
like near near 100% score had five out
of n yesterday six out of n yeah he
scored six out of nine and that was
enough to overturn a twoo def deficit so
mvl scored three and a half out of nine
yeah Sapar Sapar as we just take a look
at the end of uh the game that we just
witnessed this is where the Rook got
trapped the last Square you expected to
get trapped and Maxim immediately
realized it but he had to make a move
with just a second left on the clock and
then uh Fabby knows he's done it he's he
got the draw on the back the king comes
in The Rook sacrifices itself for the
bonds exactly and as we uh close our
show I just want to give thank out to uh
the wonderful people at the World Chess
Hall of Fame who hosted uh this rapid
and Blitz they do do such a great job to
make the people feel at home to the
Arbiters our Arbiter team
for
never I didn't hear a peep from the
Arbiters that's always a good sign
except for the clock malfunction we got
to remember the clock malfunction that
was Fab's loss in a in a rook and Bishop
versus Rook no he got flagged he got
flagged per this is peria and Fab mvl
and Maxim getting the full point exactly
and uh well I ladies you got a lunch you
got a lunch I thought it was lunch and
in know I I think it was H
tacos Anastasia and I know what's up a
faan is uh absolutely on us and uh Peter
I just wanted to say it was fabulous
working with you really I enjoyed your
company pleas enjoyed your company as
always is my first time doing the board
and I think my interactions with the
board provided an additional layer of of
hilarity to the show which I was the
board actually liked you I don't think I
don't think it does but it worked to
Perfection during the analysis the live
what happened what was up with that with
what yeah I mean it worked at the end
yeah I got I got a tip from from a close
friend who figured it out from a long
long way away what I was doing now and
told me it doesn't like the engine being
switched on with the engine switched on
it seems to be behaving much worse than
with the engine Switched Off well you're
such a good engine you don't need
one I also want to say a big uh shout
out to the St Louis chess club uh
Scholastic Center for all of their
hosting and everything that they do
thank you Tony rich thank you Ryan
Chester thank you to the entire staff
there to our production team here in
studio Silverback Tom Megan Tyler Mark
you guys are terrific uh vusion uh
keeping us on our toes when we miss
things so many people working so hard
behind wow and it's not over we have
more coming and I think the SN Bell Cup
starting Monday is that right mark your
calendars these are the dates November
21st the action resumes on Fabiano
Carana who's leading the grand Chester
the winner of the St Louis rapid and
Blitz will be fighting it out this this
is the final event of the 2023 season
exactly as we get ready to go through
our list of the players and how uh they
completed themselves again Tanya I want
to say it's been years I know covid
messed everybody up but you got a
promise to return we love your ener so
much fun calling the action uh and
really yes everyone who works behind the
scenes to make our jobs easier and
everyone uh tuning into our broadcast a
big shout out to our audience and we've
got Anastasia with a very special guest
congratulations
Fabby yeah congratulations Fabiano I
have hero of the day today Fabiano
yesterday you were telling me two points
I'm fighting only for the second place
and here we go now you you won the
tournament how did it happen with a lot
of luck so absolutely no I mean last two
games were terrible but before that I I
think I won some very important games
three in a row uh these were really
important and okay last game I was just
incredibly lucky against Maxi what can I
say I mean he uh he was winning okay it
was kind of equal but unpleasant for me
for a long time and then he he played
rookie too but he kind of like I think
dropped it for a second and then he
realized that and then he picked it back
up and then he I don't know I'm not 100%
sure if he dropped it but he said he did
so of course other had to play Rook to
after well rookie for and he's two pawns
up I mean not I wouldn't resign yet but
yeah I'd probably lose this of course I
like this moment Rook A3 is very simple
like many you realized it after no I
realize it now yeah see no many many
regrettable moments in the last two
games um but overall yeah it it worked
out so what this Victory I mean you have
won so many tournaments but what
particular victory means for you this
one this one is really important because
also for the grand chest tour it's uh
it's I don't know if I'm like almost
securing first place in grandest tour
with this but it's very close to
securing I think uh so this one was
really important because I really wanted
to to win grandest tour this year and I
don't know if I'm have yet or anything
but it's definitely a big step towards
that and um also I've never won rid and
Blitz uh Grand chest Tour event it's the
first time so I've won some like Blitz
and Rapid events but never in the grand
chest tour so this is but the thing is
I've had better tournaments than here
than I've done here like I remember one
time in Warsaw we played a tournament
and I think I finished 24 points and I
got fourth place so here I finished like
21 points and I got first place so it
depends on what how your opponents are
also playing right yeah this is why I'm
lucky but that's what it's better to be
lucky and bad than unlucky and good
that's the thing you're probably meaning
this previous game like how did you feel
going to the last round after losing
against rare ropes and this absolutely
crazy position yeah yeah it was a draw
on the end I believe but I had already
kind of made it difficult um but I ran
out of time in a drawn position I I
believe it was a draw at least uh but I
was down a full piece at some point like
literally full piece uh maybe I had one
Pawn for it or something so of course
this was a a bad game I think I have to
say I'm very proud of my games against
Yan against um against Ali Resa and
against Anish I think those three games
I'm I'm very proud of the level I showed
in those games yeah so I mean it was
very tiring tournament five days but
it's not over in two days we're going to
have sinkfield cup what are you going to
do between during those two days how are
you going to celebrate
oh celebrate well I'll try to celebrate
tonight um it's of course a very good
feeling I mean I couldn't have hoped for
better like if you told me yesterday
that I would even be fighting for first
I wouldn't believe you because two
points and Maxim I thought would be in
very good shape today but um but he
wasn't in his best shape and yeah so
this is of course a dream that I
actually managed to win this tournament
it's like completely unexpected and now
we play classical chess so it's a bit
more stable let's say you know usually
less well always there's less action
still you know it's I hope to play well
but at least I won't have so many
emotional ups and downs like here
exactly I mean by the way I was still
believing that you can win the
tournament as well as t s who is the one
of the commentators here and we won
lunch with uh yaser because of that so
thank you fa it was really amazing I
also lunch that's a good point yes are
you inviting
also it's
commentators only commentators but in
any in any case five such a great result
I mean such a great tournament thanks so
much for this drama for everything what
happened today even for the fact that
you lost this previous in the previous
round it was really amazing to see all
this thank you and all the best of luck
for you simple definitely you guys thank
you Anastasia definitely our
congratulations to you uh Fabiano uh
really just uh out outstanding just
outstanding final standings for our
tournament if you please Tanya take us
to through the list of winners and there
we have it the winner Fabiano Carano
with an additional 13 Grand Chester
points $40,000 Victory with a final
round draw against Maxim Vash gra who
finished uh at second place both these
players clearly the best performers in
the two days BL and as Fabby said that
he needed a little bit of help from
Maxim because he was in such a good
position at the start of the day with
two extra points a two-point lead uh but
it was uh not meant to be and then we
see Yan pishi and Liam tied for third
Yan pishi gets an additional 7 and a
half Grand Chester points alira finished
fifth the world number one Blitz player
and that just shows how difficult this
WOW field was and uh with this of course
we've got one more event and we've got
wesle so in seventh place and this is
after all of that where we stand with
our grand chest standings Fabiano is not
only really happy with his result of the
St Louis rapid and bits but this puts
him at such a great spot for that
$100,000 bonus at the end of the Season
no question about it 33 grandchester
points that's a whole 11 that is uh
simply that's going to be impossible to
overcome as we have our uh rapid and
Blitz Champion he said it's the first
one he won Peter final thoughts of uh
today's broadcast what can you say it
was fantastic to watch and we also got
exactly the dunon we we we wanted for it
the two best players of the tournament
facing each facing off in the last round
game with everything to play for so uh
from the viewers perspective I think
more or less an ideal tournament to
watch nobody running away with it and a
deserved winner in the end somebody who
played very solidly played very good
chess almost throughout he is I think
understandably critical of his last two
round games but still very very good
tournaments by Fabby and congratulations
to him deserved winner of the St Louis
rapid blit and Anastasia and I deserved
winner of the lunch there yes we were
having a very nice conversation I don't
care you you know you signed up for it
Bobby did it like I said it was you got
it baby you got Tanya it was wonderful
Peter thank you so much it was great and
uh thank you all for joining us don't
forget in two days time uh we will have
the granddaddy of the all the sville cup
we'll look forward to seeing you then in
the meanwhile bye-bye bye bye
[Music]
byebye
a
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited